WE'LL START THE MEETING -- THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS -- WILL OPERATE AS A
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE UNTIL WE
REACH A QUORUM THAT'LL TAKE ROLE --
AND WE LIKE TO SEE ALL THE
MEMBERS COME TO THE MEETING --
WE'RE GONNA -- START THE HEARING
AS A CLEAR THE WHOLE AND THEN
WHEN I SEE MY ONE MORE MEMBER I
WILL TAKE ROLAND.
GOING TO ACTION SO THAT MEANS WE
CAN VOTE ON STUFF FOR A ROLL
CALL.
SO -- WE LIKE PEOPLE TO PLEASE
SO.
TAKE THEIR CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE
TURN OFF CELL PHONES OF COURSE --
AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR A LOT OF
BILLS TODAY SO WE WANT TO LIMIT
OUR TESTIMONY TO TWO WITNESSES
PER SIDE. TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS -- AND WITH THAT I THINK
WAS A COMMUTER HOLE START WITH --
CENTER PORTANTINO -- HE HAS ONE
BILL THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ONE SB.
SEVEN ANSWER YOU OF THE 40%.
THANK YOU -- I HAVE A NUMBER OF
THE LOBBY.
IN EACH CHAPTER -- ONE IF YOU
WILL YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
FOUR OKAY.
ONE EIGHTY YEAH THANK YOU YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AMAZON IN FACT I'LL GIVE THEM A
MINUTE AND A HALF.
SO THEM A LITTLE MORE TIME SINCE
SO.
THIS IS BEEN A SIXTY YEAR
STRUGGLE.
YES YES YOU BROUGHT IN A THANK
YOU. ONE PERSON ARE YOU OF THE
FOR CENTER THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THEY ARE PRESENTING THE SEVEN
WHICH PROHIBITS CALTRANS FROM
CONSTRUCTING A FREEWAY TUNNEL
SURFACE OR EXPRESSWAY.
TUNNEL BETWEEN THE SEVEN TEN I
TEN AND THE TWO TEN FOR THE
SEVEN TEN FREEWAY AS THE CHAIR
AND I JUST TALKED ABOUT.
THIS IS BEEN A SIXTY YEAR
STRUGGLE EARLIER IN THE YEAR
CALTRANS CERTIFIED THE FINAL THE
I. R..
WHICH ESSENTIALLY -- HAS THE
STATE GOING IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION AFTER SEVERAL YEARS OF
COMMUNITY CHARETTE OUTREACH --
AND DISCUSSIONS CALTRANS AND
METRO DETERMINE THAT THE TUNNEL
WAS NOT THE PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE THAT A SERIES OF
LOCAL TRAFFIC IMPROVEMENTS --
WHICH IS CALLED THE TSM.
TSM TDM -- IS THE PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE IN THE FINALLY I
OURS WAS QUITE EXCITING WE HAD
THE CALTRANS -- DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY DOWN IN
THE DISTRICT.
TO HAND OVER THE FINALLY I ARE.
DECLARING AN END TO THE THREAT
OF THE TUNNEL -- THAT'S THE GOOD
NEWS -- WHAT THAT DOES IS IT
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY NOW TO
DISPOSE OF THE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
PARCELS OF LAND?
THAT CALTRANS HAD ACQUIRED OVER
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS WHEN THEY
HAD DESIGNS AND DOING A SURFACE
ROUTEMANY OF THOSE CALTRANS
TENANTS OR A HANDFUL OF THOSE
CALTRANS TENETS ARE NON PROFITS.
AND SO THIS BILL DOES THREE
THINGS HEY IT DELETES THE SEVEN
TEN FROM THE STREETS AND
HIGHWAYS CODE WHICH IS NO LONGER
NEEDED BECAUSE THE I. R..
DETERMINE THAT THE PROJECT WAS
NO LONGER FEASIBLE. TO IT ALLOWS
THOSE LONG STANDING NON PROFITS
TO PURCHASE THERE ARE PROPERTIES
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AT THE CURRENT USE SO FOR
EXAMPLE SEQUOYAH SCHOOL WHICH WE
HAVE TO STUDENTS HERE TO TESTIFY
HAS BEEN OPERATING AS A SCHOOL
FOR HOW MANY YEARS.SIXTY YEARS
AS A TENET OF THIS AREA AND SO
THIS BILL ALLOWS THEM TO
PURCHASE THEIR PROPERTY AT THE
USE FOR A SCHOOL.
NOT FOR THE USE FOR MANSIONS --
RONALD MCDONALD HOUSE HAS BEEN
HELPING FAMILIES IN NEED OF CARE
BECAUSE IT'S ADJACENT TO
HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL. FOR DECADES
AGAIN IT ALLOWS RONALD MCDONALD
HOUSE TO PURCHASE THEIR PROPERTY
FOR THE USE OF A NON PROFIT
HEALTH FACILITY NOT. FOR THE USE
AS A MANSION -- THE ARLINGTON
GARDEN IS A BEAUTIFUL BOTANICAL
GARDEN THAT IS BEEN OPERATING AS
A TENANT FOR MANY MANY YEARS IT
ALLOWS ARLINGTON GARDEN TO
PURCHASE THEIR PROPERTY FOR THE
USES AS A GARDEN.
NOT FOR MANSION SO WE THINK
THAT'S A COMMON SENSE SOLUTION
TO THESE NONPROFITS THAT HAVE
BEEN SERVING THE COMMUNITIES --
SO WONDERFULLY FOR FOR DECADES
AND WE THINK IT'S THE FAIR THING
TO DO THE THIRD THING THE BILL.
DOES IS IT LAYS THE FOUNDATION
FOR ANY DISPOSITION OF THE NO
LONGER NECESSARY FREEWAY STUBS.
BACK TO THE CITIES IN WHICH THEY
ARE IN THAT PIECE OF THE PUZZLE
WE'RE WAITING FOR CALTRANS TO
PROVIDE US.
THE APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE BECAUSE
FROM WHAT CALTRANS IS TOLD ME.
WHETHER WE CALL IT SURPLUS IT'S
ONE SECTION OF GOVERNMENT CODE
ABANDONMENT IS ANOTHER SECTION
OF GOVERNMENT CODE -- WHATEVER
NOMENCLATURE IS USED GOVERNS HOW
ALL THOSE IT IT'S A BIG DISH AND
SO CALTRANS IS INTERNALLY
REVIEWING HEY WHAT'S STUBS ARE
NEEDED. TO MEET THE LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AND BE.
IF THINGS ARE NOT NEEDED HOW WE
CAN FACILITATE GETTING THEM BACK
INTO THE HANDS OF THE CITIES --
THE BILL DOES NOT DEAL WITH ANY
OF THE RIVER FINANCIAL IMPACTS --
METRO IS PROGRAMMING THE DOLLARS
LEFT OVER FROM MEASURE R. IN ANY
DOLLARS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
ALLOCATED.
TOWARDS THE TUNNEL THEY'RE USING
THOSE DOLLARS ON A LOCAL
PLANNING PROCESS BEING
SPEARHEADED BY A SUPERVISOR
CATHY BARKER AND SUPERVISOR
HILDA SOLELY SO THEY'RE WORKING
WITH THE AFFECTED COMMUNITIES.
ON HOW BEST TO USE THE RESOURCES
T..
TO IMPLEMENT THE PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE AND MITIGATE ANY
TRAFFIC CIRCULATION ISSUES.
THAT ARE LINGERING SO THIS
PROJECT THIS BILL DOES NOT DEAL
WITH -- THE DISPOSITION OF THE
FUNDS WE THANK AT ITS NECESSARY
ONCE AND FOR ALL PUTS THE FINAL
STAKE.
IN THE HEART OF THE FREEWAY AND
IS FAIR AND COMPASSIONATE TO THE
NONPROFITS THAT CERTAINLY HAVE
BEEN SERVING THE COMMUNITY SO
WELL AND THEN AS I SAID WE'VE
BEEN WORKING IN CONCERT WITH
CALTRANS.
ON THE APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE FOR
THE DISPOSITION OF THE STOPS AND
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
BY SEPTEMBER WILL COME BACK IN
JANUARY AND DEAL WITH THE STUBS
STAND BUT WE HAVE IT BY
SEPTEMBER.
YOU KNOW AND OF COURSE THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THAT
LANGUAGE AND YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL
WORKING -- IN CONCERT AND I WANT
TO THANK AGAIN THE CHAIRS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL AND WITH THAT
OF I CAN HAVE MY WITNESSES GO
DOWN THE LINE.
AND BE BRIEF.
THANK YOU CENTER APPRECIATE THAT
AND EACH ONE OF YOU HAVE A
MINUTE OUT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH DEVER AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE PASADENA RONALD
MCDONALD HOUSE THE PASADENA
RONALD MCDONALD HOUSE IS A HOME
AWAY FROM HOME. FOR FAMILIES WHO
HAVE CHILDREN WITH SERIOUS AND
LIFE THREATENING ILLNESSES THEY
COME TO PASADENA SEEKING MEDICAL
CARE THAT THEY CANNOT RECEIVE
CLOSER TO HOME.
CHILDREN ARE TREATED AT LOCAL
HOSPITALS FOR LIMB DEFICIENCIES
ORGAN TRANSPLANTS -- ORTHOPEDIC
CONDITIONS CANCER AND BURN SCARS
OUR GOAL IS TO KEEP FAMILIES
pMEDICAL CARE AND CLOSE TO ONE
ANOTHER.
SINCE OPENING IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR WE'VE SERVE MORE THAN
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE HOUSE IS LOCATED AND
CALTRANS HOMES ACROSS THE STREET
FROM HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE RAN OUT A
HUNDRED AND 16% OCCUPANCY AND WE
ARE CONSTANTLY TURNING FAMILIES
AWAY.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TWELVE
BEDROOMS AND ARE ABLE TO HOUSE
NINETEEN FAMILIES AT A TIME THAT
MEANS THAT FAMILIES ARE WILLING
TO DOUBLE UP IN ROOMS TO BE
CLOSE TO THEIR CHILD'S MEDICAL
CARE.
RESEARCH SAYS THAT WE NEED
THIRTY BEDROOMS TO MEET OUR
CURRENT NEED SB SEVEN WILL ALLOW
US TO EXPAND TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF SICK CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MEGAN
FOCUSED ON THE CO CHAIR FOR THE
BOARD OF THE PASSING AROUND THE
DONALD HOUSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
OF FOR ALL OF THE AROUND THE
DONALD HOUSES ACROSS THE WORLD
ARE LOCATION IS MISSION CRITICAL
WE NEED TO BE CLOSE TO OUR
HOSPITAL PARTNERS.
IN PASADENA WE ARE DIRECTLY
ACROSS THE STREET FROM
HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL WHERE SHORT --
WALK AWAY FROM SHRINERS HOSPITAL.
SB SEVEN IT WILL ALLOW US -- TO
IT WILL HELP KEEP THE PURCHASE
PRICE WITHIN REACH FOR US WE
REALLY DO NEED TO BE IN THESE --
PROPERTIES AND WITH THE HELP OF
SB SEVEN WE'LL BE ABLE TO RAISE
THOSE FUNDS TO THE COMMUNITY.
IF WE CAN'T RAISE THE PURCHASE
PRICE FOR THESE PROPERTIES THEY
WILL BE SOLD AND AT THAT POINT
WE WILL HAVE PRIDE HAVE TO LEAVE
PASADENA SO -- ON BEHALF OF THE
PASADENA ROAMING DONALD HOUSE WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALICIA
BARKER VAUGHN AND I AM CURRENTLY
A HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR AT SEQUOIA
SCHOOL.
THE JUNE I'LL BE PART OF THE
FIRST PIONEERING CLASS OF THE
GRADUATING SENIORS AT SEQUOIA I
FEEL INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO HAVE
TEACHERS WHO CHALLENGE ME
INTELLECTUALLY WHILE ALSO GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE WHAT
I LEARNED IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND APPLY IT TO MY COMMUNITY AND
THE WORLD SO WHAT HAS PROVIDED
ME AWAY TO BE A BETTER PERSON
GIVE BACK TO MY COMMUNITY.
AND OPEN THE DOORS OF BUSINESS
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE TO ME AT SUCH
A YOUNG AGE.
AFTER BEING PLACED IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM I'D ALWAYS WANTED TO
CHANGE TO HELP CHANGE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT WERE OFFERED TO
THE CHILDREN IN THE SYSTEM.
THROUGH THE SOCIAL INNOVATION
PROGRAM THAT'S A QUIZ HIGH
SCHOOL I WAS PROVIDED A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP CHANGE THE
LIVES OF FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
PASSING A UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THROUGH MY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS MARK YOUR FUTURE
RUNNING I'M SORRY I'M RUNNING A
NONPROFIT AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN HAS ALLOWED ME TO WORK
ONE ON ONE WITH KIDS THAT HAVE
BEEN THROUGH SIMILAR EXPERIENCES
AS ME.
THIS WOULD NOT HAVE OTHERWISE
HAPPENED HAD I NOT GONE TO
SEQUOIA I WILL NEVER FORGET MY
HIGH SCHOOL YEARS AT SEQUOIA.
WHEN I LEAVE FOR FOR FOR COLLEGE
NEXT FALL I WILL BE TAKING WITH
ME THE VALUES OF THE KOREA AND
ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE STUDENT
BODY?
THANK YOU FOR SECURING THE
FUTURE OF OUR SCHOOL WITH THE
SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DASCHLE GALLON AND I'M A FIFTH
GRADER AT SCHOOL AND SCHOOL IN
PASADENA MY SCHOOL IS A SPECIAL
PLACE BECAUSE WE LEARN BY DOING.
I HAVE ATTENDED SCHOOL IS SINCE
KINDERGARTEN AGE OF MY TEACHERS
TAUGHT A WIDE SUPPORT TO SPEAK
UP AND BE AN ACTIVE CITIZEN IN
YOUR COMMUNITY.
I FEEL THANKFUL TO BE PART OF
THE SCHOOL THAT LET ME PUT Y.
LEARNING TO ACTION BY COMING TO
SACRAMENTO TO TESTIFY BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
AT SCHOOL WHERE WE CELEBRATE
MOREABOUT HUMAN DIGNITY ON A
LOCAL AND GLOBAL LEVEL.
THIS YEAR FOR EXAMPLE WE STUDIED
THE POLICY TO LEGALIZE STREET
MANY IN LOS ANGELES AND THE
RIGHTS OF VENDORS TO WORK
LEGALLY WITHOUT FEAR OR HER
ASMAN.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE SEVENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE UNIVERSAL
DECLARATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS.
MY CLASSMATES AND I RESEARCHED
AND ANALYZE THE FIRST
INTERNATIONAL DOCUMENT SIGNED BY
UNITED NATIONS RECOGNIZING OUR
INALIENABLE RIGHTS AS HUMAN
BEINGS.
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN WOULD
SECURE FUTURE FOR MY SCHOOL SO
THAT MORE STUDENTS.
CAN BENEFIT FROM AN EDUCATION
THAT CHALLENGES THE MIND
SEARCHERS THE HEART AND SOUL
RIGHT TO INDIGNITY THANK YOU.
OF ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR
OF THE THIS -- BILL SB -- SEVEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHECK YOUR
ROSS ON BEHALF THE CITY'S A
PASADENA AND SOUTH PASADENA BOTH
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GREAT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RENEE DICK WILSON I'M
A RESIDENT OF THE DISTRICT AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANKS.
MARIN PM WE HAVE THE CITY OF A
HAMMER OUT WELL WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT POSITION RIGHT THANK THE
SENATOR FOR CONTINUED TO WORK
WITH US.
AS A WE'VE BEEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE A NUMBER OF TIMES
BEFORE SO WE LOOK TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU.
SO THAT THE CITY OF A HAMMER
ALSO REDUCES TRAFFIC ON THE
STREETS WHICH IS MUCH MUCH
NEEDED THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
OUR OWN.
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR IF NOT --
QUICK CALL THE WITNESSES
OPPOSING THE BILL.
OR HAVE QUESTIONS ANYBODY.
OPPOSING THE BILL -- NOT NINE
SEEN -- QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE.
DOES THE WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
JUST A REMINDER RUBIO -- THE FOR
THANK YOU JUST A REALLY BRIEF
COMMENT -- FIRST WANTED THINK
THE FIFTH GRADER IN ALL I TAUGHT
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS AND ALWAYS.
MAKES ME REALLY HAPPY TO SEE
COURAGEOUS YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
LIKE YOU JUST COME UP AND TO
HAVE THE COURAGE TO SPEAK IN
FRONT OF IT ALSO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT -- I ALSO REPRESENT
ALL HAMBRE AND SOME OTHER --
SURROUNDING AREAS AND DOWN I AM
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE SURPLUS
NON RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES BEING
ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW I HAVE A A BETTER
USE AND AND GIVE YOU GUYS A
PEACE OF MIND THAT YOU CAN
PURCHASE SAID -- I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE STOPS BUT I
ALREADY SPOKE WITH THE THE
AUTHOR AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING -- WITH CALTRANS TO TRY
AND RESOLVE THAT AND SO WITH
THAT.
I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS NO OF SUPPORT TO
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT HAS
BEEN DECIDED CORRECT AND AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY -- YOUR APPROACH TO
THIS ENTIRE ISSUE IS HAS BEEN TO
LET THE I RB CERTIFIED.
AND YOU KNOW WE MADE THAT
COMMITMENT TO YEARS AGO TO YOU
AND YOU KNOW WE'VE ALL.
I THINK CALTRANS TRADITIONAL
ADVERSARIES EVERYBODY HAS SORT
OF ALLOW THE PROCESS TO PROCEED.
AND I THINK YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THAT -- HAS IS TO BE COMMENDED.
AND I JUST WANNA -- STATE THAT --
SINCE THE TRANSPORTATION --
DEMAND MANAGEMENT -- ALTERNATIVE
IS NOW THE LOCALLY DECIDED UPON.
AGREED UPON BY A BY THE ELECTED
BODIES AND SO FORTH.
ALTERNATIVE -- THIRD PLANNING TO
USE SOME OF THE MEASURE ARE
ANOTHER FUNDS AND WE'RE BECAUSE
THIS IS A DIFFERENT AND HAVING --
PLAN AHEAD OF FREEWAY WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO WORK HARD NOT
ONLY AT THE LA COUNTY LEVEL BUT
THE STATE LEVEL. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE TIAS CM.
TDM ALTERNATIVE IS SUCCESSFUL
FOR ALL THE NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE
AREA INCLUDING -- CIVIC CENTER
RUBIO'S DISTRICT AS WELL.
SO WE'RE WE'RE COMMITTED TO THAT
HERE AND WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A A GOOD PLACE
TO LIVE FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE OF
OF YOUR COMMUNITY AS WELL THANK
YOU FOR COMING BY THE WAY. TO
OUR COMMITTEE -- AND WE NOW HAVE
A QUORUM SO TAKE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
THERE ABOUT YOUR BELL PRESENT
BATES -- BATES PRESENT DODD.
DODD PRESENT GALGIANI GALGIANI
PRESENT MCGUIRE MORALE ROSS
RUBIO.
RUBIO PRESENT SKINNER STONE
STONE PRESENT AMBERG FORECASTING
CASSIE PRESENT.
THE BILL.
WE ARE MOTION FOR THE BILL --%
AND WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THANK CHAIRMAN MAY I SAY ONE
MORE THING ROOF YES SIR SAME
KEYWORD TâM.
I'VE BEEN ASKED BY SEVERAL
PEOPLE WHY I WAITED TO MY THIRTY
YEAR TO INTRODUCE THIS BILL.
AND WHILE THE FOR THE FACT.
WHAT?
IN THE SENATE YEAH.
IN THE ASSEMBLY DIFFERENT STORY
THAT WAS A DECADE AGO SO.
THIS COAT THIS GO AROUND -- AND
THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE IS THE
CHAIR AND I REFERENCED EARLIER.
YOU KNOW.
THE DEAL THAT WAS.
DISCUSSED WAS TO ALLOW THE AYE
ARE TO BE CERTIFIED.
AND SO THAT GAVE THE IMPRIMATUR
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND SORT
OF THE TAKE THE CONTROVERSY OUT
OF THE ISSUE.
AND SO THAT WAS THE COMMITMENT I
MADE BACK IN DECEMBER. TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND SO TODAY IS
A FOLLOW AT FOLLOW UP ON THAT
COMMITMENT AND YOU KNOW THE
CHAIRS LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN PART
OF IT AS WELL SO I RESPCTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
A THANK YOU -- CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
SENATE BILL SEVEN BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER ABOUT BY
WELL I BATES RIGHT BATES AYE
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE MORALE ROSS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STONE STONE I
AM BURKE WILL CASKEY BECAUSE HE
AYE. SEVEN ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU EVERYBODY.
OKAY -- MEMBERS -- WILL CAN WE
MOVE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON
THE AGENDA TODAY.
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- IT
CONSISTED OF ITEM -- THREE
WITCHES SETTERS STERN'S BILL SB.
ONE FORTY CENTER MINING'S BILL.
SB.
FIVE OH FOUR SIR COVER HEROES
BILL SB -- SIX TWENTY EIGHT
CENTER CHANG'S BILL -- SIX FORTY
EIGHT ANSWER GALGIANI IS BILL.
SIX EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
DISCUSSION ON A THOSE BILLS.
OKAY BUT NOT ME WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE AND THE CONSENT COUNCIL
CALENDAR SENATOR ABOUT BY WELL I
BATES HI BATES AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
ROCKS.
RUBIO.
SKINNER STONE.
STONE AYE AMBERG CASKEY WE GOT
THE ICE.
OKAY THANK YOU -- THAT POSSIBLY
THE ROLE OF BROWN'S AND MEMBERS --
WILL NEXT -- MOVED TO CENTER
ALLEN HIS TWO BILLS SB.
FIFTY NINE AND SB FIVE TWENTY
SIX CENTER.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR WHICH I KNOW
YOU LIKE TO TAKE UP FIRST I
LET'S DO FIFTY NINE TO SINCE THE
OKAY WE ARE IN FILE ORDER --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND OBVIOUSLY I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ITS WORK.
ON THIS MEASURE AT THIS HAS TO
DO WITH AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
HI THE INTRODUCTION OF
AUTONOMOUS PASSENGER VEHICLES
ONTO OUR ROADS AND WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES REALLY DOES HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO REVOLUTIONIZE.
HOW WE GET AROUND AND RECEIVE
OUR COMMUNITIES?
NOW WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT HOW THE BY THE GREAT
PROMISES THAT -- THE THAT THIS
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY MAY BRING
I MEAN ME DRASTICALLY REDUCE
COLLISIONS.
ENHANCE TRAFFIC FLOW THAT'S VERY
PROMISING -- BUT IF NOT
THOUGHTFULLY DESPITE DEPLOYED
THIS NEW MOBILITY REVOLUTION
COULD ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
NEGATIVE IMPACTS INCLUDING
EXACERBATING CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY.
SEVERE CLIMATE AIR QUALITY
PLANNING AND CONGESTION
CHALLENGES SO IT'S REALLY GONNA
COME DOWN TO HOW WE IMPLEMENT --
OVER HOW WE WITH THE SERVER THE
THE THE THOUGHT THAT WE PUT INTO.
THE INTRODUCTION OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY ONTO OUR ROADS.
I SEVERAL RECENT STUDIES HAVE
FOUND THAT BECAUSE A VIS MAKE
TRAVEL LESS ONEROUS.
THEIR WIDESPREAD ADOPTION COULD
ACTUALLY -- END UP INCREASING
VEHICLE TRAVEL BY 15260%.
IN AN EXPERIMENT CONDUCTED BY UC
DAVIS UC BERKELEY AND GEORGIA
TECH MIMICS LIFE WITH THE NAVY
BY PROVIDING EACH PARTICIPATING
HOUSEHOLD.
WITH THE SHOW FOR AN EXPERIMENT
SO I HOUSEHOLDS TRAVEL YOU 3%
MORE MILES PER WEEK WITH MORE
THAN A FIFTH OF THE VEHICLE
TRIPS.
SENATE CARRYING NO PASSENGERS AT
ALL.
BUT YOU JUST HAVE THE THE CARS
CIRCULATING.
SO THESE FINDINGS INDICATE THAT
AV'S COULD ENCOURAGE CONSUMERS
TO DRIVE MORE FREQUENTLY COMMUTE
LONGER DISTANCES USE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION LAST.
THUS INCREASING SPRAWL
CONGESTION AND POLLUTION.
INSTEAD THESE IMPACTS COULD BE
AVOIDED IF THE STATE FINDS WAYS
TO ENCOURAGE RIDE SHARING
MINIMIZING ZERO OR PASSING A
PASSENGER TRIPS.
AND QUICKLY MOVE FORWARD TOWARD
ELECTRIFYING THE FLEET.
SO THESE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE FLOATING OUT THERE IN
THIS CONVERSATION I I WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE A GOOD WAY OF KNOWING
HOW IT IS THAT.
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY MAY IMPACT I
PRESENT IT'S KIND OF A WORST
CASE SCENARIO BUT I THINK IT'S
WORTH.
OUR OUR SPENDING SOME TIME
CONTEMPLATING THAT AND AND AND
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR US TO REALLY STUDY AND GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF OF THIS.
POTENTIALLY REVOLUTIONARY CHANGE
TO THE WAY THAT WE GET AROUND A
PLANNED INCREASE OUR CITY SAID
THIS BILL SB FIFTY NINE CREATES.
AN INTERAGENCY WORKING GROUP. TO
DELIBERATELY PLANNED FOR A
THOMAS VEHICLES IN A WAY THAT
SUPPORTS THE STATE'S PLANNING
CLIMATE AND SUSTAINABILITY GOALS
WITH THE MIND TOWARD AVOIDING.
POTENTIAL A NEGATIVE IMPACTS
VERTICALLY THE TRANSPORTATION
SPACE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING INDUSTRY
GROUPS AUTOMAKERS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS TO REFINE THE
MEASURE TO INSURE THAT WE
DELIVER REALLY PLAN WILL NOT
SIGN ME -- THIS THIS INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGY AND SO I'M VERY
COMMITTED TO WORKING CLOSELY
WITH -- STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AS
THE BILL PROCEEDS.
I KNOW THAT WE SAW SOME MORE
WORK TO DRESS CONCERNS AT THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED A CONVERSATIONS
OF AN VERY PRODUCTIVE.
AND I HAVE WITH ME JASON FROM
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS ALSO RIGHT. TO CHARGE
FROM CAL START -- THEY'RE GONNA
BOTH SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
IN FAVOR PLEASE SHOW THE FLOOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CHASIN BARB US WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND JUST
BRIEFLY YOU BUILD ON THAT
PRESENTATION CENTER ALLEN JUST
MADE.
ABOUT HOW THE ADVENT OF SELF
DRIVING CARS COULD POSE EITHER
BENEFITS OR RISKS TO OUR CLIMATE.
AND WHY THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
ACT SAID TO STEER THE TECHNOLOGY
IN A CLIMATE SMART DIRECTION.
MANY RESEARCHERS ARE ARE
ANALYZING THIS ISSUE AND AND HOW
SELF DRIVING CARS COULD IMPACT
TRAVEL AND CONGESTION.
AND ACCESSIBILITY I AM POLLUTION
AND IT'S PROVIDING IMPORT
INSIGHTS INTO HOW -- THE ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FOR BUILDING A
MODERN TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM BUT
ALSO THE SIGNIFICANT RISKS OF
INACTION.
AND SO YOU KNOW THE POSITIVE
VISION THAT WE ASPIRE TO FOR
SUSTAINABILITY IS ONE IN WHICH A
VIS -- ARE PAIRED WITH ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WHICH HAVE LOWER CARBON
EMISSIONS WHILE ALSO USHERING IN
A NEW WAVE OF TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES THINK.
UBER AND LIFT TWO POINT NO WHERE
SHARED RIDER MORE CONVENIENT AN
INDIVIDUAL COULD VEHICLE
OWNERSHIP IN OUR COST
COMPETITIVE.
AND WHEN WHEN COMBINED WITH
INCREASED ACCESS TO MOBILITY
OPTIONS LIKE SHARED BIKES AND
SHARE SCOOTERS AND EFFICIENT
MASS TRANSIT AS WELL AS SAFER
STREETS.
INDIVIDUALS COULD CHOOSE FROM A
WIDER VARIETY OF OPTIONS FOR
EACH TRIP RATHER THAN ALWAYS
DEFAULTING TO THE CAR FORMALLY
PARKED IN THEIR DRIVEWAY.
SO THAT'S THAT'S A POSITIVE
VISION THAT WE'RE SHOOTING FOR
AND THAT WOULD BE LOWERING
EMISSIONS LOWERING VEHICLE
TRAVEL -- BUT THERE'S MUCH TO BE
CONCERNED IN TERMS OF THIS
WEATHER THIS OUTCOME WILL RESULT
WITHOUT PUBLIC POLICY TO TO
STEER.
ANSWER JUST BRIEFLY A COUPLE OF
THE RISKS OF THAT -- RESEARCH
HAS HAS UNCOVERED ONE IS THAT
EIGHTIES COULD DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE DRIVING.
SO IF EIGHTIES PRIMARILY ENABLE
INCREASE SINGLE OCCUPANCY
VEHICLE TRIPS WE ARE CERTAINLY
IN TROUBLE BECAUSE WE ARE ONE OF
THE THE WIDELY CITED STUDIES
FROM RESEARCHERS FROM A NUMBER
OF THE PARTNERSHIP FROM THREE
DIFFERENT UNIVERSITIES.
FOUND -- THEY LOOKED AT THE THE
IMPACT ON TRAVEL BEHAVIOR IN
CARBON EMISSIONS A WHOLE NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT WOULD
COME FROM FROM THE ADVENT OF THE
TIME IS VEHICLES IN THE SINGLE
LARGEST.
INCREASE IN EMISSIONS AND ENERGY
USE.
CAME FROM BEHAVIORAL RESPONSE SO
CENTER ALLEN TO REFER TO THIS
ALREADY BUT YOU KNOW DRIVING CAN
NOW BE A PRODUCTIVE TIME.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT BEHIND THE
WHEEL COMMANDING THE VEHICLE
THEN LONGER COMMUTES FOR EGGS
FOR INSTANCE -- MAY NOT BE THE
BURDEN THAT THEY ONCE WERE -- IN
THIS STUDY FOUND A VIS COULD
INCREASE VEHICLE TRAVEL -- BY
60%.
HOPEFULLY NOT LIKE THE GUY THAT
FELL ASLEEP IN.
YEAH I AREAS THAT WAS ON HIGHWAY
ONE I WANT TO SLEEP IN HONEST AS
LOW AS IT WAS GOING. SIXTY FIVE
MILES AN HOUR.
THAT WAS NOT.
TO I WAS I DON'T NEED THAT. ONE
OF THAT ONE OF THE SECOND RISKS
IS THAT PEOPLE WILL NOT END UP
SHARING RIDES IN SELF DRIVING
VEHICLES IN THAT MORE ALL OVER
THEY PULL PEOPLE FROM TRANSIT.
WHICH AFTER ALL IS THE ORIGINAL
POOL DRIED.
AND AND SO -- IS SIMILARLY
RESEARCH THERE AS ALSO LOOK AT
HOW EVEN IF WE HAVE.
SELF DRIVING CARS AND THEIR
ELECTRIC CARS IF WE ARE PULLING
RIDES ARE STILL GONNA NOT BE
REACHING OUR OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
AND A FINAL RISK THAT I'LL I'LL
MENTION IS IS AV'S COULD
EXACERBATE A PERPETUATE
INEQUITIES IN OUR COUNTRY
EXPECTATIONS SYSTEM SO.
YOU KNOW OUR OUR CURRENT CAR
OWNERSHIP BASED TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM DOES NOT SERVE ALL
COMMUNITIES IN AN EQUITABLE WAY.
AN EIGHTIES COULD IMPROVE
MOBILITY FOR COMMUNITIES
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED BY
CURRENT TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
FOR THE CURRENT INEQUITIES COULD
BE EXACERBATED IN FOR EXAMPLE MY
ORGANIZATION.
RECENTLY MODEL SEVERAL SCENARIOS
OF THE EFFECTS OF SELF DRIVING
CARS IN THE WASHINGTON DC
METROPOLITAN AREA.
AND FOUND THE PEOPLE LIVING IN
LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
EXPERIENCED FORTY SEVEN TIMES AS
MUCH CONGESTED DRIVING IS THE
REGIONAL AVERAGE I IN THAT
ANALYSIS.
SO JUST TO SUMMARIZE I THINK THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL -- IN ONE
SENSE OF DATES THAT EIGHTIES MAY
BE ABLE TO DRIVE THEMSELVES.
BUT IT'S UP TO THE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO STEER THEM IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND SB FIFTY
NINE TAKES IMPORTANT STEP IN
STRANGE TECHNOLOGY AS A SAMPLING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON A RARE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M RANGE YOU
ARE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CAL
START WERE A TECHNOLOGY
CONSORTIUM THIS BEEN WORKING FOR
THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO
ACCELERATE THE GROWTH OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY JOBS
INVESTMENT.
AS YOU'VE HEARD WHETHER
CALIFORNIA'S READY OR NOT
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ARE A THESE
ARE HERE AND THEY'RE POISED TO
TRANSFORM THE STATE'S ENTIRE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND THE
WAY THEY CALIFORNIANS USE IT.
AND WE'RE ENCOURAGED BY A VIS.
THE TECHNOLOGY COULD SPEED THE
GROWTH ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
THE COULD ENCOURAGE CARPOOLING
GIVE NEW TOOLS TO TRANSIT
AGENCIES -- AND REDUCE ACCIDENTS
THERE MOSTLY CAUSED BY DRIVER
ERROR.
BUT AS YOU HAVE ALSO HEARD SINCE
IT IS A NEW TECHNOLOGY WE'RE
JUST GUESSING AT THE FUTURE AND
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT EXACTLY IS
COMING.
OTHER THAN THAT THE EFFECTS OF A
DRIVERLESS FUTURE WILL BE
PROFOUND AND WILL BE COMPLEX.
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS INDUSTRY
EXPERTS AND PUBLIC OFFICIALS ARE
ALL TRYING TO COME TO GRIPS WITH
THIS AND DEVELOP A CLEAR VIEW
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF AV'S.
ON BOTH THE BENEFITS AND THE
CONCERNS MUCH LIKE THIS
COMMITTED WITH THE HEARING ON
THE SUBJECT LAST YEAR.
SO THERE ARE STILL SOME MORE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS HOW HOW
LADIES -- EFFECTIVE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED IN LAND USE HELLO
LADIES AFFECT INDIVIDUALS USE OF
ALTERNATIVE MODES PARTICULAR
PUBLIC TRANSIT BICYCLING AND
OTHER ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION --
HOW CAN WE PROMOTE SHARED
PASSENGER MOBILITY AND ON
BALANCE WILL A THESE HELP OR
HINDER CALIFORNIAN ACHIEVING ITS
CLIMATE GOALS?
WE WANT TO GIVE AB TECHNOLOGY
THE BEST CHANCE IT HAS TO CREATE
THE MOST BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND SUCCEED IN THE
LONG RUN.
SB FIFTY NINE WILL HELP CREATE A
CONSENSUS VIEW ACROSS AGENCIES
IN THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT WHAT
THE KEY ISSUES AND GOALS ARE FOR
THIS DISRUPTIVE TECHNOLOGY AND
WHAT THEY NEED TO BE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE BELIEVE IN THAT
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE TASK FORCE IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY -- TO
CREATE SUCH AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AT THANK YOU SENATORS JOSH WAS
STARK ON BEHALF OF TRANSFORM IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WILL BE AIRED AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEDI BAKER
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE WE
HAVEN'T TAKEN A FORMAL POSITION
ON THIS BILL BUT WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL ON CONTENT.
THE NET MANTEGNA'S NGUYEN BERMAN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF BILL
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY ARM. TO HAVE SPEAKERS
OPPOSING THE BILL PLEASE COME.
FOR OF ONE CHIU LETTER C.
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
MR TURN MEMBERS COURTNEY JENSEN
ON BEHALF OF TECH THAT -- WE ARE
IN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION I FIRST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAFF FOR THEIR GREAT WORK ON
THE BILL SO FAR WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ON THAT WENT INTO THE
BILL OF REFLECT A LOT OF OUR
CONCERNS -- BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
MOVING FORWARD AND SO WE REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
TO CONTINUE OUR WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE AUTHORS OFFICE IN
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
I'M GENERALLY TECH THAT'S
APPROACH SHOULD -- THOMAS
VEHICLE LEGISLATION IS MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
THIS TECHNOLOGY IS STILL
DEVELOPING WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT STIFLING.
THIS INNOVATION -- AND THAT THE
BENEFITS AND POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
COMES WHEN THERE'S WIDESPREAD
DEPLOYMENT OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
WE'RE NOT THERE YET AS MUCH AS I
WOULDLIKE TO NOT DRIVE A CAR
TOMORROW.
WE'VE GOT AWHILE TO GO BEFORE WE
GET THERE -- SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ADDS CALIFORNIA LOOKS
DOWN THE LINE FOR THIS
TECHNOLOGY IN THE WIDESPREAD
DEPLOYMENT OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
THERE WERE AVOIDING POLICY IS --
THAT COULD STIFLE THE INNOVATION
OF THIS TYPE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
THAT WOULD MAKE IT SAFER THEY
WOULD MEET YOU KNOW GET CLOSER
TO CALIFORNIA'S -- GREENHOUSE
SCHOOL GAS EMISSIONS GOALS AND
ALL THOSE KIND OF THINGS WE
DON'T WANT TO WE DON'T WANT TO
STIFLE THIS TECHNOLOGY -- BUT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
DOLLARS OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THIS WORKING GROUP AND
PROVIDE THEM SOME GUIDING
PRINCIPLES THAT ARE APPROPRIATE
FOR WHERE THE TECHNOLOGY IS AT
TODAY AND WHERE WE WANTED TO BE
IN THE FUTURE.
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT.
OF OTHERS SPEAKERS OPPOSING --
DISCUSSION -- COMMITTEE.
I A I A I A I HAD A QUESTION ON
THIS -- I NOTICED THAT THE MULTI
MODAL -- ASPECT IS GOING TO BE
LOOKED INTO BY THE TASK FORCE --
I THINK THE AREA THAT I'M
SPECIFICALLY INTERESTED IN IS.
HOW THE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES?
COULD AID AND OR HOW THEY WOULD
AFFECT PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS.
OF THE BUS SYSTEM WILL IT
REPLACE THE BUSES.
ON CERTAIN ROUTES.
A IS THERE A POTENTIAL FOR THAT
OR WILL IT ENHANCE -- OTHER --
TRANSIT -- TRANSIT SYSTEMS LIKE
A HEAVY RAIL OR OTHER KINDS OF
TRANSIT -- SO WILL REPLACE IN
OFFER REPLACES.
BUSES -- ON CERTAIN ROUTES OR IN
CERTAIN AREAS.
OF HOW IT WAS IMPLICATIONS OF
THAT IN TERMS OF LAND USE
PLANNING FOR EXAMPLE I MEAN THE
SIR ALLAN JOB I KNOW YOU PUT IT
IS ONE OF THE GOALS.
BUT I WANTED.
TO ASK YOU ABOUT -- DATA MISTER
CHAIR THAT I MEAN THAT THAT'S A
THAT'S A PERFECT.
EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF OF REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION.
THAT WE NEED TO BE SPENDING TIME
LOOKING AT AND THAT'S WHAT.
WE'RE LOOKING TO TO EXAMINE HI
THERE JUST SO MANY UNCERTAINTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ROLL OUT.
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY WHICH COULD
BE INCREDIBLY PROMISING I MEAN I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WE WERE
I GUESS THE POINT HERE IS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT.
IT REALLY DOES SERVE -- THE
NEEDS OF OUR SOCIETY AND AND AND
AND BECOME SOMETHING IT BECOMES
IMMENSELY POPULAR AND SUCCESSFUL
AND SAFE AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY AND AND ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT IT PROMISES TO DO --
AND AND NOT SEE THAT THAT
QUESTION OF MULTI MODAL AND
WOULD WOULD BE ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE CENTRAL QUESTIONS
BEING ASKED BY -- BY THE BY THE
OFFICE -- SO. TO THE EXPERTS
HAVE ANY OPINION ABOUT THE DO
YOU THINK IT WILL HAVE AN IMPACT
ON BUS ROUND SERVER -- TRANSIT
IN SOME WAY HOW WOULD IT AFFECT
TRANSIT.
SYSTEMS DAVIS WELL IT YOU KNOW-IT'S NOT CONCLUSIVE AT THIS
POINT BUT I THINK THE YOU KNOW
THE RESEARCH IS OUT THERE --
RAISES THE EXACT SAME CONCERNS
THAT YOU HAVE AND THEN THERE'S
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT A THAT
EITHER OUTCOME -- IS POSSIBLE
AND AND PROBABLY WILL TAKE IT'LL
TAKE MORE CONSIDERATION OF WHAT
WOULD BE THE POLICY LEVERS AND
TOOLS THAT STATE AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS MIGHT HAVE. TO
ENSURE THE BEST OUTCOME THERE
WILL WE HAVE HEALTHY TRANSIT --
THAT'S COMPLIMENTING THE USE OF
OF SELF DRIVING CARS -- YOU KNOW
PART OF THE ESPY ONE WAS TO DO --
CERRONE WAS TO DO -- RESEARCH WE
pYEAR AND SB ONE FOR RESEARCH.
IF WE ASK THE UNIVERSITY --
RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS TO CENSOR
TASK FORCE WOULD THAT BE
IMMENSELY HELPFUL AND I AND I
LOVE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW THE UC
DAVIS INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES.
WORKS ON THIS YET EVEN LOOKING
THEIR VERY INTO THIS BILL AND
ARE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROMISE THAT COULD BRING BUT
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT QUESTION
AND WE WILL BRING THE PROFESSORS
FROM THERE YOU KNOW.
DEAR AND HAVE YOU HAVE A SOUL
DIALOGUE WITH THEM IN.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL OF ALL SEE IF
I CAN INCLUDE AND ARE REQUESTED
RESEARCH THERE'S A WORK WITH
YOUR OFFICE ON ON THE BACK OF
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THIS
ARE THE QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS SENATORS SKINNER.
CENTER BATES YOU WANT ME TO
MOTIONS -- SKINNER.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- I AM
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY AND A I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I HAD A BILL THAT WAS SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR [inaudible]
THE MY FIRST YEAR IN THE SENATE --
THAT WAS RECOGNIZING THE FACT
THAT -- MANY INDUSTRIES NOT TO
SEND ST SPORTS NOT MANY
AUTOMAKERS AND OTHER ENTITIES
ARE LOOKING VERY STRONGLY AT
MOVING.
TOWARDS AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AS A
DOMINANT OF OF VEHICLE ON OUR
ROADS AND WE WANT TO BE I THINK
THE STATE WANTS TO BE PREPARED
RATHER THAN GETTING A SITUATION
LIKE WE HAVE SO MANY TIMES WHERE.
EITHER A NEW TECHNOLOGY OR NEW
PRACTICE IS ALREADY FLOODED US
AND THEN WE'RE TRYING TO
REGULATE.
THAT WE THINK IN ADVANCE WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
MIGHT BE ANTICIPATED BESIDES
SAFETY.
THAT WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING AS
THESE AT ARMS VEHICLES ROLL OUT
AND I THINK SUCH TASK FORCE
SO SO THANK YOU.
OUR CENTER BATES.
THANK YOU ARE.
SENATOR BAIL QUESTION FOR YOU
SENATOR ALLEN I'M JUST LOOKING
OUT WHO WOULD SERVE ON THE ON
THE TASK FORCE OF THE STUDY
GROUP THING YOU DON'T SHOW THAT
WE HAVE ANY FOR ANYONE FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND I THINK SAFETY -- IS THERE
IS A HUGE ISSUE WITH REGARDS TO
THE AUTOMATION.
SO I WOULD HOPE YOU'D CONSIDER --
SOMEONE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
PARTICULAR THE HIGHWAY PATROL IT
WAS MENTIONED IN OUR ANALYSIS AS
A THIS WOULD BE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
YEAH I I THINK YOU'RE -- I THINK
JUST IT THAT'S NOT A BAD IDEA
AND ANY AYE AND I'M ABSOLUTELY
HAPPY -- TO CONSIDER I DON'T
JUST MEAN THAT IN THE WAY THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE SAY THAT AND THEN
THEY DON'T MEAN IT.
REALLY CONSIDERI I ACTUALLY
THINK IT'S I JUST WROTE DOWN HE
REALLY MEANS IT I I I I I I
THINK.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA THE THE
REASON WHY IT WASN'T IN
ORIGINALLY IS THAT THIS IS.
NOT -- DID DID THERE THE THE WE
WERE TRYING TO FILL THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF WORK ON THE SAFETY SIDE.
HI AND AND WE'RE TRYING TO FILL
A GAP.
BASICALLY EVERYTHING ELSE
INVOLVING A VISA IS NOT REALLY
BEEN OUT OF A LOOK AT AND I'LL
BE SAD.
IF THE THE INCLUDING LOT FORCE
IS NOT JUST A FIFTIES RIGHT ALSO
ABOUT TRAFFIC FLOW IT'S ABOUT.
CULPABILITY LIABILITY -- TICKETS
YOU KNOW I MEAN ALL THAT SO I I
AM TALKING MYSELF INTO I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA.
AND WE HAVE A YOU HAVE A A SLOT
ON YOUR COMMITTEE FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WE DO
WHICH INCLUDES THE CH WE DO SO
THE LEADER OF THAT ARE THAT
MIGHT BE THE PLACE TO DO IT.
BUT I I I THINK WE WOULD BE I
THINK WILL BE A GOOD IDEA TO
HAVE SINCE I I'D SAY THAT
BECAUSE SERVING AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE VEHICLE CODE IS
HUGE IN TERMS OF HOW YOU SET
SPEED LIMITS SOBS.
WHERE ALL OF THAT AND IT'S AGO
IF THIS COMES TO PASS YOU HAVE A
VEHICLE CODE THAT IS GOING TO BE
TOTALLY [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
THE ANGER MOOT NO I'VE STALINIST
ART.
WILL BE GOOD IDEA TO HAVE THEM
INVOLVED AND HOW THAT MIGHT BE
RIGHT NOW LOOKED AT IN THE IN
THE CONCEPT.
OUR CONTACT THEM ALL OF THIS
YEAH.
IT MAKES LICENSE OKAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- SURGERY CLOSING
REMARKS I'D APPRECIATE
DISCUSSION APPRECIATE THE OPEN
AS I I YOU KNOW I I WE'VE
ALREADY -- THEY THOUGHT MORE
THAN HALF OF WHAT WAS IN THE
TECHNO LETTERS ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED NOW -- BUT WE'RE GONNA
KEEP WORKING TOGETHER I I THINK
THIS ULTIMATELY IS ABOUT.
MAKING IT WORK FOR EVERYBODY IN
AND AND ABSOLUTELY MEET THE
GOALS OF OF THE INDUSTRY WHICH
ARE TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS A
I TECHNOLOGY THAT ACTUALLY HELPS
TO MAKE OUR SITE BETTER.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT FILLS THE THE PROMISE OF
SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
FRIENDLINESS AND AND AND AND
GOOD PLANNING AND AND CONGESTION
RELIEF AND AND CREATING AT THE
CITIES THAT WILL ACTUALLY
FUNCTION BETTER.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE I THINK THIS WILL
HELP TO MOVE US IN THAT
DIRECTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR I THINK I
THINK THIS WILL BE A VERY
FRUITFUL EXERCISE AND WILL TRY
TO ASSIST THE RESEARCH ON THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE BEST WE
CAN -- WE HAVE A MOTION IN FAVOR
WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE ON THE
MOTION.
SENATE BILL FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
SENATOR WELL I WELL I BATES
RIGHT BATES AYE DODD
[inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MORALE [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I WILL CASKEY BECAUSE HE
AYE [inaudible]
DODD AYE. THIRTY DODD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE HAVE A VOTE IN FAVOR OF
CENTER WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY.
ITEM -- ELEVEN SB -- FIVE TWENTY
SIX REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS.
CENTER YOU CAN PRESENT ON THIS
BILL PLEASE THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AND AN OBVIOUSLY
THAT THAT ANOTHER THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFFERS SPENDING
TIME IN THIS BILL AND ALSO FOR
GIVING STAKEHOLDERS WE HAD A
MEETING IN RANDY'S VERY CRAMPED
OFFICE.
IT WAS ONLY CRAP BECAUSE THERE
WERE SO MANY PEOPLE IN THE ROOM --
BUT I I THINK IS A VERY FRUITFUL
DISCUSSION AND APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK LOOK I WAS IN THERE YEAH IT
WAS.
ALL RIGHT SO.
SO -- WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE FIND
A WAY TO EFFECTIVELY REDUCE --
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
POLLUTION ASSOCIATED WITH LAND
USE AND TRANSPORTATION SECTOR --
BUT YOU KNOW THERE REALLY HAS
BEEN A TOUGH NUT TO CRACK IN A I
DO APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEES
ENGAGEMENT MISS.
IN THIS AREA SO -- HI BUT WE ARE
WE ARE PREPARED TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS -- THAT ARE OFFERED
BY THE COMMITTEE AND YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THE SENSITIVITY THE
COMMITTEE IS BROUGHT TO THE
ISSUE OF OF OF SHIP FUNDING AND
AND YEAH I I JUST ASK THE CHAIR
THE CHAIR AND I SPOKE A LITTLE
BEFORE THAT.
THIS MEETING BUT I I REALLY DO
ASK THE CHAIR.
TO ASSIST US IN AND HELPING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS -- THIS BILL
DOES REALLY IS REALLY MEANINGFUL
I'M IF WE'RE NOT GONNA DO IT
THROUGH -- THE SHIP FUNDING
ISSUE AND LET LET'S FIGURE OUT
ANOTHER WAY TO TO TO MAKE IT
MEANINGFUL STEPS DEFINING WHEN I
TOOK A STEP FUNDING -- SO.
I IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AS AS
FOLKS KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
THIS WAS PRO TEM STEINBERG.
BILL WHICH WAS ABOUT SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES IT WAS ALL ABOUT
TRYING TO LINK TRANSPORTATION
LAND USE AND HOUSING EFFORTS
WITH OUR CLIMATE GOALS NUMBER
THE THE LAW REQUIRES THE AIR
BOARD TO SET GROUP REGIONAL
GREENHOUSE GAS.
REDUCTION TARGETS FOR THE
STATE'S EIGHTEEN METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THEN THE NPOS -- CRITICIZE
THE ANIMAL COMMUNITY STRATEGY.
AS PART OF THEIR REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO HELP THEM MEET THEIR
REDUCTION TARGETS.
WE THEN IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN JUST
A COUPLE YEARS AGO PASSED SB ONE
FIFTY WHICH ASK HARD TO ASSESS
THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE TOWARD
MEETING THE REDUCTION TARGETS
AND THE SAD TRUTH IS THAT WE'VE
NOW HEARD BACK FROM CARBON THEY
SAID UNEQUIVOCALLY.
THAT CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON TRACK --
A TO MEET ITS GREEN I GET
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
EXPECTED UNDER SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE AND A NOTED CONCERNS OVER
QUOTE THE CONTINUE PERVASIVE IN
LONG STANDING DISCONNECT.
BETWEEN THE FACTORS THAT SHAPE
REGIONAL GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
CALIFORNIA SUCH TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENT.
REGULATORY AND HOUSING MARKET
CONDITIONS OF THE LOCAL REGIONAL
STATE LEVELS AND THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY CLIMATE
HEALTH ECONOMIC AND HOUSING
[inaudible]
GOALS.
THIS REPORT.
F..
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX ESTABLISHES
THE MOBILITY ACTION PLAN FOR
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND THIS
WOULD BE A TASK FORCE CHARGED
WITH IDENTIFYING STRATEGIES TO
GET THE STATE ON TRACK TO
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION LAND USE
SECTORS.
AN INCREASE THE PROCESS TO
CLEVERNESS SORRY DATA TO
EVALUATE THE PROGRESS THAT
REGION'S ARE MAKING THE BILL
ALSO CALLS ON OUR END PO'S. TO
INCLUDE AN ACTION PLAN WITHIN
THEIR REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLAN.
THAT SPELLS OUT HOW THEIR
SUSTAINABLE COMMITTEE STRATEGY.
I WILL BE IMPLEMENTED.
AND IT'S OUR HOPE THAT THIS WILL
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY WILL
GIVE ALL LEVELS OF DECISION
MAKERS STATE REGIONAL LOCAL A
SENSE FOR WHAT IS NEEDED. TO
MEET OUR TARGETS -- NOW THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS MAKES SEVERAL
SUGGESTIONS THAT I WANT TO DRESS
FIRST COMMON NUMBER THREE
QUESTIONS THE TIMING OF THE BILL --
I I YOU RESPECTFULLY DON'T AGREE
THAT THIS.
MEASURES PREMATURE WE WE ASK THE
AIRPORT TO LOOK AT WHETHER OR
NOT WE'RE MEETING THE GOALS OF
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH
COURSES PAST. TEN YEARS AGO.
ARE WE HAVE THE REPORT BACK AT
THE BOOKS YOU KNOW THE THE THE
THE THE BILLS ON THE BOOKS FOR
TEN YEARS IN THE LAND USE
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE NOW HAVE
LONG TERM IMPLICATIONS AND IT
REALLY IS TIME FOR US TO FIGURE
OUT.
HOW TO RIGHT THE SHIP IN MEET
THE TRUE PROMISE OF SB?
THREE SEVENTY FIVE NO COMING
OVER FOR THE HOUSE IS STRONGLY --
THE THE THE ALSO SUGGEST
STRIKING THE SECTION THE BILL
RELATED -- TO TO TO STEP FUNDING.
I AND YOU KNOW I REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
PUT ITS MONEY WHERE ITS
PRIORITIES ARE AND IF REGION'S
AREN'T MEETING THEIR TARGETS
SHOULD.
SEE FUNDING BE USED TO DIG A
DEEPER HOLE.
THAT BEING SAID AS I MENTIONED I
TALKED -- TO THE CHAIR I
UNDERSTAND WHERE HE'S COMING
FROM HIM I'M CERTAINLY WILLING
TO TAKE THIS AMENDMENT NOW WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR
WILL WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO FIND A WAY TO
ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
MAKE SURE THERE'S REAL MEANING.
IN THIS BILL -- WE CERTAINLY ARE
CONTINUED YOU COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN VERY
PRODUCTIVE SO FAR WE WANT TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO IDENTIFY HOW
TO BEST A LINE.
ALL OF OUR STATE GOALS IN OUR
FUNDING.
AND YOU KNOW WE WE WE WE KNOW
THAT THE GOALS THAT ARE LAID OUT
THREE THIRTY FIVE IMPORTANT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET A
REAL MEANING AND AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE THIS
BILL TODAY SO.
WITH WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING I
WE'RE WE'RE WILLING TO ACCEPT --
THOSE THOSE CRITICAL MOMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE BUT BUT
REALLY DO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY MOVING FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THIS BLL REMAINS STRONG.
I HAVE WITH ME CARTER RUBIN FROM
AN RTC JOSH START FROM
TRANSFORMERS CARMINA UNIT YOU'RE
NOT CATERING.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL YEAH WILL
BEAR IT YOU'RE NOT WILL BURY
OKAY YOU WILL VERY RIGHT OKAY.
SO AND JOSH STARK IS BACK THERE
SOMEWHERE YEAH OKAY.
WE HAVE SOME GOOD FOLKS HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THE BILL AND VICTORIA
ROME FROM AN RTC.
YES ALL SORTS OF FOLKS.
YOU KNOW YEAH THE FLOOD TO
PEOPLE IN RADIO.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'
VICTORIA ROME WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWENTY SIX
AND I JUST WANNA KNOW QUICKLY.
THAT WE HAVE A GROUP OF OUR
VOLUNTEERS AND MEMBERS HERE
TODAY FROM SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA THERE IN THE FIRST COUPLE
ROWS THERE AND THEY'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
AS WELL AS SPEAKING TO MEMBERS
BOUT SOME OTHER IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL BILLS TODAY.
SO -- AS YOU HEARD SB FIVE
TWENTY SIX IS DESIGNED TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT TO HALT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
EXTENDS TO OUR LARGEST SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GASES THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
AS YOU WELL KNOW CALIFORNIANS
ARE ALREADY SUFFERING FROM THE
DEVASTATED IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH POOR AIR QUALITY.
DESPITE INCREASINGLY FREQUENT AN
UNPRECEDENTED DISASTERS WE
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ONLY ADDS TO
OUR EMISSIONS.
OUR OWN STATE AGENCIES HAVE
RAISE THE ALARM THAT OUR CURRENT
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES ARE
PUSHING MORE ROADS AND WIDER
ROADS.
EXPERTS AND OUR OWN EXPERIENCES
TELL US THIS JUST ENCOURAGES
MORE AND MORE DRIVING.
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX BUILT ON THE
FOUNDATIONAL WORK OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT SB ONE FIFTY FROM.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO RECOGNIZE
THAT FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE
MEANS GIVING CALIFORNIANS
SOMETHING THEY CONSISTENTLY
ASKED FOR THE ABILITY TO GET
AROUND TO WITHOUT GETTING IN
THEIR CAR.
THANKS TO SB ONE FIFTY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD PRODUCE THE
FIRST COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE
SIGNIFICANT MISALIGNMENT BETWEEN
OUR TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS
AND OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
AND THEY FOUND THAT CALIFORNIA
IS NOT ON TRACK TO MEET
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
REDUCTIONS EXPECTED UNDER SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AS
NECESSARY TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS EVEN THESE ARE WONDERFUL
BUT THEY ALONE WON'T GET US
THERE.
THE PORTION OF COMMUTERS DRIVING
ALONE TO WORK IS RISING AND
ALMOST EVERY REGION.
CALIFORNIA STANDS TO SPEND ONE
POINT ONE TRILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE LIFE OF CURRENT
TRANSPORTATION PLANS BUT THESE
PROJECTS ARE NOT ALIGNED WITH
CLIMATE GOALS OR STRAIGHT
PRIORITIES ON EQUITABLE GROWTH
AN OPEN SPACE CONSERVATION. TO
SECURE THE PUBLIC HEALTH EQUITY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION AND MOBILITY
CHOICES ENVISIONED BY SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND TO ENSURE
WE REMAIN ON TRACK TO REDUCING
HARMFUL POLLUTION.
AND ATTAINING HEALTH PROTECTIVE
CLIMATE STANDARDS REAL CHANGES
MUST BE MADE TAA TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM AND INVESTMENTS.
WE THANK SENATOR ALLEN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON ON THIS ISSUE AND
ON SB FIVE TWENTY SIX PACIFIC
LEE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M WILL BEAR IT
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION IS CO
SPONSORING SB FIVE TWENTY SIX TO
HELP ADDRESS THE CRITICAL.
NEED TO REDUCE HARMFUL
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS AND
CREATE HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IN SHORT LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION DECISIONS AND
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS MUST
BE VIEWED AS PUBLIC HEALTH
DECISIONS.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE LONG
SUPPORTED THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND WE'RE
DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH THE
FINDINGS OF THE SB ONE FIFTY
REPORT.
BLUNTLY WE AREN'T ON TRACK.
THE PROMISE OF HEALTH YOUR
COMMUNITIES ENVISIONED IN OUR
NPOS -- SCS PLANS IS NOT BEING
REALIZED DUE TO A VARIETY OF
FACTORS OUTLINED IN THE REPORT.
INCLUDING ROADWAY EXPANSION
PROJECTS -- CHALLENGES WITH
HOUSING PRODUCTION.
IN OTHER OUTSIDE FACTORS.
I SENATOR ALLEN NOTED THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN LOCAL ACTIONS
AND STATE GOALS IS HIGHLY
PROBLEMATIC.
THROUGH THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE WE CAN ACHIEVE A
WIDE RANGE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS RELATED TO CHRONIC
ILLNESSES IN CANCERS RESPIRATORY
AND CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE.
OBESITY RELATED DISEASES AND
DIABETES IMPROVEMENTS IN SAFETY
FOR ALL PASSENGERS AND ALL
TRAVELERS ON OUR ROADS AND
STREETS.
MENTAL HEALTH IMPROVEMENTS AND
SENIOR AND YOUTH INDEPENDENCE
FOR THOSE WHO MIGHT BE ISOLATED
BECAUSE OF TRANSPORTATION LAND
USE DECISIONS.
BUT WE ARE ON TRACK TO ACHIEVE
THESE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS
THROUGH IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND WE WON'T
BE WITHOUT STRUCTURAL CHANGES
NECESSARY -- WE SUPPORT SB FIVE
TWENTY SIX AS A WAY TO ADDRESS
THE GROWTH IN TRANSPORTATION
POLLUTION AND TO ADVANCE THE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE.
LEVEL STAKEHOLDERS TO GET US ON
TRACK TO PLANNING INVESTING IN
AND BUILDING HALTHIER
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO IMPROVE TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
SOCIAL EQUITY AND SUSTAINABILITY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES -- WITHOUT I
HEARD YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU -- WELL OTHERS
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX PLEASE COME
[inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND CATHERINE
GARCIA WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
IN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MATTHEW BIGGER PLAYING
CONSERVATION THEY ALSO AND VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
JOSH WAS STARK ON BEHALF OF
TRANSFORM BAY AREA HERE I AND
SAN FRANCISCO AND BAY AREA
SILICON VALLEY -- AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK.
ESTHER RIVERA CALIFORNIA OXEN
SUPPORT.
THEN THE COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION IN SUPPORT.
JULIE JORDAN WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SUPPORT AND
EXCITED ABOUT WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE ON AND ENSURING COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT IN EQUITY COMPONENTS
THINKING.
JOHN MADDOX WITH THE SAFE ROUTES
TO SCHOOL NATIONAL PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT.
RE A **** WITH THE SF COUNCIL
SUPPORTERS OF ENERGY SEE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
BECAUSE THANK YOU NOW -- NO
OTHER SUPPORTERS IF NOT -- LET'S
HEAR OPPOSITION OR NEUTRAL OTHER
POSITIONS.
PLEASE COME FOR HAVE A SEAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- BILL AGAINST WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNCILS FORGET OF GOVERNMENTS
AND WE WANT TO THANK -- THE
SENATOR FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION WE HAD IN A MISTER
CHIN'S OFFICE BECAUSE I THOUGHT
THAT THAT WAS VERY FRUITFUL WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS HE'S
TAKING TODAY.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE HOW ALL OPEN
HIS OFFICE HAS BEEN WITH ALL THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WE THINK
THAT THERE'S A COUPLE OF WAYS
THAT WE CAN MAKE THAT REPORT A
LITTLE BETTER.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY AS THE
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS RESPONSIBLE WE ARE
ARE GRAPPLING.
WITH THE LARGER ISSUES HERE
ABOUT HOW WE ACHIEVE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND BUILD ENOUGH HOUSING
UNITS AND DEAL WITH THE THOMAS
VEHICLES AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
WITH THE LIMITED AMOUNT OF
AUTHORITY IT'S A LOT OF PLANNING
AND CONSENSUS WITH LOCAL
AGENCIES AND WE DO NEED.
A LOT OF HELP AND ASSISTANCE
FROM STATE.
AND LOCAL PARTNERS IF WE'RE
GONNA CHIEF ALL THESE GOALS AT
THE SAME TIME AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS WHERE A TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY I'M WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE POSITION BUT BUT TRULY
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OR TO
THE AUTHOR -- AND THE PROPONENTS
AND AND YOUR STAFF -- FOR FOR
TRULY SOME SOME PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS -- VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT THAT
WAS TAKEN -- THE CHALLENGE THAT
A TRANSPORTATION AGENCY LIKE US
HAS WITH -- THIS BILL IS THE
FACT THAT THIS IS ABOUT.
A THE VERY REAL ISSUE OF HOW ARE
WE MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
ONE OF THOSE REGIONAL DECISIONS
THAT ARE BEING MADE IN THOSE
LOCAL DECISIONS THAT ARE BEING
MADE BUT AS A TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY WE DON'T MAKE THOSE LAND
USE DECISIONS.
THOSE ARE NOT MADE BY
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES.
THAT WILL OUR JOB IS TO MAKE
SURE WE GIVE FULL MOBILITY
OPTIONS FOR ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS
OF ORANGE COUNTY NOT JUST THOSE
THAT LIVE IN CERTAIN POCKETS SO
THAT'S OUR CHALLENGE.
I THINK GLOBALLY WITH THIS.
AND THEN I'D ALSO LIKE TO JUST
MENTION -- WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
A LITTLE BIT AND MAYBE WE COULD
WORK ON THIS GOING FORWARD AND
THAT IS THE BILL DOES -- DISCUSS
AND AND RELY ON V. M. T. AS A AS
A SIGNIFICANT -- INDICATOR OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS WE
DON'T THINK THAT'S A GREAT
BAROMETER OF OF WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE MEETING OUR GOALS WE HAVE
A PROJECT IN ORANGE COUNTY THAT
WERE INCREDIBLY PROUD OF ITS ON
THE OC STREET CARTS A BRAND NEW
TRANSIT SYSTEM NO ONE ELSE IS
BUILDING NEW TRANSIT.
OR BUILDING A BRAND NEW TRANSIT
SYSTEM IT'S A ONE OF THE MOST --
THE DENSEST POPULATED AREAS OF
THE STATE -- IN THE NATION IN
SANTA ANA -- AND TECHNICALLY IT
WOULD AT LEAST NARROWLY INCREASE
V. M T. BECAUSE IT RE ROUTE
TRAFFIC AND WE HAVE PEOPLE
TRAVELING TO THE END POINTS.
BY ALL ALL MEASURES THIS IS THAT
THIS IS A PROJECT THAT I THINK
THAT -- WE ALL WOULD AGREE IS IS
GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TERMS OF BUILDING MORE TRANSIT.
SO WE WOULD LIKE THE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO AND WOULD LIKE TO
CONSIDER -- THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER -- BROADENING THE HOW
WE MEET OUR GHG REDUCTIONS --
BROADER THAN VMT SO APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARC WATTS REPRESENTING
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA WE'RE
NOT EXACTLY OPPOSE WE CAME LATE
TO THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE.
EXPRESS SOME DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT
THE STEP COMPONENT -- THAT WAS
CONTAINED IN THE CURRENT BILL
AND ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR AT
LEAST NOW TAKING THAT PIECE OUT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
BAKER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS GOT SCORE BEHALF
DISTINTAS COUNCIL GOVERNMENT'S
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FOR
MONTEREY COUNTY WE ALSO HAVE
BETWEEN YOUR POSITION JUST LIKE
MISTER WATSON THAT'S BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T HAD THE BENEFIT.
OF A CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHOR -- I THINK THE TWO
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE IS NUMBER
ONE WE WILL ME BACK UP WE
DEFINITELY SHARE THE GOAL OF
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
THE COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT TO
HAVE SALES TAX MEASURES TO TRY
TO PROVIDE MULTI MODAL OPTIONS
IN ORDER TO WIN PEOPLE OFF OF
THEIR DEPENDENCE ON THE VEHICLE --
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE HOWEVER
THOUGH IS THAT WE DO NEED TO
IMPROVE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SO.
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
HAPPEN IS FOR SAFETY CONGESTION
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS TO ALSO FALL
BY THE WAYSIDE?
AND SO WHAT I THINK MIGHT BE
UPROOTED APPROACHES FOCUSING ON
WHERE THOSE PEOPLE TRAVELING TO
THEIR OFTEN TRAVELING TO THE JOB
CENTERS AND SO FOR FOLKS THAT
LIVE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH
IS IN A NON TEAM AN AIR DISTRICT.
THOSE FIRST TO HAVE BEEN DRIVING
TO THE BAY AREA BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THE JOBS ARE IN SO MAYBE
FOCUSING ON INCENTIVES TO
PROMOTE CREATE MORE JOBS WITHIN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY STATE WE
REDUCE VMT WE REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
AND THEN MAKING MORE INVESTMENTS
AS THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE WITH
PASSENGER RAIL SERVICE COULD BE
A REAL INCENTIVE IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THE TRUE MULTI MODAL --
SERVICE THAT WERE ALL LONGING --
TO IN ORDER TO VERY THANK YOU ME
TO MEET THE GOAL SO THANKS X..
ONLY TWO SPEAKERS PER ITEM
PLEASE OF OVER.
EIGHT WHAT HAS SPENT SEVERAL WE
TOTALLY CONCUR WITH IMPACT AND
ALSO ISN'T CONCERNED MORE BRINGS
UP A VERY VALID POINT.
OF ROAD WITH REGARD TO ANOTHER.
OF LOOK AT GMT AND WHAT PM T.
DOES OR DOESN'T DO AS A
BAROMETER BUT WE APPRECIATE
FURTHER CONVERSATION LOVE TO CUT
GOTTEN IN THE ROOM.
WITH THE SENATOR RAND.
AND BILL HAGENS BUT THANK YOU
ACCORDING FROM THE DIALOGUE
[inaudible]
OKAY -- OKAY -- SO WE I I I AM
RECOMMENDING THIS BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AUTHORED THREE TO THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THAT
ENTAILS THE THE ISSUE OF THE
STATE OF BEING THE FOR THEM --
SIR -- AS WE HAVE SOME TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ALSO.
WE AGREE TO AND I WANT TO KNOW
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE -- I
SEE NO ANSWER ON THE ONE EIGHT
ONE OF THINGS I THINK IS THE
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS WERE DESIGNED --
TO WORK WITH THE AIR REGIONAL
AIR QUALITY BOARDS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE STATE
[inaudible]
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
SUPPOSEDLY GOING TO WORK WITH --
STATE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
AND DEVICE TRANSPORTATION PLANS
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANS --
BUT IN THE DO THAT NAY THEY WORK
TOGETHER ON THE PLANNING PART
BUT THEY DON'T.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT WHAT WE PLAN
AND WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS ARE
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS BECAUSE OF
THE ECONOMY.
AND MORE JOBS COME IN ALL THE
SUDDEN THERE'S MORE.
DRIVE BEING OTHERS MORE
POLLUTION LESS TRANSIT USAGE.
A LOT OF FACTORS INFLUENCE --
YOUR ARE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR -- SO I THINK I THINK WE
HAVE TO SET OURSELVES AND LOOK
WHAT COULD HAVE THE THE GREATEST
IMPACT THE BIGGEST BANG FOR YOUR
BUCK OR BIGGEST RETURN ON YOUR
INVESTMENT.
IN EACH AREA EACH REGION. TO
WHAT COULD -- REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
AND GET THE METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS. TO
COMMIT TO THAT.
AND IT AS YOU KNOW I I WAS ON
THOUGH THE BAY AREA METROPOLITAN
PLANNING COMMISSION WITH THE
SERVER DODD AND OTHERS AND OTHER
SENATORS.
SIR WINNER -- EYES SERVED AS
CHAIR AND I SERVED ON THERE FOR
TWENTY ONE YEARS.
AND I THINK THE THE DISCONNECT
IS BETWEEN THE PLANNING.
VERSUS THE FUNDING AND THE
ACTION PART [inaudible]
SO.
THE PLANNING IS ALL GOOD BUT
THEN YOU DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO
IMPLEMENT THE PLANS THAT
ACTUALLY REDUCE TO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS [inaudible]
SO -- MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN
DEVISE.
WITH THE WORK YOU'RE DOING.
SOME KIND OF WAY OF CONNECTING
THE TWO BETTER SO WE CAN.
GET RESULTS PEOPLE WANT RESULTS
THEY WANT TO THEY WANT TO SEE
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCED.
SO WE HAVE TO HAVE RESULTS SO.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THAT -- BUT BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT
AND THE REGIONAL PLANNING
AGENCIES OF COURSE AND OTHER
OTHER LEGISLATORS YEAH I THINK
ARE COMPLEX ISSUE THOUGH.
DODD THAT WHENEVER SOME AS CHAIR
AND I THINK THE REASON.
WE LOOKED AT IN THE RESULT AFTER
THE BILL WE LOOKED AT THAT AD
STEP IS A WAY OF OF OF GETTING
THERE I I GET THE CONCERNS THAT
EXIST ABOUT USING THAT AS THE AS
THE THE LEVERAGE.
SO LET'S FIGURE OUT SOMETHING
ELSE THAT THAT REALLY IS --
MEANINGFUL -- AND WHEN I SAY ME
FOR A WHILE TO EFFECTUATE THE
GOALS WE HAVE.
AND WE LAY DOWN IT WE'VE BEEN
MEDICALLY NOT BEEN ABLE TO MEET.
I THINK THAT SOME WE CAN WORK ON
I I HOPE THAT THE REGIONAL
PLANNING AGENCIES WILL WORK WITH
YOU ON THIS SENATOR.
YEAH ANON DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OTHER.
WE HAVE A MOTION WITH THE
ACCEPTANCE WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
SIR DODD A CENTERED ALLEN JULIE
TO MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE AND AND
AND I I I I DO FEEL.
GOOD ABOUT THE CONVERSATION
MOVED FORWARD AND AND WERE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK REALLY CLOSELY
WITH EVERYBODY.
AND RESPECT S. RIVAL.
OKAY WE'LL MOTION TO APPROVE
THIS WITH THE MEMBERS.
CORRECT.
AND COULD CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY
SIX BY SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING.
SENATOR AS WELL.
BELL AYE BATES NO BATES NO DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI MCGUIRE MORALE.
MORRELL NO ROTH.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STONE.
STONE NO -- BURKE.
NUMBER I WILL COST ME WE GOT THE
AYE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SIXTY THREE WE HAVE OUR SIX
POSTS IN FAVOR THREE AGAINST
WILL THESE ARE ALL OF AN MEMBER --
SIR BORDER ISSUE OF THE FLOOR
YOU HAVE A BILL COMING UP HERE.
SIR BORDERS AS ITEM EIGHT THIS
IS AS BEFORE -- TO AND THIS IS
OFF A HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION
THE COUNTY AND YOU KNOW AND
CENTER.
WELL COM UM [inaudible]
AND YOU HAVE THE FLOOR SENATOR
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION ON YOUR
BILL.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
CHAIRMAN.
I GOT A CITIES WHAT ON WE HAVE A
WIDE NO CHAMBERS SO WE CAN --
OUR CONDUCTOR BUSINESS.
THANK YOU THIS IS A VERY COOL --
OPPORTUNITY THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT I PRESENTED SO IT
LOOKS DIFFERENT FROM THE SIDE.
OF THE ROOM -- AND ALSO TODAY
WAS A THREE COMMITTEE DAY AT THE
SAME TIME SO RUNNING AROUND.
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME AND
AND ALLOW ME TO PRESENT -- THEY
CAN BECOME MEMBER -- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS BILL
TODAY.
SB FOUR OH TWO IS A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION TO INYO COUNTIES
ADVENTURE TRAIL PILOT PROGRAM.
LOCATED IN SENATE-DISTRICT.
EIGHT IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AB
SIX TO EIGHT ESTABLISHES PILOT
PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWED INYO
COUNTY TO DESIGNATE SPECIFIC
COUNTY ROADS AS COMBINED USE
ROUTES FOR OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
USE.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
IMPLEMENTATION DELAYS BY COURT
ACTION.
THERE HAS NOT BEEN ENOUGH TIME
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM ITSELF.
THE GOALS OF THIS PROGRAM ARE TO
INCREASE TRAFFIC SAFETY.
IMPROVE NATURAL RESOURCE
PROTECTION REDUCE OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE TRUCK TRESPASS ON
PRIVATE LAND AND MINIMIZE
IMPACTS ON COUNTY RESIDENTS.
NEITHER THIS BILL NOR THE
EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM CREATE A
SINGLE NEW TRAIL OR WROTE.
IT DOES HOWEVER CREATE A BETTER
NETWORK OF TRAILS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY A LEGAL AND
REGULATED MEANS TO ACCESS
EXISTING MAINTAINED TRAILS
[inaudible]
THIS PROGRAM.
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
PROTECTING TRILLS AND LANDS FROM
TRUCKS AND TRAILERS UNLOADING
AND STAGING A TV VEHICLES
BECAUSE NOW PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE TRAILS FROM EXISTING
PARKING LOTS BETTER CLOSER TO
TOWN.
ADDITIONALLY BY HAVING A LINK TO
TRAIL SYSTEM.
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS THE TOOLS TO
PROPERLY DIRECT OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES -- H. V. USERS TO
APPROVED ROUTES AND REDUCE THE
NEED -- TO POLICE ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THIS PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT TO
LOCAL ECONOMY.
INYO COUNTY WHICH CONSISTS
PRIMARILY OF HIGH DESERT WITH
LESS THAN 2% PRIVATELY OWNED
LAND.
HAS A ROBUST ATV -- H. B.
COMMUNITY AND RELIES EXTENSIVELY
ON TOURISM DOLLARS.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN INYO
RECENTLY VOTED UNANIMOUSLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS EXTENSION.
I RESPECT TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON S.
BEFORE -- TO MEMBERS I'D ALSO
LIKE TO INTRODUCE INYO COUNTY
SHERIFF JEFF HOLLOWELL.
WHO IS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND PAUL SMITH FOR MARCY
RC THE RULE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA?
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BILL
AND DISTINGUISHED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
I AM JUST FOLLOWING THE SHERIFF
OF INYO COUNTY -- LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR BARGES FOR SPONSORING US
BEFORE -- TUNE FOR YOU ALLOW ME
TO SPEAK.
AND TWENTY TWELVE THE INCOMING
MORE SUPERVISORS RECEIVED THIRTY
EIGHT APPLICATIONS FOR COMBINED
USED ROUTE.
AFTER A RATHER THOROUGH AN
EXHAUSTIVE -- APPLICATION
HEARING PROCESS IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE WERE ABLE TO
APPROVE SEVEN OF THOSE ROUTES.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SB THIRTY
FORTY OR EXCUSE ME THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE EXTENT OF THE PROJECT
UNTIL JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY OF THE SEVEN ROUTE
THAT WERE APPROVED TO THOSE WERE
OPEN UP IN JULY TWENTY FIFTEEN
ONE ROUTE IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE REMAINING FOUR IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SINCE THIS PILOT PROJECT OPEN
NEITHER MY OFFICE MORE THE SIEGE
PM RECEIVED.
ANY REPORTS OF ACCIDENTS OR
INJURIES RELATED TO ANY OF THE
SEVEN COMBINED USED ROUTES. TO
THE C. H. P. NOR MY OFFICE HAVE
RECEIVED ANY FORMAL COMPLAINTS
REGARDING THE ROUTES.
WE CAN EVEN YOU IS NOT RECEIVED
ANY REPORTS FROM.
PARTNERING AGENCIES REGARDING
DEGRADATION THE ANY OTHER
IDENTIFIED ROUTES.
THE ROUTES CURRENTLY CONSISTS OF
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILES THIRTY NINE OF WHICH
ARE ACTUALLY PAVE ROADS -- THE
WHICH FEES ARE ALREADY PERMITTED
ON THE REMAINING TERM PORTIONS
OF THOSE ROADS.
WE HAVEN'T CHANGED ANYTHING
THERE.
LAST YEAR MY OFFICE PATROLLED
OVER FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED MILES OF
THESE ROUTES.
MAKING PROBABLY SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE CONTACTS WITH
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
EACH ONE OF THOSE CONTACTS.
ALLOWED US TO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL OUTREACH AND PROVIDE
GUIDANCE FOR SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE RECREATION.
DURING THAT TIME NO CITATIONS
WERE ISSUED.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AS BEFORE --
TO A NEW COUNTY WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLETE A
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION ON THIS
PILOT PROJECT.
AND PRESENTED COMMITTEE WITH THE
OUTCOMES OF THE EVALUATION.
THE EVALUATION WOULD INCLUDE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTCOMES AND REDUCTION OR
EACH BE INCURSIONS ON TO NON OHP
AREAS.
ALEX TAKE YOU ARE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND
I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR OUR NEXT WITNESS
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
SMITH WITH THE REAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES -- WE REPRESENT
THE RURAL COUNTIES OF OF THE
STATE INCLUDING IN YOU KNOW WE
WERE VERY INVOLVED IN THE
INITIAL CRAFTING OF THIS BILL IN
THE EXTENSION WE JUST NEED A
LITTLE MORE TIME TO SEE IF THIS
IS A VIABLE PROGRAM -- AS
LIMITED AS THAT MAY BE AND WE'RE
HOPING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
GRANTS IS THAT AND WE CAN DO
ANOTHER STUDY OF THE STUDY HAS
BEEN DELIVERED TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S REQUIRED IN THE
PREVIOUS AUTHORIZATION LOOK FOR
TO A MORE COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW.
OF ONCE WE HAVE THAT TIME TO DO
THAT EVALUATION.
THANK YOU OF WITNESSES IN FAVOR
PLEASE COME FOR A WITNESSES -- I
SEE NON OKAY -- WITNESSES
OPPOSING THE BILL PLEASE COME --
FOR RIGHT HERE PLEASE
[inaudible]
OVER HERE.
YEAH RIGHT HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES SIR YOU'RE THE FOR GERMAN
GOVERNMENT.
THE PHONE NUMBER ON YOUR CLOSER
WHICH BUTTON THE GREEN BUTTON.
THANKS VERY ON THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR BERMAN BELL AND
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS STEVE WHITE.
I'M A LONG TIME RESIDENT OF
BISHOP WHICH IS THE LARGEST TOWN
IN INYO COUNTY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK AND BE PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS I AM HUMBLED
BUT HONORED TO BE HERE.
SENATE BILL FOR A TWO IS A
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE IN INYO
COUNTY.
THE BILL WOULD CIRCUMVENT THE
STATE MOTOR VEHICLE CODE
ALLOWING ALL OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES TO DRIVE ON PAVED
COUNTY ROADS TO LET DRIVE TO LET
RIDERS CONVENIENTLY DRIVE INTO
TOWNS.
THIS PILOT PROGRAMS CALLED
ADVENTURE TRAILS AND IT HAS THE
STATED INTENT OF PROMOTING --
EACH V. TOURISM IN INYO COUNTY.
I SPEAK FOR MANY WHO ARE
ADAMANTLY AGAINST THIS PROGRAM.
AND I TRUST THAT YOU ALL
RECEIVED THE PACKETS OF LETTERS
SENT BY THIRTY OF OUR CONCERNED
CITIZENS.
LET ME BE CLEAR WE ACCEPT LEGAL
AND RESPONSIBLE USE OF OFF ROAD
VEHICLES BY LOCALS AS BEING PART
OF THE RECREATION MIX.
IT IS THE PROMOTION OF IT AS A
TOURIST DRAW THAT IS ALARMING.
THE ECONOMY OF OUR AREA IS
HEAVILY DEPENDENT UPON NON
MOTORIZED OUTDOOR RECREATION BY
TOURISTS.
THESE INCLUDE HIKING ROCK
CLIMBING BACKPACKING FISHING
PHOTOGRAPHY BIRD WATCHING
HORSEBACK RIDING SKIING AND
GENERAL SIGHTSEEING.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE NEGATIVE IMPACT OF THIS
PROJECT ON OUR ECONOMY.
THAT'S CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
BECOMES EVER GREATER.
OUR COUNTY VAST UNPOPULATED
LANDSCAPES BECOME EVER MORE
DESIRABLE FOR THOSE MILLIONS WHO
ARE SEEKING QUIET PURSUITS.
WE ARE EIGHT YEARS INTO THIS
PILOT PROGRAM WHEN THIS IS
APPROVED BY OUR COUNTY
SUPERVISORS WE WERE TOLD THAT
THERE WOULD BE A MONITORING
PROGRAM.
DIALOGUE ABOUT MITIGATION
EFFICIENT AND COMPREHENSIVE WAYS
TO IDENTIFY YOU LEGAL USE.
AND THAT THE PUBLIC WOULD BE
KEPT INFORMED OF THE STATUS OF
THIS PROGRAM.
THE STEPS WERE NEVER TAKEN.
AS A CASE IN POINT.
THE CURRENT BILL SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE CALL FOR AND
I QUOTE.
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AT A PUBLIC HEARING HELD
BY THE COUNTY IN ORDER TO
EVALUATE THE PILOT PROJECT.
THIS DEDICATED THIS DEDICATED
HEARING NEVER HAPPENED.
PROPONENTS OF SAID THAT THE
PILOT PROGRAM SHOULD BE COULD
CONTINUE BECAUSE THERE WERE
DELAYS IN IMPLEMENTATION.
WELL ONE REASON THERE WERE
DELAYS WAS THAT THE ORIGINALLY
PLANNED THIRTY SEVEN ROUTES MET
WITH STIFF OPPOSITION AND
FINALLY HAD TO BE TRIMMED BACK
TO SEVEN ROUNDS BEFORE BEING
APPROVED.
IN YOUR COUNTIES OPEN LAND IS
VIRTUALLY ALL PUBLIC.
BILL IN FOR A SERVICE AND
NATIONAL PARKS.
BY THEIR OWN ADMISSION THESE
AGENCIES ARE UNABLE TO DEAL WITH
MONITORING EVEN THE CURRENT
LEVEL OF EACH BE ACTIVITY.
KNOWING THAT -- EACH V. USE.
HAS A MUCH HIGHER IMPACT THE NON
MOTORIZED USE HOW CAN WE EXPECT
THEM TO MONITOR AN EMPHASIS
PROGRAM LIKE ADVENTURE TRAILS.
I RESPECTFULLY BUT URGENTLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE AGAINST THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
TERM HOW.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MY NAME'S DAN CONNER AM AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MUSIC TEACHER.
IN BISHOP CALIFORNIA.
JUST A WEEK AGO THE SENATE THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE PASSED TWO
BILLS TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
SB FOUR HUNDRED IS ATTEMPTING TO
ELIMINATE GROSSLY POLLUTING
VEHICLES FROM OUR ROADS AND
HIGHWAYS.
A GREAT IDEA BUT I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THOSE CLUNKERS AREN'T NEARLY
AS DIRTY AS THE VEHICLES.
THAT SB FOUR OH TWO IS INVITING
EN MASSE.
THE ANNUAL COUNTY.
THE CALIFORNIA REESE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD SAYS THE
CLEANEST BURNING -- H. B.
POLLUTES THE EQUIVALENT OF
THIRTY PASSENGER CARS.
AND THE DIRTIEST AS MUCH AS
SEVEN HUNDRED PASSENGER CAR.
THE PASSAGE OF SB FORTY FIVE
ENABLES CALIFORNIA TO PREPARE
FOR ONE OF THE MAJOR EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WILD FIRES.
SENATOR DODD.
I BELIEVE.
WELL MAYBE IT HERE.
IS CONCERNED ENOUGH ABOUT
WILDFIRES TO AUTHOR TWO PIECES
OF LEGISLATION ABOUT THEM.
SO HE KNOWS THAT THE MOST
WILDFIRES.
THAT MOST WILD FIRES ARE CAUSED
BY HUMANS.
AND MISUSE OF GASOLINE POWERED
EQUIPMENT SUCH AS CHAIN SAWS
FARM EQUIPMENT AND H. P..
ARE COMMON OFFENDERS FROM THAT
GROUP.
THE MOST POPULAR -- H. B. THE
POLARIS RAZOR HAS HAD OVER HALF
A MILLION RECALLS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS MANY BECAUSE THEY
SPONTANEOUSLY BURST INTO FLAMES.
DOES IT MAKE ANY SENSE TO TRY
AND ATTRACT LARGE OR EVEN SMALL
NUMBERS OF THESE VEHICLES TO A
COUNTY WHICH IS FULL OF
CHAPARRAL AND SUBJECT TO WILD
FIRE.
IN YOUR COUNTIES TRIED FOR EIGHT
YEARS TO GET THIS PILOT PROGRAM
UP AND RUNNING MILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS VIA THE O. H.
P. TRUST FUND HAVE BEEN SPENT.
IN ADDITION TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FROM INYO
COUNTY TAXPAYERS.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THEIR
INSISTENCE.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
INSISTENCE OF OUR SUPERVISORS TO
THROW GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD.
AND THEY AREN'T EXPLAINING IT TO
US IN FACT IT SEEMS THEY ARE
AVOIDING THE PUBLIC'S
INVOLVEMENT.
WE HAD A PUBLIC HEARING IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
HAVEN'T HAD ONE SINCE -- AS YOU
CAN YOU WRAP IT UP WE WE HAVE
THE RULES TWO MINUTES PER
SPEAKER.
FIRST TWO TWO SPEAKERS AND TWO
MINUTES FOR EACH BY ALREADY GONE
TO MEN.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY.
BERMAN CAN I JUST SAY THAT --
WE'RE NOT PROFESSIONAL
POLITICIANS WERE JUST ORDINARY
CITIZENS EXHAUSTED FROM BATTLING
THIS THING FOR EIGHT YEARS.
AND OUR INTEREST IS SIMPLY TO
PLEAD FROM OUR HEARTS TO PLEASE
HOLD THE PRINCIPLES THE
PROPONENTS.
ARE ASKING YOU TO A BAND.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR -- OTHERS SPEAKERS
NOT IN FAVOR OF THIS
[inaudible]
PROPOSAL.
BRENDA WIKI CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
AND ALSO FOR SIERRA CALIFORNIA
ALSO ENOUGH IS OPPOSITION.
LYNN BOLTON I'M THE CHAIR OF THE
LOCAL -- SIERRA CLUB FOR IMMUNE
MONO COUNTY THE RANGE OF LIKE
GROUP OF THE TOTALITY CHAPTER OF
THE SIERRA CLUB [inaudible]
OUR WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS PILOT
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT INDUCES MORE --
HV RECREATION ACTIVITY ON PUBLIC
LANDS WITHOUT AN ADEQUATE
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT OF THE
IMPACTS ON PUBLIC LANDS.
AND ON NON -- HVAC RECREATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
M. HOLLAND OF FROM WESTERN ROAD
IN BISHOP OF FORMER VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTERS.
I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF THE OVERAGE FEES AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED.
ALL THEY DON'T BELONG.
ON OUR ROADS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING
US.
OF OKAY -- THEY HAVE QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS -- PERCENT OKAY
THERE'S A MOTION.
OF FRICTION ROSS ROSS SO
[inaudible]
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SHERIFF -- IF THE IF THE
OPPONENTS TO GET THEIR WAY AND
AND WE REALLY LIMIT OFF ROAD
HIGHWAY VEHICLE.
OPPORTUNITIES AND IN YOUR COUNTY --
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE RESULT
WILL BE DO THINK TOLD?
ME A LOT OF OFF ROADERS
UTILIZING.
HABITAT AREAS THAT ARE MUCH MORE
SENSITIVE AND WILL CREATE A
PUBLIC SAFETY NIGHTMARE FOR YOU
AS FAR AS HAVING OFFICERS
WRITING CITATIONS AND YOU SEE
THE POINT IN TRYING TO MAKE.
YES -- I I BELIEVE IF IF WE DO
NOT.
CONTINUE WITH THIS PILOT PROGRAM.
BASICALLY WHAT THIS IS GOING TO
DO THAT PUSHES EVERYBODY WITH
THEIR VEHICLES AND TRAILERS OUT
INTO SPACES WERE NORMALLY PEOPLE
LIKE TO GO OUT AND RIDE HORSES
AND WALK AND HIKE AND HUNT AND
FISH.
AND WE'RE GONNA PUSH THEM INTO
THAT AREA.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT THEN YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE THE ILLEGAL USE THAT
COMES WITH THAT WHICH IS GOING
TO CREATE YOU KNOW MORE PROBLEMS
FOR FOR MY DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
I WOULD CONTROL.
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY
INVESTIGATE ACCIDENTS YEAH THAT
THAT'S MY CONCERN MISTER
CHAIRMAN BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE.
CERTAIN AREAS IN THE STATE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN RIGHT THERE -- H.
FEES DISLIKES PEOPLE HAVE
FISHING HOBBIES AND WANT TO DO
IT AND IF WE RESTRICT.
OF THE AVAILABILITY OF PLACES
FOR THESE PEOPLE SAFE YOU'RE
RIGHT A RECREATIONAL VEHICLES
WITHOUT FEAR OF WARRANTED OR
INCOMPATIBILITY IS WAS
EQUESTRIANS AND WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO CREATE A LOT MORE
PROBLEMS IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
SORRY.
I SUPPORT THE MOTION AND THERE'S
MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THE
SAME THING.
HOME OTHER QUESTIONS -- MAYBE
THE RESPOND TO SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS SO OF TURN OF YOU FOR
YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU AND HELD
ON TO SOME OF THE AND I'LL BE
BRIEF -- I WANT TO THANK -- MR
DAN CONNOR MISTER STEVE WHITE
AND OTHERS.
WHO CAME OUT TO SPEAK ON THIS
MATTER -- I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCES THAT
WE'VE HEARD BUT I THINK THE MOST
TELLING.
IS THE STATEMENT MADE THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THIS FOR
EIGHT YEARS.
THAT'S PRECISELY WHY THE PILOT
PROGRAM HAS NOT BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
AND I THINK WHEN YOU HAVE THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND YOU
HAVE THE SHARE OF AND THE
CONSTITUENCY THAT IS ASKING FOR
THOSE TAX.
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
THIS INVESTMENT. TO REVEAL THE
MERITS OF THIS PROGRAM.
I THINK IT'S ONLY APPROPRIATE
THAT WE LET THE MERITS OF THIS
PROGRAM REVEALED THEMSELVES.
UP FOR THIS -- FOR THE REMAINDER
OF THIS PROPOSED PILOT PERIOD --
WE MAY FIND THAT -- THAT -- THIS
PROGRAM MAY NOT BE WORTH
PURSUING.
WE SUSPECT HOWEVER AS THE
SHERIFF MENTIONED THAT WE DO NOT
WANT ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO DRIVE
THEIR OFF ROAD VEHICLES.
INTO PRISTINE ENVIRONMENTAL
LANDS THAT'S PRECISELY THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT'S OCCURRING
HERE E. HAVING DUAL USE ROAD
ROADS IS GOING TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT WE PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT -- WHAT WE
LOOK AFTER THE INTERESTS OF --
INYO COUNTY.
THANK YOU WILL MOTION ON THE
FLOOR AND MORE QUESTIONS.
OF OKAY THANK YOU OF CENTER WILL
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE THIS IS AN
ABOUT FOUR OH TWO BY SENATOR
BARGES THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES ON WATER.
SENATOR BREAUX I FELT I BATES
RIGHT BATES AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI MCGUIRE MORALE.
WELL I ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO SKINNER STONE.
STONE AYE AMBERG WILL CASKEY.
WE HAVE SIX VOTES -- SENATOR
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- IN DENVER
AND NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
SIR CABALLERO YOU OF ONE BILL --
I HAVE TO SAY SENATOR -- WE PUT --
PRINT A A BY PASS BILL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND IT WAS APPROVED BECAUSE I
THINK THIS COMMITTEES VOTED ON
THAT.
HOW MANY TIMES IS THAT BILL A
FULL TIME I THINK IT'S AT LEAST
A COUPLE TIMES FOR A MORE IN
THAT -- DISPENSER ROLL PRINT A A
BY PASS BILLS OVER THE YEARS.
KLAY ONE LAST YEAR AND NOW NOW
THIS ONE SO -- WE PUT THAT ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO YOU'RE ON SB -- THREE SEVENTY
ONE ON SCHOOL BUSES AND ALL TURN
THE FLOOR OVER YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MR AT
CENTER CHAIR FOR MISTER CHAIR--
AND SENATORS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB.
THREE SEVENTY ONE THE BILL THAT
ADDRESSES THE ALARMING NUMBER OF
SCHOOL CHILDREN STRUCK BY
VEHICLES WHILE GOING TO AND FROM
THEIR SCHOOL BUS.
LET ME START BY THINKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
AMENDMENTS AND WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
DURING EVERY SCHOOL DAY IN
CALIFORNIA SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN RIGHT A SCHOOL BUS TO
AND FROM SCHOOL.
ACCORDING TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF PEOPLE TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES THERE ARE TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DRIVERS IN CALIFORNIA.
NOR THE STATE'S SCHOOL BUS STOP
LAW AS A SPEED BY SCHOOL BUSES
AS CHILDREN APPROACH -- EXIT
THIS BILL WOULD AMEND THE
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE TO
PROVIDE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
OPTION TO INCORPORATE SCHOOL BUS
STOPS Là VIDEO TECHNOLOGY.
THIS TECHNOLOGY WOULD HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT STOP VIOLATIONS SB
THREE SEVENTY ONE CONTAINS
PRIVACY.
JUDICIAL PROCESS SIGNAGE
REQUIREMENTS AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
BEFORE VIDEO TECHNOLOGY CAN BE
UTILIZED.
THE BILL ALSO PROTECTS SCHOOL
BUS DRIVERS AS WELL AS SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES FOR MANY INCREASED
LIABILITY ASSOCIATED WITH VIDEO
TECHNOLOGY DEPLOYED ON THE BUS
THEY ARE DRIVING.
THESE PRACTICES ARE TAKEN FROM
SIXTEEN OTHER STATES WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED VIDEO
TECHNOLOGY.
CALIFORNIA HAS TRAFFIC SAFETY
LAWS IN PLACE FOR THE SAFETY OF
CHILDREN.
THE LAW REQUIRES DRIVERS TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE FLASHING RED
LIGHTS AND AND THE STOP ARM ON
SCHOOL BUSES.
DRIVERS BY LAW ARE REQUIRED TO
STOP BEHIND THE SCHOOL BUS WHEN
DRIVING IN THE SAME DIRECTION AS
A BUS.
AND BEFORE A BUS WHEN DRIVING IN
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
THE FACT THAT CHILDREN TODAY
CONTINUE TO BE STRUCK BY DRIVERS
WHO DO NOT FOLLOW THE LAW
INDICATES THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
AND THIS BILL PROVIDES SCHOOL
DISTRICT WITH THE POTENTIAL
SOLUTION IF THEY WISH TO USE IT.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I'VE WITH ME TODAY IS
STEVE BORROW REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN SAFETY AND HEALTH AND
LIBBY SANCHES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY OTHER CENTERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS THE
BARREL I AM THE PROJECT DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH I'M
ALSO THE STATE COURT CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA UNINTENTIONAL
INJURY PREVENTION STRATEGIC PLAN
PROJECT WHICH IS WHAT I'M NOT
JUST A LONG.
WAY OF JUST SAYING WERE CHARGED
WITH TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET DROWNING POISONING FALLS ON
A WINDOWS TRAFFIC TEEN DRIVER --
ISSUES TAKEN CARE OF IN THE
STATE SO THAT IS NOT THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH AND
HOSPITALIZATION OR STATE.
THIS BILL IS AN AWFULLY
IMPORTANT BILL BUT IT'S A TOUGH --
ONE WE OF ADDED FOR OVER THE
YEARS A NUMBER OF THINGS IS THE
SENATOR HAS HAS IDENTIFIED --
FLASHING LIGHTS STOP ARMS --
WE'VE -- IN ELEVATED AT THE DMV
ON THE DRIVER TOUTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF STOPPING BEHIND
THE BOSS IN IN FRONT OF THE BUS.
YET NOW WE'RE UP TO THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION VIOLATIONS A YEAR
AND THESE ARE NOT CARS CREEPING
BY THE BUS THESE ARE.
THESE ARE CARS SPEEDING BY A
SCHOOL BUS -- WE HAD THERE'S A
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT HOW MANY
TIMES CHILDREN ARE HIT IN OUR
STATE BUT WE HAD WENT BACK AND
HAD THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY GO INTO OUR OWN YOU SEE
H. P..
SWEATERS COLLISION DATA WE
IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE TIMES IN THE LAST TEN YEARS
THAT CHILDREN HAVE BEEN HIT.
SO SOME WILL FATAL SEVERAL
SERIOUS BUT THERE'S A
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THAT BUT BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE HAVE SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
THESE ARE CHILDREN FROM
PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS.
USING THE BUS SYSTEM BECAUSE OUR
PARENTS ARE WORKING TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND YET WE ARE ALLOWING
THREE POINT.
SEVEN DODD MILLION DRIVERS TO
SPEED BY THEIR BOSSES IT'S WERE
CREATING A SITUATION WHERE IT IS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A STOP LAW.
ON OUR BOOKS WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT OKAY WHAT ELSE DO WE NEED TO
DO TO PROTECT THESE CHILDREN
THIS IS A SERIOUS THIS IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
SO WE'RE SPONSORING THIS
LEGISLATION AFTER LOOKING AT
SIXTEEN OTHER STATES WERE TAKING
THE VERY BEST PRACTICES AND
PIECES OF THE VERY BEST
PRACTICES IN OTHER STATES. TO
PUT INTO OUR VEHICLE CODE THE
STRUCTURE THAT COSTS US
CALIFORNIA'S WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IF A SCHOOL DISTRICT DECIDES ON
ITS OWN THAT IT WANTS TO TRY TO
USE THIS TO PROTECT ITS CHILDREN.
THIS DOES NOT REQUIRED TO DO IT
BUT IT DOES GET US GOING DOWN
THE ROAD OF WHAT DOES IT LOOK
LIKE WHAT ARE THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
WHAT ARE THE RIGHTS OF THAT
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
OF THE DRIVERS OF THE STUDENTS --
HOW DO WE PAY FOR IT ALL THAT IS
BUILT INTO THIS BUT YOU CAN'T
SHARE THIS DATA WITH ANYBODY BUT
THE TRAFFIC ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
IN THAT JURISDICTION?
SO THERE'S A LOT OF DETAIL IN
THIS BILL THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT
MORE WE JUST TOOK SOME MORE --
GOOD AMENDMENTS ABOUT NOT
INCENTIVIZING ANY OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO WRITE A INCENTIVE
IS ATION CONTRACT WITH THE
VENDOR.
BUT WE'RE FACED WITH SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND KIDS.
THAT WE'RE SETTING A MOP. TO BE
NERVOUS AND SCARED SIMPLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO THEIR
SCHOOL BUSES AND THEY ARE
GETTING HIT BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THOUSANDS OF THEM DON'T GET HERE
BUT THEY HAVE TO DODGE THE CARS
AND THAT'S NOT RIGHT AND I THINK
IS A STATE WE CAN DO BETTER AND
THIS IS A GOOD STEP FORWARD FOR
FRAMING UP.
ANOTHER WAY OF DOING IT SIXTEEN
STATES A MOVE FORWARD THEY'RE
GETTING A 40% AND A 50%
REDUCTION IN THEIR IN THEIR
VIOLATIONS AND I GO THROUGH THAT
DETAIL IF YOU WANT TO ASK BUT
THANK YOU FOR HEARING THE BILL
WE HOPE YOU MOVE IT FORWARD WERE
TRIPLE REFERRED BE.
OUT TO MORE COMMITTEES TO GO
THROUGH I'M SURE THEY'LL BE MORE
MORE AMENDMENTS TO TIGHTEN UP
HOW THIS WORKS FOR US IN
CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN SCHOOLS DO
NOT WE'RE NOT TELLING THEM THEY
HAVE TO USE THIS.
YEAH BUT ON ANYWAY SO THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WITNESSES WOULD BE
SANTOS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE ONE
EXPRESSED APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY.
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THE VIDEO
TECHNOLOGY WILL BE USED
CURRENTLY FOR THE PURPOSE FOR
WHICH IT WAS INTENDED NOT FOR
EMPLOYEE DISCRIMINATION -- AS
WAS.
ILLUSTRATED IN THE ANALYSIS OUR
SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS THAT WE
REPRESENT ARE TASKED WITH
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
CROSSING KIDS ACROSS THE STREET.
IN ADDITION TO THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH WHICH
THEIR IMPARTED JUST TRANSPORTING
KIDS THEY TAKE THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY.
THE PROBLEM IS OTHER DRIVERS
DON'T ARM.
I KNOW THAT THIS BODY DOES NOT
LEGISLATE BY ANECDOTE BUT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HELP INFORM THE CONVERSATION IF
I SHARE MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AS A MOM WHO WALKS HER THREE
KIDS ACROSS THE STREET. TO
SCHOOL ALL RIGHT WHEN THE SCHOOL
BUSES ARE PARKED THERE SO THE
SCHOOL BUSES ARE PARKED THERE
I'M WALKING IN A DESIGNATED
CROSSING LOCK.
THERE IS A CROSSING GUARD THERE
IN YELLOW BLAZER AND STOP SIGN
AND I CANNOT COUNT THE NUMBER OF
TIMES I'M NOT I'M NOT KIDDING I
CANNOT COUNT THE NUMBER OF TIMES.
SOMEONE HAS DISOBEYED THE LAW
AND SPED THROUGH THE CROSSWALK
WHILE I AM TRYING TO WALK MY
CHILD.
WITH THEIR HAND ACROSS THE
STREET SO THIS DOESN'T JUST
INCREASED SAFETY FOR THOSE KIDS
RIDING THE SCHOOL BUSES A
GUARANTEE IT'LL INCREASE SAFETY
FOR THOSE KIDS WHO ARE TRYING TO
BE TRANSPORED ACROSS THE STREET
AS WELL. FOR THOSE REASONS RUN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU --
THANK YOU A WE HAVE OTHER PEOPLE
IT'S SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS KATHY BRING
IN CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN SAFETY AND HEALTH IN
SUPPORT A OTHER SUPPORTERS
PLEASE -- WE HEAR ANY OPPOSITION
FOR THE BILL PLEASE COME
[inaudible]
FOR OPPOSITION -- HAVE A SEAT
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SPELL -- WE
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THE
VERY IMPORTANT GOAL OF
PROTECTING CHILDREN HOWEVER WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF PRIVACY
CONCERNS RELATED TO THIS BILL.
ANY TIME AT THE GOVERNMENT
IMPLEMENTS A NEW SYSTEM FOR THE
AUTOMATED COLLECTION OF LARGE
AMOUNTS OF DATA.
SUCH AS THE USE OF RED LIGHT
CAMERAS OR THE AUTOMATED SCHOOL
BUS VIDEO ENFORCEMENT SYSTEMS.
THAT WOULD BE AUTHORIZED BY THIS
BILL.
THERE IS A DANGER TO INDIVIDUAL
PRIVACY.
AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INCLUSION OF SOME
LIMITATIONS ON PROTECTIONS SB
THREE SEVENTY ONE STILL FAILS TO
PUT IN PLACE BASIC NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS TO PREVENT THE
MISUSE OF THE INFORMATION
GATHERED. FOR EXAMPLE SB THREE
SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT INCLUDE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THE USE OF
AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATE READER
TECHNOLOGY WHICH CAN BE USED TO
COMPILE DATABASES OF INFORMATION.
CAPTURED BY A SCHOOL BUS CAMERA
THAT CAN THEN BE USED TO TRACK
THE LOCATIONS OF VEHICLES AND
THE PEOPLE ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
VEHICLES.
NOR DOES THE BILL PROHIBIT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM SHARING THE
INFORMATION COLLECTED ALTHOUGH
THE VENDORS THEY CONTRACT WITH
ARE SUBJECT TO THAT RESTRICTION.
THE DANGERS OF COLLECTING THE
DATA ARE HEIGHTENED BY THE
NINETY DAY RETENTION PERIOD FOR
THE RECORDINGS.
FAR LONGER THAN IS NECESSARY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ENFORCING THE LAW.
AND LIKE I SAID WE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THAT
THE VERY IMPORTANT GOALS OF THIS
LEGISLATION BUT WE UNFORTUNATELY
MUST OPPOSE IT BASED ON THESE
PRIVACY CONCERNS THANK YOU.
OKAY OTHERS SPEAKERS OPPOSING.
I DON'T SEE ANY [inaudible]
OF OKAY -- SIR RAFEAL QUESTION.
STILL.
THERE STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M --
CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONCEPT I'M.
FRANKLY FRIGHTENED BY THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO.
DISREGARD RED LIGHTS BOTH IN.
CITIES AND EARLIER AROUND THE
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION VEHICLES
AND IN MY EXPERIENCE I'VE BEEN A
FEW CITIES IN MY FAIRLY LONG
LIFE AND FRANKLY THIS ONCE THE
WORST.
BUT LET ME ASK A QUESTION ABOUT
THE PROCESS FOR DEALING WITH THE
VIDEO CAPTURES SO.
I'M FAMILIAR WITH VIDEO -- AND
PHOTOS THAT ARE TAKEN HAVE BEEN
TAKEN BY THE CITY RED LIGHT
CAMERAS.
AND THE FIDELITY IS PRETTY GOOD.
AND THE PHOTOS ARE OF BOTH THE
VEHICLE AND THE DRIVER IN THE
VEHICLE.
SO.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
AMENDMENTS CHANGED TO PUT A NOTE
IN THE ANALYSIS IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE THE VIDEO
CAPTURE IS GOING TO BE OF THE
VEHICLE NONE OF THE PASSENGERS
OR THE DRIVERS AT THE CASE.
YEAH THESE THESE CATS THESE
CAMERAS ARE DIFFERENT THAN THE
THAN THE INTERSECTION CAMPUSES
ALSO IS A CIVIL CITATION --
THAT'S BEING -- CONTEMPLATED IN
THE BILL AND THE CIVIL CITATION
IS DIFFERENT IT IS -- CITATION
AGAINST THE VEHICLE SO LIKE YOU
OTHER CITATIONS LIKE A PARKING
TICKET OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO ASSIGN SO
IF YOU GET A CIVIL CITATION ON
YOU YOU SPEED PAST THE BUS
CAMERA TAKES THE PHOTOGRAPH OF
THE VEHICLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DETERMINES AL THAT WAS A
VIOLATION THEY SEND YOU A
CITATION.
HE SAID WELL THAT WAS MY
NEIGHBOR DRIVING MY CAR THAT DAY
OR THAT WAS MY SON YOU ARE
ALLOWED TO ASSIGN AND THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUST BY CURRENT
STATUTE IN CODE.
THEY MUST RE ASSIGN THE TICKET
OR THE CITATION OVER -- THE IT
IS NOT THE SAME AS IF A TRAFFIC
OFFICER OR RED LIGHT CAMERA
CAUGHT YOU IN AN INTERSECTION
IT'S NOT THE SAME AS IF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER PULLS YOU
OVER -- IAN WITNESSES YOU DOING
THIS THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT
BALLGAME.
SO DO THE THE AMENDMENTS
CONTEMPLATE.
TO OF A LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY REVIEWING THE VIDEO
CAPTURE.
DOES THAT MEAN THE AGENCY HAS
THE DISCRETION TO DEEM A
VIOLATION NOT TO HAVE OCCURRED
UNDER THE VEHICLE CODE.
YES.
THEY DO AND WHAT'S THE TIME
LIMIT FOR THE TIME FRAME IN
WHICH SHOULD SOMEONE WHO'S
VEHICLE IS UTILIZED IN AN
IMPROPER WAY.
WHAT'S THE TIME LINE TO A DUTY
ASSIGNMENT.
RIGHT NOW IN THE BILL THEY HAVE
NINETY DAYS TO RETAIN THE VIDEO --
ACLU IS ASKING FOR THAT TO BE
SHORTER BECAUSE AND WE AGREE
WITH THEM WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS ONLY USE FOR
TRAFFIC VIA THIS SPECIFIC.
TRAFFIC VIOLATION AND SO --
WE'VE ALREADY SPOKEN TO THE
AUTHOR ABOUT AMENDING THE BILL
AND TIGHTENING DOWN THAT -- THE
TIME FRAME HOUSE TO BE MUCH
SHORTER BECAUSE IT IS JUST A
CIVIL CITATION -- THAT -- THAT
THE VIN THE THAT VIDEO IN FILMS
ARE DESTROYED IN LAS THE DRIVER
HAS A RIGHT TO SEE -- MANASSE
FORM BUT NOBODY ELSE HAS A RIGHT
TO GET THROUGH THOSE THAT THAT
INFORMATION AND THAT HAS TO BE
TIGHTENED UP IN THE BILL.
ABOUT -- THAT IT CAN'T BE SHARED
BEYOND THE TRAFFIC ENFORCEMENT
ENTITY THAT IS DOING THE
DETERMINATION IN THAT
JURISDICTION ONLY -- SO THE
THERE IS SOME WORK TO DO ON
SHORTENING THE TIME FRAME BUT
RIGHT NOW THE BILL HAS A NINETY
DAY -- ACLU IS SAYING THAT'S TOO
LONG BECAUSE THE LENGTH OF TIME
THAT VIDEO SITS THERE.
SOMEBODY COULD DO SOME NEFARIOUS
THINGS WITH IT.
WE AGREE THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
DOING IT WE DON'T AGREE THAT
THAT EVERY TIME THERE IS OF OF
VIDEO SYSTEM THAT THERE'S
SOMEBODY TRYING TO USE IT FOR
SOMETHING -- TO SHARE IT WITH
SOMETHING WRONG BUT WE THINK
THAT WE DO NEED TO TAKE -- AND
WE HAVE A JUDICIAL COMMITTEE
COMING -- HEARING COMING UP TO
TAKE A MEMBERS FURTHER
AMENDMENTS REDRESS THERE WERE
FOUR ISSUES AT A CO YOU PUT IT
ON AND WE HAVE AMENDMENTS FOR
ALL FOUR OF THEM.
AND IT WILL BE MEETING WITH THEM
BUT I MEAN I WANT TO MAKE SURE
SO THIS IS IF THIS IS A CIVIL
VIOLATION BUT IF YOU COMMITTED.
A IS THERE NOT A IS THERE NOT A
POINTS SYSTEM WITH RESPECT TO
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE AND THE
DMV.
THOUGH THIS WILL BILL IS -- IS
IT SETS OF DATA BASE FIND ON
LIKE A TICKET IF YOU GET PULLED
OVER BY AN OFFICER IS FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THREE POINTS IN
YOUR RECORD.
AT ALL ON THE AND AND THEN THE
COURTS ADULTS SEVEN TO NINE
HUNDRED DOLLAR -- COURT FEE SO
IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE TICKET IF
YOU GET CAPTURED HERE IT'S A
VERY IT'S A BASE FIGHT.
TO FIFTY OF FOR THE FIRST FIVE
HUNDRED FOR THE SECOND NO COURT
FIND NOTE NO POINTS.
I MUST HAVE THE WRONG ANALYSIS.
WITH I'M LOOKING I'M LOOKING AT
ONE HERE LET ME JUST READ IT TO
YOU.
THE TOTAL FINE FOR THE FIRST
VIOLATION KOONING ALSO SEATED
FEES AS A MINIMUM MINIMUM OF
SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY SIX DOLLARS.
AND A MAXIMUM OF ONE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
DOLLARS.
IT ALSO IS A POINT TO THE
DRIVER'S RECORD.
AS WITH MANY TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS
THE COURT MAY PERMIT A VIOLATOR
TO INSTEAD PARTICIPATING TRAFFIC
SCHOOL FOR A FIRST OFFENSE.
AND THEN IT GOES ON TO TALK
ABOUT.
BUT WHOEVER WROTE THIS THAT WAS
A SEVERE PENALTY SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE GENESIS FOR MY
QUESTION BECAUSE HAVING.
HAVING BEEN IN CITIES WHERE YOU
HAVE TRAFFIC CAMERAS AND THIS
CURRENTLY THE PROCESS IS NOT
MUCH DIFFERENT THAN THE PROCESS
YOU'VE OUTLINED HERE.
WERE A OF A PEACE OFFICER OR A
PANEL OF RETIRED PEACE OFFICERS
VIEW THE THE PICTURE OF THE
FOOTAGE TO DETERMINE WHETHER A
VIOLATION HAS OCCURRED.
AND THEN DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT A CIVIL CITATION IS SENT.
THE REASON I ASK.
THE REASON I ASKED THE QUESTION
ABOUT THE TIME LINE IS THERE
THERE'S SOME TIME LINE AT LEAST
UNDER THE MUNICIPAL TRAFFIC
CAMERA PROGRAM.
IN WHICH SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT
DRIVING THE CAR HAS THE ABILITY.
TO RAISE HIS OR HER HAND AND SAY
IT'S NOT ME IT'S HIM.
AND THEN THERE'S A SHIFTING OF
RESPONSIBILITY AND PRESUMABLY A
SHIFTING OF THE OF THE POINT AND
IF YOU MISS IT HOWEVER YOU'RE
SUNK.
AND YOU ARE YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
TO COURT BUT YOU HAVE THE ISSUE
OF GOING TO DRIVING SCHOOL.
IN LIEU OF HAVING A POINT ASSIST
AGAINST YOUR LICENSE SO AND BACK
TO MY QUESTION.
HOW MUCH TIME DOES YOUR?
PROCESS CONTEMPLATE BECAUSE I
ASSUME IF YOUR MUNICIPALITY
THERE'S A PROCESS THAT YOU PUT
IN PLACE IN TERMS OF HOW THIS
WORKS.
THIS BILL DOESN'T SEEM TO PUT
THAT IN PLACE YEAH WE HAVE LIKE
I SAID WE HAVE SOME MORE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE TO WORK
OUT OF THE TIME FRAMES.
WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE THE BASS
LIKE -- MONTGOMERY COUNTY
MARYLAND IS THE SYSTEM THAT WERE
TRYING TO MIMIC RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THEY HAVE ONE OF THE
BEST SYSTEMS.
THEY HAVE A SHORT SEVERAL WEEK
TIMEFRAME THAT THEY DO THE
REVIEW.
AT THE END THEYONLY CHARGE A
BASE FINE.
THEY ACTUALLY FOUND THAT TO LOW
BASE FIND DIDN'T GET THEM THE
REDUCTION IN VIOLATIONS BUT THEN
WHEN THEY WENT TO TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BUT THEY DID FIND THAT
IF THEY LEFT THE POINTS OFF THEY
HAVE THE SAME SYSTEM WE HAVE A
FOOT.
TRAFFIC OFFICER PULLED YOU OVER
IN THE IN AT THE RANDY WROTE THE
ANALYSIS WAS RIGHT THAT IF YOU
GET PULLED OVER THIS IS A PRETTY
STE THIS IS A RIDICULOUSLY STEEP
FINE.
BUT THE INTENT HERE IS TO HAVE
THE CITATION. TO BE  BASE FINE
NO POINTS CIVIL PENALTY. FOR THE
FIRST ONE TO TO EDUCATE YOU IF
YOU GET HIT BY THE THIRD ONE
DEAD AT ALL BETS ARE OFF WELL.
LISTEN LISTEN I'M NOT
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE SITE
NECESSARILY ABOUT THE SIZE OF
THE FILE AND WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT KIDS ON SCHOOL BUSES AND
PEOPLE STOPPING WHEN.
THE LIGHTS ARE FLASHING IN THE
SUN IS OUT.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
IT'S MY CAR BUT I'M NOT DRIVE
AND THEN I'VE GOT TEN DAYS OR
FIFTEEN DAYS WHERE THE BELLS GO
OFF.
AND I HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SAY
IT'S NOT MY CAR THAT'S MY CAR
BUT SHE WAS DRIVING IT.
IF I ONE OF FIVE ONE A YOU KNOW
FINGER MY NEIGHBOR -- I DO THAT
AND THEN AVOID HAVING THE
PROBLEM SO THAT'S MY CONCERN I
WILL STOP TALKING MISS CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION THE BILL IS SILENT ON
THAT RIGHT NOW WE'VE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW. TO DEAL
WITH THAT EXACT ISSUE AND AND WE
EXPECT TO BE DOING AMENDMENTS ON
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR OUTLINING
THE NEED FOR IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CENTER STONE AN ANSWER -- DODD
THAT SURCHARGE YOU WANNA
[inaudible]
WHAT?
SO I GUESS WHAT I'M WONDERING IS
ARE THERE POINTS WITH THIS NOW
WELL THERE IS THERE IS THE WAY
IT'S WRITTEN WE ANTICIPATE DOING
AMENDMENTS -- THE THAT THE
ANALYSIS RAISE SOME ISSUE AS
WELL AS THE OPPOSITION WERE
TOTALLY PREPARED TO WORK WITH
WITH EVERYBODY BUT RIGHT NOW
IT'S AT ONE POINT AND IT'S A BIG
FINE AND WE DON'T ANTICIPATE.
GOING FORWARD THAT WE DO THAT DO
IT THAT WAY WE'RE JUST BILL GO
NEXT.
IT'S TRIPLE REFERRED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE HITTING ALL THE
COMMITTEES IN THE SENATE THE
INTENT IS NOT YET OUT POINTS ON
ON THIS THIS KIND OF A CITATION.
THIS IS A TRIPLE PLAY BILL.
CONSIDER STONE WERE USED TO IT
EVERY CHILDREN'S SAFETY BILLS
FOR OKAY GO AHEAD THANK YOU ARE
STUCK IN SINCE HER FIRST BY ONE
APPLY AND CENTER CABALLERO. FOR
BRINGING A BILL LIKE THIS
FORWARD. ONE DEATH IS TOO MUCH --
HAVING A CHILD -- WALKING ACROSS
THE STREET AT AT A BUS STOP --
BUT I BUT I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AND I FUNDING FOR
FINDING VERY HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT I'M ACTUALLY AGREEING WITH
THE ACLU ON AN ISSUE FOR THE
FIRST TIME I THINK FIVE YEARS
THAT WE'VE.
BEEN HERE BUT JUST A COUPLE OF
THINGS -- WHEN I WAS ON THE TO
MAKE IT A CITY COUNCIL WE ARE A
NEW CITY -- PEOPLE WERE GOING
THROUGH RED LIGHTS BLATANTLY I
MEAN IT WAS JUST RIDICULOUS Là
REMEMBER.
SITTING IN A CITY COUNCIL
MEETING I SAID WHAT WE NEED WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THIS AND I'VE.
PUT TOGETHER PROGRAM CALLED THE
SLAP PROGRAM STOPLIGHT ABUSE
PROGRAM AND AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND RIPPED INTO MACULA AND AND
THE FIRST THE FIRST WEEKEND I
WAS DOING THAT.
THEY WILL THREE HUNDRED
CITATIONS [inaudible]
THREE HUNDRED AND THE STOPLIGHT
ABUSE WENT AWAY IMMEDIATELY SO --
INCREASE ENFORCEMENT I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING IS NECESSARY AND
THEN -- SOME MUNICIPALITIES IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ORKS FOR
AMENDING WITH UP WITH CAMERAS
AND I'LL TELL YOU.
IF THERE'S ONE THING THAT EVOKED
A LOT OF ANGER WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS IT WAS A STOP LIGHT
CAMERAS -- THEY CAME TO OUR
COUNCIL MEETINGS AND COMPLAIN
AND WHAT THEY ACTUALLY DID WAS
ACTUALLY BECAUSE A LOT OF
ACCIDENTS BECAUSE YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT COULD COULD OF GONE
THROUGH WITH THE SAFETY LOS AND
I'M NOT TAKING ANY CHANCES.
SLAMMED ON THEIR BRAKES AND REAR
REAR ENDED WE HAD A LOT OF
ACCIDENTS AND IT GOT TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY ACTUALLY TOOK
OUT ALL OF THE CAMERAS.
SO THAT THAT LEADS ME TO A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THEY WERE
COMPARING THE STOP LIGHT CAMERAS
WITH THE CAMP THE OTHER CAMERAS
IS GOING TO BE ON THE BUS. FOR
ANIMAL I KNOW I NOTICE BUT
HERE'S THE DEAL AT LEAST WHEN
YOU'RE GOING INTO A TRAFFIC
SIGNAL KNOWS A CAMERA THERE YOU
GET A FOR WARNING.
THAT A RED LIGHT IS COMING UP.
IN THIS BILL ARE YOU GOING TO
HAVE A A YELLOW SIGN THAT SAYS A
A RED STOP ORDER IS GOING TO BE
COMING NEXT AND IT'S GONNA
PREPARE PEOPLE DRIVING BY.
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THEY BETTER
STOP IF NOT THEY'RE GOING TO GET
A ELEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
DOLLAR.
TICKET OR ARE WE GOING TO HAVE
PEOPLE THAT.
ARE NOT PAYING ATTENTION AS MOST
PEOPLE ARE NOT AS ARE DRIVING
THEIR TEXTING THERE ARE YOU
MAILING THERE.
LISTEN TO THE MUSIC -- SOME
PEOPLE ARE GONNA DRIVE BY NOT
PAY ATTENTION UP PEOPLE ARE
GONNA SLAMMED THE BRAKES ON IN A
SEA OF RED STOP SIGN AND YOU'RE
GONNA SEE TRAFFIC COLLISIONS.
AND PROBABLY MORBIDITY AND
POTENTIALLY MORE MORTALITY WHICH
I DON'T WANT TO SEE BUT HOW HOW
WOULD HOW WOULD WE GIVE WARNINGS
TOUR BUSES RIGHT NOW WHEN
THEY'RE GOING TO DO STOP THEY
HAVE AN AMBER LIGHT COMES ON
WHEN THEY'RE ABOUT TO STOP THAT
GIVES EVERYBODY BEHIND A MAN IN.
FRONT OF ON A WARNING THAT THE
SCHOOL BUSES ABOUT TO STOP.
AND THEN -- WHEN THEY DO PULL
OVER THE REDS COME ON AND THEY
FOR THE FLASHING REDS ARE ON AND
THEN THE STOP ARM ACTUALLY A
STOP SIGN IN YOU YOU FOLKS ALL
PUT THAT ON THE BUSES RIGHT TO
TRY TO PROTECT THE KIDS?
SO THE THIS BEST A STOP SIGN
POPS OUT ON THE SIDE OF THE BUS.
SO THERE IS AN AMBER SO THERE'S
A WARNING TIME PERIOD.
THERE IS ALSO A WARNING TIME
HERE WHERE THEY ASSUME THAT
LIGHT TRUCKS ARE MOVING ALONG
SIDE ABBAS AND THEY GO TO PULL
ROOM THEY STOP.
THERE IS A LIKE SIX SECONDS
BEFORE THE STOP ARM COMES OUT.
THAT ALLOWS BUT EVERYBODY ELSE
YOU KNOW THERE'S A AMBER.
SCHOOL BUS PULLS OVER YOUR
BEHIND HIM YOU KNOW IF THAT'S
GOING TO STOP RED LIGHTS ARE
FLASHING YOU KNOW YOUR TO YOU TO
SAY THAT I KNOW I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE I USED TO BE A PARAMEDIC
AND WE HAD ALL KINDS OF THINGS
ARE UNITS AND I GOT.
HIT THREE TIMES BY DRIVERS THAT
JUST DON'T PAY ATTENTION BUT THE
PROBLEM IS.
THIS WORKS.
IN THE STATE SET OF USERS
THEY'VE THEY'VE HAD A 40% DROP
IN GEORGIA.
IN MARYLAND THEY'VE HAD A 50%
DROP IN VIOLATIONS.
THEY HAVE NOT AS MANY KIDS WE
HAVE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND KIDS
RIGHT BETTER DEPENDED ON THE
SAFETY THESE BUSES THESE BOSSES
ARE ISLANDS THEY'RE NOT LIKE AN
INTERSECTION EVERYBODY KNOWS
THERE'S AN INTERSECTION HERE'S A
LIGHT IT'S BEEN THERE FOREVER I
DRIVE THROUGH THERE RIGHT.
BUSES ARE ISLANDS THEY MOVE
AROUND AND THEY'RE THE ONLY
THING TO PROTECT THOSE KIDS AND
UNFORTUNATELY EVERYTHING WE'VE
DONE HERE IN THIS LEGISLATURE
EVERYTHING WE'VE ADDED ON WE'VE
GOTTEN SOME PROTECTION. THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION VIOLATIONS
AND THESE ARE SPEEDING CARS
THESE ARE NOT LIKE CRAWLS BY.
AND SO IT'S A DIFFERENT ANIMAL I
KNOW IT'S HARD TO KIND OF LIKE
YOU GET AWAY FROM OKAY RED LIGHT.
RED LIGHT.
INTERSECTION HAS THESE.
BIG PROBLEMS.
THIS IS A SCHOOL BUS SITUATION
THESE CAMERAS ARE EVEN DIFFERENT
THE PIXEL RATE ON A MORE
DIFFERENT.
THEY'RE A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY.
AND FOR THE FIRST SIX MONTHS IN
THAT JURISDICTION'S THERE'S
BILLBOARDS TO HAVE TO BE PUT UP
THEIR SPECIAL SIGNAGE ON THE
BACK OF THE BUS IS THAT YOU HAVE
TO ADD.
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THIS IS A DIFFERENT
ANIMAL THAN AN INTERSECTION OKAY
AND CAN YOU ELABORATE I KNOW
THERE ARE SPECIAL INSTANCES --
ON A SCHOOL BUS WHEN THE SCHOOL
BUS DRIVER ACTUALLY NEEDS TO GET
OUT AN ESCORT THE STUDENTS
ACROSS ACROSS WALKER WHERE CAN
YOU ELABORATE ON THAT.
NOW I KNOW IN ALL THE FOLLOWING
THAT GOT THAT RULE THERE'S A LOT
THERE'S A THERE'S A A LAW IS A
GOOD LAW IT SAYS THAT THE SCHOOL
BUS DRIVERS.
MUST GET OFF AND AND AND I
ESCORT.
CHILDREN WHERE THEY THINK THAT
IT'S THERE THAT'S NECESSARY TO
DO THAT.
THE PRODUCT BUT IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE THEM TO DO IT.
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT IS
SPECIAL IN RURAL AREAS LIKE YOU
KNOW CENTER MCGUIRE IS GONE NOW
BUT AND CENTER REQUIRES ORIENT
AND FALL OUT YOUR RIVERSIDE AREA.
IT'S A LONG BUS RIDE FOR THOSE
KIDS.
IF THE IF THE DRIVER GOT OFF
EVERY TIME.
IT WOULDN'T BE AN HOUR RIDE IT
WOULD BE A TWO ARE RIGHT IT IS
JUST NOT PRACTICAL BUT THE LAWS
THERE.
AND THEY CAN AND THEY SHOULD AND
THEY DO GET OFF TO PROTECT THOSE
KIDS UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF THE
THINGS WE FOUND IN THE UC
BERKELEY ANALYSIS OF THE DATA.
WE SUSPECT THAT A COUPLE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE HIT AROUND
THOSE BOSSES WERE THE DRIVERS.
AND WE'RE STILL TRYING TO WE
CAN'T READ THE REST OF THE
REPORT WE CAN ONLY READ THAT
THERE IS A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
PEOPLE YET.
GOING TO OR FROM THE SCHOOL BUS
SO.
YEAH BUT YOU'RE RIGHT IN THE ONE
WHICH IS FINAL QUESTION -- YES
SIR WHO IS GOING TO BE THE
BENEFICIARY OF THE THE REVENUES
GENERATED BY THE THE TICKETING
IF YOU WILL.
WHAT I WAS GONNA BE REVENUE
SHARING OF THAT THE TICKETS?
THE BILL OF THE REVENUE IT'S
IT'S THE SAME AS YOUR WE DON'T
CHANGE THE CURRENT SHARING A LOT
EXCEPT FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ALLOWED. TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
THE THE CITY AND COUNTY
JURISDICTIONS TO USE SOME OF THE
FINEST ARRIVE TO PAY FOR THE
SYSTEM.
AND THEY CAN ONLY DO THAT THEY
CAN'T INCENTIVIZE FOR YOU KNOW
YOU GET A WHOLE BUNCH MORE
TICKETS THEY CAN'T DO THAT IN
THE CONTRACTS.
BUT THE IT'S PAID -- FOR BECAUSE
SCHOOLS WERE NOT.
HANDING THE SCHOOLS EXTRA MONEY
THE SCHOOLS PAY FOR THIS AND ALL
THE OTHER STATES USE THAT THEY
PAY FOR IT OUT OF THE OF FINES
BUT IS NEGOTIATED WITH THE
ENTITIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T CHANGE THE THE HOW IT'S
STRUCTURED NOW.
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEY HAVE THE
SAFETY PROGRAMS ALL GET THEIR
THEIR SHARE EXCEPT FOR THEY CAN
TAKE SOME OF THE MONEY TO PAY
FOR THE SYSTEM.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN YOUR BILL
SENATOR THAT -- HE IS A A A
VOLUME INCENTIVE FOR THE MORE
CITATIONS ARE ISSUED THE MORE
REVENUE THAT IS COLLECTED OR
JUST A FLAT FEE FOR THE LEASE OF
THE CAMERAS AND WHATEVER
REVENUES THAT'S ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS.
PROPOSING THAT OKAY.
IN THAT REVENUE IS ONLY TO
RECOVER THE COSTS OF THE SYSTEM.
THE PROBLEM IS IN THE
MUNICIPALITIES THANK YOU MISTER.
OF CENTER BROUGHT UP THE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS -- ARE
ACCEPTED BY THE OFFICERS CENTER --
SAID.
BUT THEY WILL BE X. PUT INTO
PLAY IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NOT NOT TODAY OKAY SO WILL THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ACCEPTED ONLY PUT
IN. TO PLAY IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE OKAY -- SIR SIR YOU
HAVE ANY -- ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
NO I REALLY THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE.
THE CONVERSATION AND I WERE
TAKING IT INTO ACCOUNT AND
YOU'LL SEE A MEN'S COME FORWARD
IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
OF CENTER -- WHEN I WAS IN
SEVENTH GRADE -- A HEARD A CRASH
AND IT WAS A BLOCK AWAY FROM MY
HOME AND SO A A WALK DOWN.
TO THE NEARBY CORNER AND THERE
WAS SOME.
A SCHOOL BUS.
AND WHAT HAPPEN IS A SCHOOL BUS
STOPPED.
AND A BUNCH OF STUDENTS GOT OFF
THE BUS [inaudible]
AND ON OUR SIDE OF THE STREET TO
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE STREET
FROM THE SCHOOL BUS SO LITTLE
BOY WAS IN THIRD GRADE.
RAN ACROSS THE STREET TO GREET
HIS SISTER WHO IS I THINK IN THE
EIGHTH GRADE OR NINTH GRADE.
AND A CAR RAN RAN THROUGH THE
RED -- THE STOP SIGN AND KILLED
THE BOY.
SO EVER SINCE THEN IT'S BEEN ON
MY MIND.
AND THAT'S KIND OF DRIVEN ME ON
THIS.
TRAFFIC SAFETY ISSUE IT'S ALWAYS
IN MY MIND.
SO I WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
AMENDMENTS FOR THIS AND ARJUNA
VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION CENTER OKAY
THANK YOU -- CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
WITH THE SENATE BILL. THREE
SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR CABALLERO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE.
NO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STONE.
STONE NO I'M BURKE WHAT CASKEY.
OKAY WE HAVE TO VOTE IN FAVOR TO
POSE WE HAVE ABSENT MEMBERS
SMALL -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KEEP THE ROLL OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SURGERY HILLS OR
YEAH YES ITEM TWELVE THIS IS SB --
SIX TWENTY FIVE SIR HILL.
ARE YOU OF THE FLOOR IN THIS
ITEM THANK YOU MATT -- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF A LOOPHOLE
IN CURRENT LAW MAKES IT LEGAL
FOR PASSENGERS TO SMOKE CANNABIS
IN A PARTY BUS LIMO TAXI OR TNC.
AS A RESULT SOME PARTY BUSES AND
LIMO OPERATORS ARE OFFERING
CANNABIS DISPENSARY TOWARDS
SIMILAR TO EXISTING TOWARDS FOR
WINERIES OR BREWERIES.
MODEL AFTER STATUTES FOR ALCOHOL
BUSES IN LIMOS SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE WILL PROHIBIT.
CANNABIS USE IN THESE VEHICLES
UNLESS SAFETY STANDARDS ARE
FOLLOWED.
SPECIFICALLY SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
MAKES IT ILLEGAL FOR A PASSENGER
ANY PARTY BUS OR LIMO TO SMOKE
OR VAPOR CANNABIS.
UNLESS THE DRIVER'S COMPARTMENT
IS SEALED OFF AND SEPARATELY
VENTILATED.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE DRIVER IS NOT
IMPAIRED IF CANNABIS SMOKE IS
CONSUMED IN ONE OF THESE FOR
HIGHER VEHICLES THE BILL ALSO
PROHIBITS ANYONE.
UNDER TWENTY ONE FROM BEING ON
BOARD IF CANNABIS SMOKE IS
PRESENT.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE WILL
ESTABLISH SAFETY RULES TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND ELIMINATE
BAD ACTORS.
HAS REBEL MEMBERS ESPECIALLY
THIS IS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
CC OR CC I A WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY FIVE WHICH
PROHIBITS THE INGESTION OF
CANNABIS AND CANVAS PRODUCTS AND
CHARTER BUSES TAXICABS IN
LIMOUSINES -- AS THE AUTHOR
NOTED -- ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS TOURISM
ASSOCIATION IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
SIDE TWO HUNDRED AND 99%.
WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TOURISTS VISITING
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR WE CAN
ASSUME MANY OF THESE TOURISTS
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEWLY COMPLIANT
CANNABIS MARKET.
CCA SUPPORT SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE
CONSUMPTION OF CANNABIS AND
CANVAS PRODUCTS AND BELIEVES THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL ARE IN
FURTHERANCE OF THIS POLICY.
NOT ONLY DOES THE BILL ESTABLISH
APPROPRIATE SAFETY MEASURES THAT
ENSURE CANNABIS IS CONSUMED
RESPONSIBLY AND BY PERSONS
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER.
IT ESTABLISHES APPROPRIATE
INDUSTRY STANDARDS FOR CANNABIS
TOURISM WILL IMPROVE IMPROVING
THE SAFETY OF BOTH PASSENGERS
AND DRIVERS FOR THESE REASONS
CCA STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
SPELLING ENCOURAGES YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY.
WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR
OF THIS BILL -- TO HAVE
WITNESSES OPPOSING THE BILL
PLEASE IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES
COME FOR OPPOSING THE BILL.
OF QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE.
CENTER STONE CENTER RUBIO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IS ON A
COMMITTEE AUTHOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND FINING THE SOUP
HOLDEN -- WE WILL WITHOUT IT WE
COULD HAVE DRIVERS INTOXICATED
WEATHER OUT DOING CANNABIS
STORES SO -- I WHEN I MOVE YOUR
BILL AND LACKEY MATTERS CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SIN
RUBIO PLEASE.
THANK YOU -- AND I DO APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT STEP AND
MAKING SURE THAT OUR OUR YOUTH
IS SAFE I'M JUST I HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF A QUESTION IN TERMS OF
FIVE ENFORCEMENT AND I'M SORRY I
WALKED IN A LITTLE LATE.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT.
WHAT IS THAT ARE LESS THAN
TWENTY YEARS A TWENTY ONE YEARS
OLD ARE NOT IN THE CAR WELL IT'S
SIMILAR TO CURRENTLY THE HIGHWAY
PATROL AND FORCES THE THE
DRIVING REGULATIONS AND THEY
ALSO ENFORCE THE INSPECTION OF
BUSES AND -- AND THOSE WHERE
THIS WOULD BE ALLOWED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE COMPARTMENTS ARE
IN FACT IN THERE ARE VEHICLES IN
IN COLORADO WHERE THEY USE IT
TODAY WHEN THEY HAVE THOSE BUS
TOURS OF OF DEATH CANNABIS IT
TOWARDS RECREATIONALLY AND THE
THE CAB -- THE DRIVER'S
COMPARTMENT IS COMPLETELY SEALED
OFF TO THOSE BUSES ARE AVAILABLE
NAY WOULD BE INSPECTED BY -- THE
HIGHWAY PATROL JUST AS BUSES ARE
TODAY THE ISSUE OF OF ANYONE
TWENTY ONE OR OLDER IN A BUS IS
A SIMILAR TO THE LEGISLATION
I'VE HAD BEFORE.
RELATED TO PARTY BUSES AND
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION ON THOSE
BUSES IN THE SAME REGULATIONS
WOULD APPLY
TO THE USE HERE AS
THEY DO TODAY SO IT'S A MEET THE
THE HIGHWAY PATROL WOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO STOP THOSE LOCAL
POLICE WOULD HAVE ABILITY TO
STOP THOSE AND AND IN FOR SHOULD.
JUST
SERVO CENTER AND WILL KEEP
THE ROLE FROM FRANCE AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES -- STONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL PLEASE.
OKAY SIR STONE AS A FLOOR.
AND HE WILL PRESENT SB.
THREE FORTY HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THANK YOU HONORABLE CHAIR BILL
PART OF THE BUSINESS DAY.
THE REASON [inaudible]
LOW RIDERSHIP.
THE SHOULD NOT COME AS A
SURPRISE US IN THE FRESNO BEE IN
NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR REPORTED
THAT AMTRAK RIDERSHIP IS
DECREASED EACH OF THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
OUR STATE AUDITOR'S ALSO
RELEASED A REPORT.
IT HIGHLIGHTED THAT THE
PROJECTED COSTS FOR THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
BUT THE ESTIMATES NOW REACHING
OVER SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
SADLY THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT ONLY HAS TWELVE POINT
SIX BILLION SECURED IN FINDING.
WHICH IS A MIXTURE FOR PROOF
STATE FUNDS AND FEDERAL FUNDS.
THIS MEANS THAT LESS THAN ONE
SIXTH OF THE FUNDS NEEDED TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECT ARE
AVAILABLE.
HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS ARE ON
THE HOOK FOR ALMOST SIXTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO HAVE A
TRAINED THAT.
THEY CLEARLY DON'T WANT TO USE.
AS A RESULT OF THIS MASSIVE
INCREASE IN COST TO THE
TAXPAYERS PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT HAS
SHARPLY DECLINED.
A U. S. C. LA TIMES POLL EARLY
THIS YEAR SHOWED THAT 49% OF
CALIFORNIANS WANT TO KILL ALL
FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT.
WASTING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON A
PROJECT THAT HAS BEEN SO
HORRIBLY MISMANAGED IS NOW MORE
IMPORTANT THAN IT EVER HAS BEEN.
EVEN OUR GOVERNOR'S GOVERNOR GAS
AT GAVIN NEWSOM AND HIS STATE OF
THE STATE ADMITTED QUOTE.
THE PROJECT IS CURRENTLY PLAN
WOULD COST TOO MUCH.
AND TAKE TOO LONG.
THERE'S BEEN TOO LITTLE
OVERSIGHT.
AND NOT ENOUGH TRANSPARENCY
[inaudible]
END QUOTE [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
THERE SIMPLY ISN'T A PATH TO GET
FROM SACRAMENTO TO SAN DIEGO LET
ALONE SAN FRANCISCO TO LA.
I WISH THERE WERE.
COLLEAGUES I AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR.
SB THREE FORTY WHAT IN THE
FAILED HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
BY STATING THAT.
NO FURTHER BONDS SHALL BE SOLD
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL PURPOSES
PURSUANT TO PROP ONE A EXCEPT.
S. SPECIFICALLY PROVIDED WITH
RESPECT TO AN EXISTING
APPROPRIATION FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL PURPOSES FOR EARLY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS IN THE
PHASE.
ONE BLENDED SYSTEM.
I'M SPENT PROCEEDS RECEIVE FROM
THE OUTSTANDING OUTSTANDING BOND
ISSUED WILL BE USED TO SETTLE
WITH THAT.
ANCHORED FROM THE ISSUANCE OF
SAID BONDS.
SB THREE FORTY RECOGNIZES THE
TAXPAYERS FUN MUCH NEEDED PUBLIC.
PROJECTS AROUND THE STATE.
BUT THAT A HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
NOT NECESSARY NOT POSSIBLE
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF REASONABLE
ACCOUNTABILITY. TO THE TAXPAYERS.
COLLEAGUES LET'S CUT OUR OFFICES
IT MEANT THAT THIS IS A PROJECT
THAT NO ONE WANTS OR NEEDS.
AND MOVE ON TO MORE IMPORTANT
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO OUR FORTY MILLION
CONSTITUENTS. FOR THOSE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THERE WERE NO.
OUR SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
NONE FIGURES OPPOSE PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN KEITH
DONE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED TRAINS -- I AM THANKFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
ON THIS PROPOSAL -- IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT THE MAJORITY
CALIFORNIANS BY THE CENTER DON'T
SUPPORT BUT I'D LIKE TO OPEN TO
ALSO REFERENCE A POLL THAT WAS
ABOUT A YEAR AGO BY THE PP I SEE
WHICH SAY THAT 53% OF
CALIFORNIANS STILL DO SUPPORT
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND THAT WAS.
ONE OF THE MORE RECENT POLLS
THAT WERE TAKEN LUIS REMEMBER
THE POLLS ARE REALLY A SNAPSHOT
IN TIME THEY GIVE YOU THE
PERCEPTION OF WHAT SOME OF OUR
VOTERS THINK AT THAT VERY MOMENT.
WE HAVE HAD AN ELECTION -- IN
WHICH THE VOTERS WERE ASKED
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SUPPORTED
ICE REAL NAY RESOUND LEAST DO
AND DID ENDORSE -- THAT PROJECT
CAN CONTINUE TO DO SO TODAY --
HIGH SPEED RAIL YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUPPORT
TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO OUR STATE HIGH
SPEED RAIL HAPPENS TO BE ONE OF
THEM.
IT'S PART OF A SYSTEM THAT IS
GOING TO INNOVATE ARE -- ABILITY
TO MOVE OUR CITIZENS FROM.
THE WORK CENTERS TO THE HOUSING
CENTERS TO CONNECT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO THE SILICON VALLEY AND
REMAINS A PRIORITY NOT ONLY OF
THIS GOVERNOR WHO HAS SAID SINCE
HIS SAY THE STATE TO CLARIFY HIS
COMMITMENT TO HIGH SPEED RAIL WE
STAND WITH THE GOVERNOR.
AND HIS COMMITMENT TO CONNECT
THE VALLEYS AND TO INVEST IN THE
BOOK AND WE HAVE OLYMPICS COMING
THE LOS ANGELES WE'VE GOT GREAT
THINGS GOING ON THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE WERE THE CHAIRMAN'S FROM.
THAT HIGH SPEED REELS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TRANSFORM THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO BRING WORKERS TO
THE JOB CENTERS FROM HOUSING
THAT'S MORE AFFORDABLE AND SOME
OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
THIS REMAINS A PRIORITY PROJECT
NOT ONLY FOR CALIFORNIANS BUT
ALSO FROM A POLICY PERSPECTIVE
FROM THIS BODY AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS IN THE
ASSEMBLY SO. FOR THOSE REASONS
AND MANY MORE WE WOULD ASK THAT
YOU VOTE NO ON THIS PROPOSAL WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
YOUR OTHER SPEAKERS OPPOSING
PLEASE [inaudible]
OKAY -- QUESTIONS WERE COMMITTEE
OF CHECK OUT JOHNNY -- FIRST OF
ALL I WOULD LIKE TO SAY I THINK
THAT YOU IN THE GOVERNOR
ACTUALLY MILES APART ON THIS ON
THIS PROJECT THE GOVERNOR DOES
SUPPORT THIS.
AND WHAT HE SAID AS HE WANTS TO
FINISH UP TO MERCED AND DOWN TO
BAKERSFIELD SO THAT WE HAVE AND
AN INCH AND NATIONAL OPERATING
SEGMENT.
THE TEST TRACK SO THAT WE CAN
CONNECT WITH REGIONAL RAIL THAT
IS WHAT HE IS FOR AND HE'S NOT
TRYING TO GET RID OF THE PROJECT --
SECONDLY I JUST WANT TO BRING UP
SOMETHING THAT WE NEVER TALK
ABOUT AND THAT'S THE FACT THAT.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY DEATHS THAT
HAVE BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
AND SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR WHEN IT WAS
FIRST INSTITUTED.
IN JAPAN.
THERE WAS ONE ACCIDENT THAT
RESULTED IN SOME DEATHS IN CHINA
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO THAT'S ALL
WE HAVE DEBTS ON OUR CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAYS EVERY TIME WE TURN
AROUND.
AND THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
MONETARY AMOUNT THAT CAN ACCOUNT
FOR THE SAFETY MEASURES THAT WE
FAIL TO TALK ABOUT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THIS PROJECT SO I JUST
THINK THAT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO ALSO RECOGNIZED WHY THIS
IMPORTANT WHY THIS PROJECT IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
TO FORWARD CENTER GALGIANI AYE.
AYE A PER AYE PRESHEAF THOSE
COMMENTS AND I THINK SAFETY IS A
VERY IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION.
AND AND I KNOW YOU WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING.
GET THIS ON THE BALLOT AND AND I
APPLAUD YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS I
THINK IF IF PEOPLE -- WE'RE JUST
ASK THE QUESTION HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GET ON A HIGH SPEED
TRAIN FROM LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO GET THERE IN TWO AND A
HALF HOURS AND PAY A SEVENTY
NINE DOLLAR.
FEE TO DO THAT.
I CAN TELL YOU SOMETHING I WOULD
DRIVE LOS ANGLES AND DO IT I
MEAN.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
UNFORTUNATELY -- PROJECT THIS IS
NOT EVEN STATE ARE YOU TALK
ABOUT TRAINS IN JAPAN.
OR YOU TALK ABOUT -- THE MAGLEV
THAT EXISTS IN CHINA GETTING
FROM THE AIRPORT I MEAN THERE
ARE TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE THAT
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE STATE
HAS AN EMBRACE THESE HIGH SPEED
TRAINS AGO THREE HUNDRED MILES
AN HOUR.
AND YOU HAVE FLAT AREA IN THE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE THEY
PROBABLY COULD DO THREE HUNDRED
MILES AN HOUR PROBABLY GETTING
OVER SOME HILLS AND GETTING
THROUGH TUNNELS MIGHT BE A
CHALLENGE BUT AND IN JAPAN I'VE
BEEN ON THOSE TRAINS.
AND THEY HAD AND THEY DO GO OVER
HILLS AND THEY DO GO THROUGH
TUNNELS AND THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS NOT YOUR
TYPICAL STEEL ON STEEL
TECHNOLOGIES SO.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE THIS THIS
PROJECT ONE TO GOT OUT OF THE
GATE -- I DON'T KNOW -- IF WHICH
HAD BEEN MISMANAGED I DON'T KNOW
IF THE IF THE THE VISION OF WHAT
WE DEFINE AS HIGH SPEED RAIL WAS.
WAS ADULTERATED SOMEWHERE ALONG
THE LINE -- I JUST KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA IS THE INNOVATOR AND
I I CAN I THINK THAT PEOPLE IN
IN CONCEPT WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GET ON TRAINS.
LIKE YOU CAN IN EUROPE LIKE YOU
CAN IN JAPAN BUT WE ARE A LONG
SINCE STATE WE HAVE A LOT OF
SPRAWL ESPECIALLY IN.
EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY I MEAN
A LOT TO GET ON THE TRAIN.
IN -- IN LOOKING TO WHERE I LIVE
IN.
I'D LIKE TO JUST BE ABLE TO TAKE
THE TRAIN TO ONTARIO PORT THAT
WOULD SAVE ME A LOT OF TIME.
BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THE SAFETY ATTRIBUTES OF OF
TRAINS BY.
AYE AYE SUPPORT THAT THAT THAT
IDEA AND I JUST HOPE THAT WE CAN
RE LOOK AT THIS TRAIN MAYBE WE
TAKE A PAUSE AND SAY LISTEN IT'S
NINETY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IS
WHAT I'M EVEN HEARING THAT THIS
THING IS GOING TO BE WHEN IT'S
ULTIMATELY COMPLETED IF YOU LOOK.
AT THE ACTUAL REAL COST OF A
GOING FROM LA TO SAN FRANCISCO
THE ACTUAL COST MIGHT BE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS WHEN YOU CAN
STILL GET ON A JET.
FROM -- SOUTHWEST AT A BURBANK
FOR SIXTY NINE DOLLARS AND SO
WITH THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY OF THIS
ONCE IT'S DONE IS ALSO GOING TO
BE SOMETHING THAT REALLY NEEDS
TO BE INVESTIGATED.
SO MAYBE LOOK AT THIS IS JUST A
PAUSE UP WE CAN JUST TAKE A STEP
BACK AND REALLY IDENTIFY WITH
THIS THING WITH WHAT IS THING
REALLY GOING TO COST AND IS A
REALLY MORE INNOVATIVE WAYS. TO
TO MOVE PEOPLE WITH -- MORE
MODERN VERSIONS OF WHAT WE
DEFINE AS HIGH SPEED RAIL BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THANK
YOU CENTERS ON QUESTIONS FROM
ANYBODY ON THE COMMITTEE CENTER
BATES.
THANK YOU.
FINISH AVAIL ENOUGH THANK YOU
SENATOR STONE FOR BRING IT
FORWARD I DO THINK THAT.
THE DIALOGUE ON THIS ISSUE WITH
HIGH SPEED RAIL MUST CONTINUE.
ON MAYBE WE WILL GET THAT NO
STATE OF THE ART SYSTEM AT SOME
POINT IN TIME.
BY ITS FULL IT MUCH IN THE
DISTANT FUTURE IN THE SUBSIDY
ISSUES HUGE.
BY HAVING THROUGH JOHN NOW ON
ORANGE COUNTY'S TOLL ROADS FOR
MANY YEARS AND JOB THE USER FEES
ARE WHICH WERE THE TOLLS
COLLECTED.
I TOOK A LONG TIME TO CATCH UP
WITH ALL THE MONTEREY BEEN ISSUE
THE REVENUE BONDS IN FACT
REFINANCING WAS REQUIRED.
IT'S NOT EVEN POSSIBLE WITH THIS
PROJECT SECONDLY IT'S BEEN MY
CONCERN.
THAT SB ONE IS ONLY TEN YEARS
AND DOG FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS IF
I REMEMBER CORRECTLY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
FOR TEN THAT AFTER THAT THERE'S
NO REQUIREMENT THAT MONEY BE
SPENT ON OUR WHAT SB ONE LAID
OUT AND MY CONCERN IS THAT THAT
WOULD BECOME THE REVENUE STREAM.
SO THESE ARE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE BECAUSE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT AND TRANSPORTATION.
THAT PROMISES MADE TO THE PUBLIC
ARE PROMISES KEPT.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S FAILING ON
MANY FRONTS WE'VE SEEN OUR RADIO
TAX ON SB ONE WE'RE GONNA HOLD
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HOSTAGE.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE I'VE BEEN
PUT ASIDE.
BUT THE IDEA IS STILL THERE.
AND I THINK THESE ARE THINGS
THAT REALLY START TROUBLING ARE
THE PUBLIC OUT THERE WHO IS
CRYING.
FOR A BETTER MOBILITY.
A WE KNOW THAT CONGESTION IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WITH
THOUGHT.
TALKS OF FLYING THE AIR YOU KNOW
SO THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING TO
RAISE THE ISSUE.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
I ACTUALLY SUPPORTED THE BOND
MEASURE WAY BACK WHEN BECAUSE I
THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO GET
SOMETHING THAT SOUNDED GREAT.
HAND JOB PERHAPS THE BUSINESS
PLAN SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
MORE CLOSELY ANALYZED WAY BACK
WHEN IT WASN'T -- FORTUNATELY
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF ATTENTION
NOW TO THE THE FAILURES THAT
SEEM TO HAVE THE ON BEEN.
HAPPENING BECAUSE FOR LACK OF
MORE ON CRITICAL THINKING AND IT
ABILITY TO KIND OF TAKE A STEP
BACK POLICY IF YOU WILL.
LOOK FOR A BETTER BETTER ROUTE
NO NO PUN INTENDED I I'VE HEARD
FROM PEOPLE WHO.
ARE THIS IS WAY BACK WHEN I WAS
ON ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY VERY FAMILIAR WITH
RAIL SERVICE IN THE EAST.
AND THE FACT THAT IF WE DONE
GRADE SEPARATIONS ON THE
EXISTING RAIL.
AND THOSE ARE VERY EXPENSIVE
THAT PUT A LOT OF MONEY AND THAT
WE COULD PROBABLY HAVE ON THE
EXISTING RAIL CONNECTING AT
THROUGH THE VALLEY THERE.
IN SOMETHING THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN AS IMPACTFUL TO THE VALLEY
FAMILIES THAT WE WOULD MAYBE
HAVE SOMETHING CLOSER TO REALITY
RIGHT NOW.
A SALUTING SET SEEM TO
CONTINUALLY BE MISTER PEOPLE NOT
WILLING TO CONFRONT THAT.
ALSO THANK YOU AND YOU KEEP
PUTTING IT OUT THERE ON THE MENU
AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THAT AND PERHAPS A CHANGE THE
DIRECTION.
THAT BENEFITS SAW ALL OF US WHO
SUPPORTED CONCEPTUALLY BUT ARE
VERY -- I THINK DISAPPOINTED --
DISSOLUTION THAT CAN IT CAN IT
EVER BE A REALITY.
CLICK HERE.
THANK YOU OF CENTER BATES -- SIR
STONE YOU HAVE A CLOSING
STATEMENT.
YES -- MISTER CHAIRMAN -- I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL I KNOW
THIS IS A VERY BOLD BILL -- I I
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE GONE DOWN A
VERY EXPENSIVE PATH AND I THINK
WE ALL WANT.
A HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM THAT IS
COST EFFECTIVE IN STATE OF THE
ART.
AND SO MY BILL IS BASICALLY A
PAUSE IT'S BASICALLY SAYING
WE'RE GONNA STOP THE FUNDING --
WHETHER IT'S TEMPORARY.
OR WHETHER IT'S PERMANENT.
UNTIL WE CAN GATHER THE THE BEST
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE IF WE HAVE
[inaudible] TO ANALYZE WHAT
WE'VE DONE SO FAR AND WHAT WE
CAN DO IN THE FUTURE TO REALLY
HAVE.
A STATE OF THE ART TRAIN HIGH
SPEED TRAIN THAT PEOPLE WILL
UTILIZE.
WHERE DO YOU LIVE IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WHETHER YOU
LIVE IN INYO COUNTY WHERE DO YOU
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY --
BELIEVE ME I WON ALTERNATIVE
FORMS OF TRANSPORTATION THAN
CARS.
AND AIRPLANES -- I I CAN'T TELL
YOU SENATOR HOW MANY HOURS I
SPENT IN AIRPORTS AND HOW MANY
HOURS I SPENT ON PLANES.
THAT I WOULD RATHER SIT ON A
TRAIN.
AND READ MY PACKETS -- AND ENJOY
THE RIDE AND AND ENJOY THE
BEAUTIFUL SCENERY AND OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STATE OF
FLYING OVER IT ALL THE TIME --
IT NOT TO MENTION YOU KNOW HE
LONG MUSK IN HIS -- HYPERLOOP
YOU KNOW THERE'S EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE THAT
MIGHT BE CHEAPER AND MIGHT BE
BETTER.
SO UP WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE SENATOR
IT'S AN HONOR TO SERVE WITH YOU.
AND SHOULD I BOOK THANK YOU OF
CENTER OF I HAVE A LOT TO SAY
ABOUT THIS BUT I'LL JUST SAY
THAT YOU YOU MADE SOME
STATEMENTS I AGREE WITH.
I A I THINK WE NEED TO BE MORE
PRODUCTIVE IN TERMS OF HOW WE
APPROACH SIZE BE REAL.
HOWEVER I'D LIKE TO SEE IT
FINISHED QUICKER -- I THINK THE
FASTER YOU FINISH A PROJECT THE
ROADLESS ACOSTA NOTE.
I KNOW THAT FROM EXPERIENCE --
CAN SPEED UP THE PROJECT
SOMEWHERE -- WITH SOME CREATIVE
FINANCING OR SOME OTHER WAY WE
CAN -- REALLY SAVE THE TAXPAYERS
MONEY.
THE SP ONE FUNDS -- MENTIONED OR
ESTABLISHED IN THE STATUTE IT'S
NOT A TIME LIMITED STATUTE IS A
PERMANENT STATUTES OF THOSE
MONIES ARE ALLOCATED TO THE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW.
AND NOW PROPOSITION -- SIXTY
NINE AN ARTICLE NINETEEN OF THE
CONSTITUTION SO.
WE HAVE -- THE STRUCTURE ON
THOSE OF THOSE FUNDS IN THAT WAY --
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
KNEW THAT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY CERRO HAVE TO
RECOMMEND -- OPPOSE ON THIS --
MEASURE AND ALTHOUGH I HOPE YOU
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE.
FOR YOU KNOW THE ISSUES THAT YOU
CARE ABOUT.
I WILL RECOMMEND OPPOSE THIS OF
THIS PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
SO YOU'RE WELCOME -- A MOVE THE
BILL CENTER BATES HAS A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR TO MOVE THE BILL.
AND WILL CALL THE ROLL THANK YOU.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY BY
SENATOR STONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
THEIR ABOUT NO BELT NO BATES HI
BATES I DON GALGIANI.
GALGIANI NO MCGUIRE REQUIRE NO
MORALE.
ROSS RUBIO.
RUBIO NO SKINNER STONE I DON'T
AYE AMBERG CASKEY.
UP TO VOTE IN FAVOR WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE FOR A SEPTEMBER'S.
CENTER BATES ALTERNATE GAL.
ONE I THINK MY BILLS OF THE LAST
ONES.
YES.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE TM.
INTO SUPPORTER OF A LET.
TWO ONE
THREE TWO THE SALON REAL TOUGH.
MAY HAVE THE MISSION
.
OKAY -- CENTER.
SENATOR BAIL.
THANK YOU WE ARE READY FOR YOU
OKAY [inaudible]
WELL -- CENTER BATES -- MADAM
CHAIR ALL PRESENT TO IF YOU IF
IT'S A PLEASURE -- I'LL START
WITH THE SP ONE FIFTY TWO YES
OKAY -- I WILL BEGIN WITH THAT
ONE THEN THANK YOU -- I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT SB -- ONE FIFTY TWO
THIS IS A BILL THAT I BELIEVE
WILL IMPROVE THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM BY MAKING
A MINISTRY OF IMPROVEMENTS.
INCREASING THE REGIONAL.
REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS ROLE.
NOW SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
EXPEDITE BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN
IMPROVEMENTS BY SHIFTING MORE
MINISTER RESPONSIBLE TO THE
METROPOLITAN -- TRIP PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS -- IN OTHER WORDS
CLOSE WATER CLOSER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- ADDITIONALLY IT
MODIFIES THE SURE FUNDS
DISTRIBUTED BY FORMULA PROVIDING
A MORE PREDICTABLE FUNDING --
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT REASONS
REGIONS OF THE STATE -- THE
CHANGES IS INCLUDED.
INCREASING THE REGIONAL SHARE
FROM 4275%.
INCREASE IN THE WORLD SMALLER IS
FROM 10215%.
AND REDUCING THE STATE SHARES
FROM 5210%.
I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
RECEIVED ON THE BILL AND FEEL
THAT WE'VE HAD MANY PRODUCTIVE.
MEETINGS WITH THE VARIOUS THAT
SHOULD STAKEHOLDERS -- ON
COMMITTED TO ENCOURAGING WE
MAINTAIN GOALS OF THE ATP
PROGRAM.
PARTICULARLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
CONTINUE TO HOLD MEETINGS AND
COMMITTED TO AMEND THE BILL TO
CLARIFY THE IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE -- CONTINUE TO
GUARANTEE DELEGATION TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
CLARIFY.
THE OVERSIGHT ON THE MPO
APPLICATION -- IN -- GUIDELINES
ON AND ON PROJECT COMPLETION.
AND TODAY AS THEY HAVE WITNESSES
ABOUT INSURER AND ALTERNATIVE
FOR MY WITNESSES -- THIS BILL IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS.
SO I'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE GROUPS -- WE ARE GETTING
CLOSE TO AGREEMENT BUT WILLS
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK SAW TURN
OVER TO MY WITNESSES MANAGER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR BACK ALONG WITH THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
MTC IS SPONSORING SB ONE FIFTY
TWO BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE
STATE'S ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM CAN BE DELIVERED MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND MORE EFFICIENTLY
BY DELEGATING A MUCH LARGER
SHARE TO THE REGIONAL LEVEL.
AND REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT
THAT EVERY REGIONALLY APPROVED
PROJECT -- TODAY BE APPROVED AND
SEES ME ALLOCATED BY THE CTC A
STEP THAT ADDS TWO MONTHS OF
UNNECESSARY DELAY TO EVERY
PROJECT.
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT TODAY ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT AND HERE'S
FACED REACHING THEIR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION TARGETS AND EIGHTY
P. PROGRAM IS VERY WELL SUITED
PROGRAM TO ASSIST WITH THAT --
WE WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE THAT THE
STATE'S MODEL FOR FUNDING
TRANSPORTATION AND FOR DRESSING
THE TRANSPORTATION -- IMPACTS OF
ARTS USING THE GREENHOUSE GAS
IMPACTS ASSOCIATE WITH
TRANSPORTATION IS VERY MUCH A
BOTTOM UP MODEL.
AND SO WE THINK THAT THE ATP
SHOULD REALLY FOLLOW THAT -- THE
75% WAS SELECTED BECAUSE THAT'S
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DO WITH THE
STEP THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
AND AGAIN SINCE -- GETTING MORE
PEOPLE TO BUY CAN WALK TO ON
THEIR DESTINATIONS TO BUY CAN
WALK TO TRANSIT IS SO ESSENTIAL
AS PART OF OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION TARGETS WE THINK THAT
FOLLOWING THAT.
THAT 75% BOTTOM UP APPROACH
MAKES SENSE -- WE'VE HEARD A LOT
FROM SOME OF THE THE FOLKS WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION WERE VERY
INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH THEM
WE THINK THAT.
I'M A LOT OF THEIR CONCERNS CAN
BE ADDRESSED AS THE SENATOR
STATED -- I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO MENTION A
COUPLE OF ISSUES ON THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES PIECE
OUR INTENT WAS NEVER TO NOT --
ENSURE THAT THE REGIONAL PROGRAM
ON REACH THOSE TARGETS AS WELL
IN FACT ON TODAY THE OVER FOUR
CYCLES 85% OF FUNDS FROM THE
REGIONAL PROGRAM HAVE BEEN
INVESTED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
ON WITH RESPECT TO THE RURAL
PROGRAM -- WE ANTICIPATED THAT
THERE WOULD BE SOME CONCERNED
REDUCING THE STATEWIDE PROGRAM --
SIGNIFICANTLY SO WE DID INCREASE
THE REGIONAL POT 215% WHICH IS
WHAT THE RURAL AND SMALL
URBANIZED AREAS HAVE BEEN
GETTING TO TO DATE INCLUDING THE
STATE WIDE PROGRAM AND THEN OF
COURSE RURAL AND SMALL URBANIZED
AREAS CAN STILL COMPETE.
WITHIN THE STATEWIDE PROGRAM SO
THEY'RE KIND OF WOULD ACTUALLY
BE RECEIVING POTENTIALLY MORE ON
THE WHAT THEY HAD BEEN.
I'M IN CLOSING I WOULD JUST --
LIKE TO REITERATE OUR ON DESIRE
TO WORK WITH -- THE FOLKS WHO
HAVE EXPRESSED IN OPPOSITION AND
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE HAPPY TO ASK
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
WE THINK THIS IS -- A GOOD BILL
TO IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND AND
LOCAL CONTROL FOR JUST THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS THAT -- ARE WELL
SUITED FOR A MORE LOCAL APPROACH --
WE THINK THAT -- WE WE CERTAINLY
HAVE -- ANY NUMBER OF PROJECTS
IN -- IN OUR REGION -- THAT ARE
ARE ARE BENEFICIAL AND REGIONAL
IN NATURE BUT SOME ARE ALSO --
VERY SPECIFIC TO SOME OF THE
NARROW AREAS AND AND I REGION'S
WITHIN OUR ORANGE COUNTY --
JURISDICTION AND THE IDEA OF
HONESTLY HAVING SACRAMENTO
CHOOSE WHERE WE PLAY SOME OF OUR
BIKE ROUTE OR PEDESTRIAN
FACILITIES DOESN'T MAKE A WHOLE
LOT OF SENSE AND WE THINK THAT
BRING THOSE -- DECISIONS TO A
LOCAL LEVEL MAKES A WHOLE LOT
MORE SENSE WE TOO ARE COMMITTED
TO WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH --
WITH ANYONE WHO DOES HAVE
CONCERNS WE THINK THAT WE'RE ALL
KIND OF ROLLING TO THE SAME TO
IN THE SAME DIRECTION AND
THERE'S THERE IS A SOLUTION HERE.
THIS GAG REGION -- THE MPO UNDER
WHICH WE OPERATE -- ALSO HAS
SOME UNIQUENESS AND WE'RE GOING
TO BRING SOME OF THOSE -- ISSUES
TO THE DISCUSSION AS THE BILL
MOVES FOR BUT WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD -- TO TO HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION AND FOR TODAY WE DO
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORE -- GOOD AFTERNOON MARC
WATTS REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
AND AS WELL.
THE SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WHO
ACTED TODAY TO MOVE FORWARD IN
SUPPORT POSITION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOE CRUISE ON
BEHALF OF CITIES SAN JOSE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND ORIGINAL VOTE
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
THERE'S NO [inaudible] FOR MORE.
HE STARTS TO ADDRESS
[inaudible]
THE NUMBER.
RIGHT NOW.
AND WE WILL HAVE BY TWO MINUTES
REACH SPEAKER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANKS AGAIN -- THIS IS ANDREW
ANTS WE HEAR ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION.
AUTHORITY AND WE REALLY REGRET
BEING IN THIS POSITION BECAUSE
OF OUR GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
FATHER IN MANY WAYS CASES ALONG
WITH MANY OF YOUR EFFORTS.
OF SB.
ONE WE THINK IT'S PREMATURE TO
BE CHANGING.
SB ONE FUNDED PROGRAM -- SO
EARLY THE INTO THE LIFE OF
HAVING SB ONE DOLLARS INFUSION
TO THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM.
WE DON'T THINK OF POLICY BASIS
THE CASE HAS BEEN MADE FOR
RETOOLING THIS PROGRAM IN THE
PROCESS.
THIS IS THE FIRST CYCLE AWARE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION FUNDS HAVE
BEEN AWARDED WITH THE INFUSION
TO SB ONE DOLLARS HAVE PROVIDED
WHICH ESSENTIALLY DOUBLE THE
PROGRAM.
AND SO WE THINK THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT IMING WHEN IT
COMES TO THE PROPOSAL ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU GO BACK AND YOU LOOK AT
THE HISTORY OF HOW MUCH TIME A
CALLOUS TA CALTRANS CDC AND
OTHERS.
HAVE SPENT REACHING OUT TO
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP THE
CURRENT GUIDELINES FOR SB ONE OR
TWO FOR THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
WE THINK THAT TO HAVE A BILL
COME FORWARD IN THIS FASHION
UNDER THIS TIMING CONSTRAINTS.
DOES NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH --
TIMING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS
TO WEIGH IN AND WORK WE HAVE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT ALL
JUMP TO GIVEN THE TWO MINUTE
TIME CONSTRAINT -- WE REALLY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT
FRANKLY IN OUR TERRITORY -- 45%
OF THE STATE'S DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE NOTIFIED OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY USING THE CURRENT.
ACCOUNT VIRUS FREE MODEL THAT
WAS DEVELOPED THROUGH SB -- FIVE
THREE FIVE WE ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THE SPONSOR AND THE
AUTHORS OF PLEDGE TO MAKE
AMENDMENTS TO ESSENTIALLY
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES BUT
ADDRESSES IN THE AYE BEHOLDER
WE'D LIKE TO BE PART OF THAT.
CONVERSATION -- IF IT'S NOT
CALLIN VIRAL SCREEN -- THEN
WE'RE GOING TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT MEASURE IN
TWO ISSUES GIVEN THE PROPENSITY.
OF NEED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
ALSO PROVIDE IMPORTANT SAFETY
BENEFIT 30% OF THE SERIOUS AND
NON MOTORIZED ENTRIES.
TAKE PLACE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SO WE WANT TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE
GREAT RESPECT I THINK THAT WOULD
DOES FROM MTC.
POINTED TO THE PERFORMANCE.
WITH RESPECT TO HAVING PROJECTS
INVESTED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES FROM THE CURRENT
PROCESS -- WE'RE TALKING OVER
88% I THINK THE WITNESSES 85%
THE ONLY -- REPORTS AS 80% OF
PROJECTS -- HAVE BEEN INVESTED
ACROSS ALL OF THE CYCLES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT A CHANGE
IN YOU KNOW WHETHER THAT WOULD
MEET THAT PERFORMANCE METRIC
WHICH IS MUCH HIGHER THAN WHAT
THE STATUTE CALLS.
FOR THE STATURE CALLS 425-
PERCENT.
AS A MINIMUM.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THE CALAVERAS FREE MODEL IS
CLEARED IF CLEARLY DEFINED A
STATUTE.
AND WE'RE ALSO WORRIED ABOUT THE
IMPACT ON IMMEDIATE CYCLES BUT I
DID HEAR THE AUTHOR SPEAK TO HIS
INTENT -- TO MAKE AN AMENDMENT
THAT WOULD ADDRESS THAT TIMING
ISSUES BECAUSE FRANKLY THE LAST
CYCLE WE SAW A LOT OF INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND OUR TERRITORY.
AND FRANKLY THE WAY THE BILL
BILL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED -- IT
WOULD PUT ALL THOSE AWARDS IN
JEOPARDY.
BAR REQUIRED THE CTC AND THE
APPEALS TO KIND OF SCRATCH WHAT
THEY'VE DONE AND START OVER AND
SO.
THANK YOU SIR YEAR. TWO MINISTRY
WITH THOSE REASONS RIPPLES WE
PLEDGE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
GOING FOR WILL HAVE HIM RESPOND
TO THOSE.
TO THE NEXT [inaudible]
HI JULIE [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE WORK WITH ME IS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ASSEMBLY CAN
VALUE CENTER CHIRLA -- WITH THE
INCLUSION OF THIS VAST MUSES
PART OF THE ATP THROUGHOUT THE
STATE PROCESS WE'VE SEEN A
PROGRESS THAT IS MORE INCLUSIVE
AND TRANSPARENT AND IT WOULD BE
OTHERWISE.
ON THE TV IS A MODEL OF HOW THE
STATE CAN INVEST IN AND
ENCOURAGE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION.
WE DON'T SEE HOWEVER -- STRONG
REASONING BEHIND THE DRASTIC RE
SHIFTING OF THIS PROGRAMS
FUNDING WHICH PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE STATE --
PROCESS -- BY PUTTING A LARGE
PORTION INTO A REGIONAL PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY THIS REGIONAL PROGRAMS
NOT WELL DEFINED IN TERMS OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY --
WHICH ARE TWO OF OUR MAJOR
CONCERNS.
IN ADDITION THERE'S ALSO A
REDUCTION -- OVER ALL OF THE
AVAILABLE POTENTIAL FUNDS THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR RURAL
COMMUNITIES -- DESPITE THE 15%
OF THE TOTAL AVAILABLE FUNDS
THAT WOULD BE MADE -- AVAILABLE
FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES TO COMPETE
FOR OUR OVERALL -- DWINDLING.
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE THE TV IS
RELATIVELY EFFECTIVE AND WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE SHIFT BEING
PROPOSED HERE CURRENTLY DOES NOT
ENSURE THAT THE HISTORICAL THIS
INVESTMENT IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WILL NOT BE EXACERBATED AT
THE REGIONAL LEVEL.
UNFORTUNATELY THE NEEDS AND
PRIORITIES AT THE COMMUTE WITH
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE WORK
WITH ARE OFTEN NOT PARTICULARLY
WELL REPRESENTED BY REGIONAL
AGENCIES.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT AT THE
VERY LEAST THERE BACKSTOPS THE
MECHANISMS FOR TRANSPARENCY
WHICH THE STATE CAN HAVE A
CRITICAL ROLE IN -- JUST AN
EXAMPLE CV LANGKAH PROJECT IN
THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
IT'S A LARGE PROJECTS THAT EVEN
INCLUDES THINGS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR GOLF CARTS --
IN REALITY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT BENEFITING DISAPPEARS
COMMUNITY COULD TELL LIKE THOSE
IN THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
THAT WE WORK WITH -- JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW REGIONAL PRIORITY
SOMETIMES DON'T LINE UP WITH
THOSE OF THE COMMUNITY --
DISADVANTAGE ON A CORPORATE
COMMUNITIES AND RURAL AREAS
OFTEN NEED SOMETHING AS SIMPLE
AS SIDEWALKS -- WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE COMMUNITY
STILL HAVE A CHANCE AT THIS --
OPPORTUNITY SO THESE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HOLD ON SB ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
GUS CORN WE HAVE TO
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY OF
MONTEREY COUNTY AND STANISLAUS
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS WE HAVE
CONCERNS SON NOT OFFICIAL POST
POSITION.
HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
DEFERENCE FOR SENATE BILL WOULD
VERY CLOSELY WITH HIM ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF SEVERAL TO
COMPETITIVE POGRAMS SO JUST A
COUPLE QUICK POINTS I THINK. ONE
CONCERN IS WE DON'T WANT TO PUT
AN ARTIFICIAL CAP UP ON THE
FUNDING WHERE WERE PARSON OUT
THE FUNDING SO THAT EVERYBODY'S
GETTING A SLIVER NO ONE'S
GETTING FED SO THAT WE'RE NOT.
EXPEDITING OR DELIVERING
PROJECTS OF SIGNIFICANCE I THINK
THAT'S ONE CONCERN WE ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED HOWEVER
ABOUT GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY AND
THAT'S SOMETHING I KNOW THE
CENTERS CONCERNED ABOUT.
TO THE PARTICULAR OUTCOME BUT
CYCLE -- FOR BUT FOR SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS YOU DO GET BANG
FOR YOUR BUCK -- WHEN YOU INVEST
ALONG THE CENTRAL COAST AND EVEN
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SOME OF THE
DISSIDENTS COMMUNITIES THAT MR
ENTRY EVEN MENTIONED -- SO I
THINK FOR THOSE REASONS PLUS --
WE DO THINK THAT IT IS WORTH
EXPLORING -- THE EVALUATION
CRITERIA IT'S SORT OF A CLUNKY.
EVALUATION WHEN YOU'VE GOT
SOMEBODY SAY FROM YOU KNOW
HUMBOLDT THAT'S PROBABLY
EVALUATING A PROJECT IN ORANGE
COUNTY WHERE THEY DON'T REALLY
HAVE A TRUE APPRECIATION --
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT PROJECT IN
THE COUNTY SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I THINK WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR WE LOOK FOR
TO BEING INCLUDING THOSE
CONVERSATION SO.
THANK YOU SENATOR BELL AND THANK
YOU MANAGER.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
HI ANSWER OF AIR WITH CALIFORNIA
LOCKS AND WE'VE BEEN AND
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OFFICE AND SPONSORS THEY'RE
STILL SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED INCLUDING
THE STATED DURING TESTIMONY AND
AND I LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED.
TO THE COMMITTEE -- OUR CONCERNS
GO AGAIN JUST TO ECHO THE
DRASTIC CHANGE IN FUNDING
STRUCTURE -- AND WHERE IT BUT
WE'RE INVESTED IN IMPROVING THE
ATP AND HAVE BEEN HOW WILLING
AND KEY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE OFFICE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS TIME
YOU MUST MAINTAIN OUR POST
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JONATHAN MATCH
WITH THE SAFE AT SCHOOL NATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE THE SAME DISCUSSIONS AND
MAINTAIN OUR OUR CURRENT OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED OPPOSITION BURKE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING MORE
WITH -- THOSE CENTERS OFFICE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
JUST WANTED -- TO MENTION ONE
ADDITIONAL ELEMENTS OF OUR
CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL -- WHICH
IS THAT WE REALLY VIEW THE
EIGHTY P. AS A CURRENTLY STANDS
AS A MODEL OF TRANSPARENCY AND
SAY WHAT BY IN -- WITH MORE THAN
TEN WORKSHOPS HAPPENING ACROSS
THE STATE LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES
ARE STAKEHOLDERS TO BE INVOLVED
AND AND THAT HAS RESULTED IN
MORE THAN A HUNDRED VOLUNTEER
EVALUATORS -- GIVING THIRTY
HOURS OF THEIR TIME ON AVERAGE --
TO INVEST IN THE PROGRAM -- IT'S
A TRIPLE BLIND PROCESS -- THAT'S
FREE OF BIAS AND WE WOULD REALLY
BE CONCERNED ABOUT -- ABOUT
EVACUATING THAT -- STATEWIDE
CONSTITUENCY THAT'S BEEN BUILT
UP AROUND ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
BY DEVOLVING INTO THE REGION'S
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THEN THE
COMMISSION WITH A CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION ALSO HERE A TO
ECHO I MY COLLEAGUES AND IN OUR
POSITION THAT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS AT THIS IS A IT THIS IS
AN ANOMALY PROGRAM FOR THE STATE
WHERE THERE'S HEAVY STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT.
THE CDC HAS MADE EVERY EFFORT TO
COORDINATE AND AND NEGOTIATE
AMONG FOLKS ACROSS THE STATE AND
SO WE YOU KNOW WE'D LIKE TO SEE
A BIT MORE.
AT OUR REGION ENGAGEMENT AROUND
HOW TO MAKE THOSE.
CHANGES -- WE FEEL THAT IF THIS
IS NOT GOING TO GET IT GO INTO
EFFECT UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WHICH WOULD THEN BE THE THE THE
END OF THIS CURRENT PROGRAM.
THEN WE WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THAT TIME TO CONSIDER ALL OF THE
CONCERNS AND WORK OUT THE RIGHT
AT AMENDMENTS TO WHAT WE CAN DO
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ON THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIR -- MY NAME IS CAITLYN DEAN
WITH POLICY LINK AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FOR ALL THE REASONS
STATED BY CALIFORNIA WALKS AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR.
YOU CAN'T.
I COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOUR FRIENDS REQUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MAN CHAIR. ONE
IS A IF I AM TO THE CHAIR FOR
ALL OF HIS WORK THAT HE HAS.
DONE AND CONTINUES TO DO FOR
STATEWIDE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS -- HAD OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET WITH THE CHAIR -- ON THIS
BILL AND I REALLY APPRECIATE AT
THE CHAIR TAKING TIME SPECIALLY
LATE YESTERDAY EVENING HAVING
THE CONVERSATION.
MISTER CHAIR MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT -- THE MY UNDERSTANDING.
IS THAT AS YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS BILL YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE
CLER THAT -- THIS BILL DOES NOT
IMPACT CURRENT FUNDING LA
ALLOCATION THROUGH APPROXIMATE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WHICH I
BELIEVE THAT SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION ROLLS THROUGH.
YEAH THAT'S TRUE YEAH WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION WE'RE NOT GONNA --
CHAU BACK MONEY ON CURRENT
PROJECTS NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. ONE OF
THE WITNESSES SAID THAT AT THIS
CURRENT FORMULA DOES NOT IMPACT
RULE I I I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WITNESS LIVES IN A RURAL AREA --
IN THIS KERN FOR ME THAT WOULD
IMPACT -- RURAL AND WHAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE -- THE CHAIR
SAYING HE SAID HE'S GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT FORMULA --
AND WORK WITH INTERESTED PARTIES
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD IN GOOD FAITH --
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FIGURE OUT
WHERE THAT SWEET SPOT IS -- IN
REGARDS TO THE FORMULA AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE A FAIR ASSESSMENT MR.
YES THAT'S TRUE AND THE YEAH
THAT'S TRUE BASICALLY THE
FORMULA IS THE KEY ISSUE.
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS.
SHOULD BE MORE PROPERLY HANDLED.
AT THE LOCAL THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR THE REGIONAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL.
BECAUSE I THINK THEY'RE THE TYPE
OF PROJECTS.
THAT OF REGIONAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHY AGAIN OR JUST
THE BILL.
I DON'T THINK THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION I'LL
BE LOOKING AT SMALL BICYCLE
PATHS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT'S KIND OF NOT THE ROLE IT
WAS NEVER THEIR INTENTION AND SP
ONE TO HAVE THEM.
GO TO THIS.
MASSIVE EFFORT TO DO ALL THIS
AND HIRE MORE STAFF AND ROCK
PROCEED TO THE CURRENT.
THAT KIND OF THING IS MORE
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE THE THE
LOCAL STEWART SO BUT WE WANT TO
HAVE A STATEWIDE PROGRAM.
A A REGIONAL PROGRAM AND A SMALL.
A RURAL CITY PROGRAM -- ON ALSO
SAY THAT I'M.
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DISADVANTAGE COMMITTEE BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS A TRUE STATEMENT
PEOPLE MAY TO WE HAVE.
TO APPROACH THIS FROM THE
STANDPOINT.
THAT -- SOME COMMUNITIES HAVE
NOT RECEIVED THEIR ADEQUATE
SHARE OF SUPPORT -- FOR WALKWAYS
SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL.
BIKE WAYS PATHWAYS AND WE SHOULD
NEVER HURTS PROMOTE THAT.
YEAH -- IN OUR DISCUSSIONS NOT
APPRECIATE IMAGES HERE AND I
THINK THAT IN JUST CLOSING HERE
AND JUST TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S PETITION COMMISSION
IN ITS CURRENT FORMULA.
WHAT I WILL SAY IS IN THE UNDER
THIS CURRENT FORMULA RULE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ABLE TO
RECEIVE AT LEAST IN RECENT?
AND MOST RECENT YEARS SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF SB ONE IN THIS FIRST
YEAR.
THERE HAS BEEN BENEFIT -- AND I
WILL SAY IN OUR BACKYARD AND
SOME OF THE MOST RULES SPOTS --
IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH MENDOCINO
AS WELL AS HUMBLE ON THE GREAT
RIDLEY TRAILING TRANSITIONING
THAT FUNCTION THE BANKRUPT --
RAIL SYSTEM INTO A WORLD CLASS
TRAIL SYSTEM THAT WILL GO
THROUGH AND TWENTY MILES CDC HAS
BEEN -- HAS BEEN A GREAT HELP
FOR THAT.
AND WHAT I'LL SAY IS -- I'M
GREATLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
CHAIR AND HIS WILLINGNESS TO B
ABLE TO WORK THROUGH THIS ISSUE%
I HAVE.
HAD THE PLEASURE TO WORK THROUGH
THAT MANY OF ISSUES WHETHER IT'S
REACHED A MEASURE.
THREE OR SENATE BILL -- ONE
INDIA IS ALWAYS BEEN A PERSON'S
WORD -- IN UNDERSTANDING THERE
WILL BE CHANGES -- TO THE
FORMULA TODAY -- AND AND WORKING
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS -- WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL.
Q. AND SKINNER [inaudible]
THANK.
I'M SO CENTER ABOUT THEM
[inaudible]
THE WHAT WHERE I'M HAVING OR MS
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S CONFUSED OR
IS [inaudible]
THE I WOULD LIKE YOU I THINK I
WOULD PROBABLY HAVE.
JUMPED OR NOT I WOULD HAVE.
NOT ASSUMED BUT FIGURED THAT.
THE LOCAL ENTITIES WOULD HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT WAS NEEDED
ON THE GROUND IN THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN OUR
BY SCHOOL TYPE PROJECTS NO WOULD
GET A FAIR.
SHAKE THAT WAY VERSES FROM A
STATEWIDE ENTITY.
BUT WE HAVE IN TERMS THE
OPPOSITION TO YOUR BILL WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE.
OPPOSING WHO SEEM TO PREFER THE
STATE WIDE STRUCTURE.
AS WELL AS SOME OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LIKE THE LA COUNTY
DEBT -- DEAD INCLUDE MANY THESE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THIS
IS WHERE I'M HAVING A LITTLE
TROUBLE I'M HAVING TO DISCONNECT.
WELL -- JUST TO BACKGROUND WISE --
THE ATP PROGRAM -- YOU CAN SEE
THE RIVER THE STAFF REPORT CARD
DESCRIBES THE ATP PROGRAM.
IT WAS ORIGINALLY FUNDED -- IS
START THE THE FUNDING WAS
STARTED -- AND THEY FUNDED TO
SIMPLY ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OKAY THAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL.
FUNDING LEVEL FOR THE ATP
PROGRAM.
AND SB ONE PASSED IN SB ONE
ADDED.
A SECOND HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THEN WITH -- DOUBT IN OTHER
FUNDS -- THIS LAST YEAR -- I
THINK THE ALLOCATED TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
SO YOU GET HOW IT.
THIS PROGRAM GREW -- WHEN THE
PROGRAM GREW -- THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
A DECISION THAT [inaudible]
BASICALLY.
ALLOCATED SOME MONEY -- FOR THE
REGIONAL [inaudible]
TRANSPORTATION PLANS THAT ARE
INCLUDING -- WALKWAYS BIKE WAYS
[inaudible]
ALTERNATE TRANSPORTATION.
AND THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE THAT
IN THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLAN. TO REDUCE -- THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH -- SB YOUTH
THREE SEVENTY FIVE OKAY SO THEY
HAVE TO HAVE.
THIS AIR QUALITY ELEMENT BIKE
WAYS PATHWAYS AND SO FORTH IN
ADDITION TO SAY FROM SCHOOL.
SHOULD BE INCLUDED.
SO -- THE REGIONAL PLANS
ACTUALLY HAVE A SPECIFIC.
MANDATE. TO LOOK AT AIR QUALITY
TO LOOK AT OF PLANNING OF
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION TO DO
A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN. TO
COORDINATE WITH THE REGIONAL AIR
QUALITY BOARDS -- AS WELL AS THE
LOCAL COUNTY EACH COUNTY HAS --
CONGESTION MANAGEMENT AGENCY AND
THEY HAVE TO CONTRIBUTE AND DO A
LOCAL PLAN TO DO THE SAME EXACT
THING.
SO I THINK THAT FOR ME -- THE
PLANNING PROCESS IS MORE
STRUCTURED.
IT'S MORE. FIVE SET UP TO MEET
CERTAIN GOALS.
OF ITS -- BY STATUTE BY
LEGISLATIVE STATUTE AS OPPOSED
TO THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION COMING UP WITH A
BUNCH OF CRITERIA WHICH THEY DID.
LIKE.
SEVERAL PAGES LONG.
OF HOW TO ALLOCATE THE FUNDS.
SO THEY CAME UP WITH THIS
CRITERIA THEN THEY CREATED THESE --
TEAMS OF EVALUATORS AND
EVALUATORS WERE VOLUNTEERS AND
THE VOLUNTEERS EVALUATE THE
PROJECTS.
AND THEN THEY CAME UP WITH THE
ALLOCATION OF THE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
SO FOR ME I THINK A MORE
[inaudible]
STRUCTURED PROFESSIONAL --
PUBLIC INPUT WISE -- THE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
PROCESS IS A VERY INVOLVED.
TRANSPARENCY PUBLIC PROCESS
THERE'S A LOT OF DEBATE THERE'S
PLENTY OF MEETINGS WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
AND I THINK THAT'S A MUCH BETTER
WAY OF DOING THIS FOR THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS.
HOWEVER THE THE BILL DOES NOT.
TAKE AWAY ALL THE FUNDS -- FOR
THE STATE IT LEAVES A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF MONEY FOR
THE STATE. TO ALLOCATE TO THE
PROJECTS SIMILAR TO WHAT CENTER
REQUIRES TALKING ABOUT OR OTHER
STATEWIDE.
PROJECTS OR OTHER PROJECTS THAT.
MAYBE HELP BALANCE THE THE
DESIRES OF COMMUNITIES TO HAVE A
LARGER SKILL [inaudible]
LARGER PROJECTS.
SO I I BELIEVE THAT THE SIZE OF
THESE PROJECTS THE PLANNING
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THE REGIONAL
LEVEL.
IS MUCH MORE STRUCTURED MORE.
MORE PUBLIC PROCESS ORIENTED.
MORE PROFESSIONAL.
THEN -- THE PROCESS USE NOW AT
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL SO.
THAT'S WHY I'VE I'VE INTRODUCED
A BILL.
I'M TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH -- THE
GOALS THAT I WANT TO ACCOMPLISH --
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO WORK ON IT
AS YOU CAN SEE THERE'S OTHER
THINGS I HAVE TO WORK ON BUT I
INTEND TO WORK ON I I RECOGNIZE
THAT THESE ARE ISSUES WE HAVE TO
WORK ON SO.
I'M I'M OTHER THAN WHAT WAS SAID
IN THE TESTIMONY -- IT'S YOU
KNOW I DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND
WHY THE DIFFERENT --
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
DISADVANTAGE -- COMMUNITY GROUPS
FUEL THAT THE WOULD APPEAR FEEL
THAT THEY WOULD NOT HAVE IS FEAR
OF A HEARING UNDER THE PROCESS
THAT YOU'RE.
PROPOSING SO I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
JUST EXPRESSED.
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO WORK IN
ABOUT IT I THINK THERE IS A
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OKAY OF
ALL AND CONTINUE TO TALK TO ON
THE CARD IS GOING TO BE A A
PROCESS [inaudible]
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
ARE WELL I'M HAVING -- WELL
FIRST FIGHT AS WELL AS A RESPECT
THE AUTHOR TREMENDOUSLY
ESPECIALLY I KNOW THAT YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OF ONE THOUGHTFUL AS A
PERTAINS TO OUT TRANSPORTATION
BUT I'M HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF
DISCONNECT AS WELL AS SENATOR
SKINNER.
MENTIONED TA IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO REPRESENT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AS WELL AND
AND WE DO HAVE -- QUITE A BIT
AND NEED IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND SO -- AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR THE POINT SINCE EVERYONE
EXPRESSED SOME OF MY CONCERNS
AND DIE I ALSO FEEL THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE WORK IN THAT
AREA AND AND I WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO SEE WE CAN -- SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS BUT AT THIS
MOMENT I I JUST CANNOT GET THERE --
I REALLY WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE
THIS DISCUSSION AND AND SEE HOW
I CAN GET TO YES THANK YOU.
REGARDLESS OF HOW WE COME OUT
HERE ALL THE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
ALL THE MEMBERS IS GOING TO BE --
OF IMPORTANT PROCESS SO TO GET
THIS FINISHED.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAIL I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WANTING TO LIVE.
ASK A QUESTION SO -- YOU MAY
CLOSE -- I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL THE MEMBERS AND
AND BOTH THE OPPOSITION
SUPPORTERS TRY.
TO ACHIEVE.
OF SOME.
FORM OF AN AGREEMENT --
SOMETIMES WE CAN'T PLEASE
EVERYBODY WITH EVERYTHING THEY
WANT BUT AT THE SAME TIME --
SINCE I SPENT FOUR YEARS WORKING
ON SB.
ONE COMING CLOSE TO THAT I MEAN
I THINK IT'S SOME OF USE
SUPPORTING IT BUT THAT'S OKAY --
I'D BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH EVERYBODY AND I THINK THE
RESULTS GOING TO BE -- A STRONG
PROGRAM FOR ALTERNATE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THAT WILL
MEET THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AN ORIGINAL
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAIL -- I ALL
MOVE THE BILL I WANT TO
APPRECIATE.
PUBLICLY YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS TO
BRING IT DOWN TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DECISION MAKING
HAVING SERVED ON THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND IT CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT
IN TERMS OF RECOGNIZING SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT.
ARE THE OPPOSITION IS BROUGHT
FORWARD BECAUSE THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
TO SO -- WITHOUT TO ALL ASKED US
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
PARTY MOVED.
YOU'RE TOO LATE SENATOR.
HELLO.
THE THING ABOUT ONE FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR ABOUT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SAID ABOUT.
WELL I BATES RIGHT BATES AYE
DODD GALGIANI.
MCGUIRE MORALE [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STONE SKINNER AYE STONE STONE I
AMBER.
AMBER I WILL CASKEY BECAUSE HE
AYE [inaudible]
YEAH. SIX ZERO WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN ON THAT ONE SENATOR
BAIL WINDOW WILL MOVE TO YOUR
NEXT BILL.
MEMBERS WHICH MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT EASIER WILL SAY -- MEMBERS
THIS IS SB. TWO ONE ONE OKAY.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE IT CLEAR THE
DRESSING HOMELESSNESS IS A TOP
PRIORITY.
NOW IN EVERY ONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THERE THE PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS AND
CALTRANS.
CURRENTLY HAS AUTHORITY IN A
HANDFUL OF JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
A JUST A SMALL YOU KNOW A FEW
JURISDICTIONS -- TO LEASE.
PROPERTY FOR HOMELESS SHELTER
PROGRAMS AT BELOW MARKET RATE.
THE AUTHORITY GIVES THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES A HELPFUL TOOL TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S SIGNIFICANT
HOMELESS CRISIS.
NOW FOR REFERENCE ALL READ THEM
TO YOU SEE YOU KNOW WHICH ONES
HAVE THIS AUTHORITY OKAY.
SERRA CISCO SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
CITY OF SAN DIEGO SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY O'QUINN'S A LOS ANGELES
AND SAN JOSE -- THAT'S IT.
THE REALITY IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
CAMPING AND SLEEPING IN THESE
PROPERTIES ALREADY ON CALTRANS
PROPERTY IN CALTRANS ACTUALLY.
SPENDS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
EACH YEAR CLEANING OUT CAMPS.
THEY SPENT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
CLEANING OUT CAMPS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY ALONE. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
SO THAT'S NOT A SOLUTION.
CITIES AND COUNTIES NEED TO BE
ABLE TO PARTNER.
WITH CAL TRANS TO COME UP WITH
REAL SOLUTIONS TO CONNECT PEOPLE
WITH HOUSING AND SERVICES.
AND LAST YEAR WE AUTHORED A BILL
THAT GAVE THIS AUTHORITY TO LOS
ANGELES AND SAN JOSE.
THERE THEY MAY HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE THEY MAYMAY HAVE
TAKEN DISADVANTAGED AND ARE
WORKING ON SEVERAL PROJECTS. TO
MEET IMMEDIATE AND PRESSING
NEEDS FOR SHELTER AND SERVICES.
THE TIME IS NOW TO EXTEND THE
SOLUTION TO STATEWIDE.
SO THE OTHER CITIES AND COUNTIES.
HAVE THE OPTION THIS IS AN
OPTIONAL THING. TO LOOK AT THIS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW CALTRANS. TO
LEASE RES REELS PROPERTY TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
IN IT ANYWHERE IN THE STATE FOR
THE PURPOSES OF STASHING
EMERGENCY SHELTER FEEDING
PROGRAM. FOR DOLLAR MONTH.
IT CAPS ADMINISTRATORS FEES AT
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
PROTECTS.
EXISTING AUTHORITY BASED ON PASS
LEGISLATION WE WANT CITIES
ALREADY DOING THIS DEVOID NICK
AND NEW ADMINISTRATIVE OF
HURDLES AND WE HAVE SOME
WITNESSES ALL TURN OVER THE
WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- STEVE CREWS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF A SENATE BILL.
TWO ELEVEN VERY BRIEFLY -- WHEN
I THINK THE SENATOR FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL?
UNLIKE OTHER CITIES -- CENTERS
A. SUFFERS FROM A SEVERE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND EGGS
EXACERBATE ARE HOMELESS PROBLEM.
AS PART OF THE CITY SOLUTION.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MAY
PROVE TO SITES -- FOR WHAT THEY
CALL THEIR BRIDGE -- HOUSING
COMMUNITIES THESE ARE -- TINY
HOMES -- THAT HAVE -- A LIVABLE
SPACE BUT HAVE COMMUNITY
BATHROOMS IN IN KITCHENS AND
COMMUNAL SPACE FOR LEARNING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO IT PROVIDES
A SAFE PLACE -- TYPICALLY THREE
TO SIX MONTHS WHAT WE LOOK FOR
TO TRANSITION THESE FOLKS TO
PERMANENT -- HOUSING -- LAST
YEAR WONDER SB -- FIVE NINETEEN
THAT ALLOW THE THE CITY TO
NEGOTIATE WITH CALTRANS FOR
THESE BELOW MARKET LIKE REESE'S
LEASES ARE -- IS MADE OF THESE
PROJECTS MORE ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE -- FOR THE CITY -- WE
THINK THAT OF HAVE THE SAME
BENEFITS ACROSS THE STATE AND SO
WE REQUEST THE SIR QUESTION
WE'RE SUPPORT -- REQUEST SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CONSOLE HERNANDEZ
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
FOR THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO.
A SIMILAR TO SAN JOSE IN OTHER
CITIES WE'RE FACING A
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS I JUST WANNA
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD MEAN TO THE CITY.
OF WE HAVE COMMITTED TO OPENING
UP EIGHT HUNDRED SHELTER BEDS --
TO HOUSE OUR HOUSE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE OF FOR THE
PAST SIXTEEN MONTHS WE HAVE
OPERATED A LOW BARRIER SHELTER --
THAT HIS HOUSE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE 40% HAVE BEEN RE HOUSING
80% HAVE BEEN CONNECTED TO
MEDICAL SERVICES.
HOWEVER THIS SHELTER IS IN A
PRIVATELY LEAST WAREHOUSE WE
SPEND TWO HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH ON THE
SHELTERING.
AND FORTY THOUSAND ARE I'M SORRY
40% OF THAT SO -- HUNDRED
THOUSAND GOES TO LEASE AND
FACILITY COSTS -- WE'RE LOOKING
TO EXPAND SHELTERS IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE FIND MORE COST EFFECTIVE
LOCATIONS -- EVERY DOLLAR THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO SPEND ON A
LEASE IS MONEY THAT COULD BE
SPEND -- FOR SERVICES ON FOR
HOMELESS PEOPLE WE CURRENTLY ARE
WORKING WITH CALTRANS ON A
POTENTIAL LOCATION -- IN IT YEAH
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED -- THE
LOCATION CURRENTLY IS A DE FACTO
HOMELESSNESS SHELTERS SO WHEN
YOU CREATE AN ACTUAL FACILITY --
IT GETS PEOPLE WHO ALREADY YEAR
THEY'RE OFF THE STREETS IT
CLEANS UP THE AREA IT'S IT'S A
WIN WIN FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED --
SB TWO ELEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
CALTRANS STAFF THE DIRECTION
THEY NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY -- TO
PROVE THIS SITE AND OTHERS
ACROSS THE STATE SO -- THIS IS
WHY WE'RE SUPPORTING IN WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
AND I'VE ALO BEEN ASKED -- TO
RELAY THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES.
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON RUN WE DO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- WE'RE KIND
OF IN AN IN BETWEEN WEAR SUPPORT
FOR MANDATE -- WE'RE LOOKING --
FOR TECHNICAL KERR FOR CATION
THAT.
WOULD ESSENTIALLY REQUIRE
SITTING COUNTY APPROVAL OF THESE.
LEASE AGREEMENTS WHICH WE THINK
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT BUT AND WE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
OBVIOUSLY -- REALLY ADMIRE YOUR
YOUR YOUR CHAMPION -- YOUR YOUR
CAMPING OF THESE ISSUES SO I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER AHS SUPPORT.
ALL THOSE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY.
IN OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE MOVED
OUT [inaudible]
SENATOR STONE.
I WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON
SENATOR BILL -- MEMBERS I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY CALTRANS
SPENDS ON PICKING UP GARBAGE IN
[inaudible]
CLEANING UP.
THE FREEWAYS EXTRA DO THE
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS.
BUT I KNOW I DO KNOW IF IT'S A
IF THEY SPEND.
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
IT MUST BE.
QUITE A BIT OF MONEY.
AND I THINK RATHER THAN SIT BACK
AND SAY IT'S SOMEBODY ELSE'S
RESPONSIBILITY THINK THIS IS A
PROACTIVE WAY OF WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE I REGION I VOTE I THINK
WILL.
HELP PEOPLE IN.
IT'LL BE GOOD -- FOR HOMELESS.
PROGRAMS TO ETTER COORDINATE
WITH THE CALTRANS IN THE OTHER
AGENCIES THANK YOU.
A CALL THE ROLL.
THE SENATE BILL TWO ELEVEN BY
SENATOR ABOUT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES SITES BATES I DON.
DODD AYE GALGIANI MCGUIRE MORALE
ROUGH RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER -- AYE STONE.
STONE I AMBER.
AMBER I WILL COUNTY WE GOT THE
AYE.
SENATOR BILLS YOU'RE HALFWAY
THERE IS A LET'S MOVE ON THIS
WAS EVEN SHORTER.
THE GENDER ITEM NINE SB.
FOUR SIX WE HAD A HEARING ON
MANAGER -- MEMBERS WE HAD A
HEARING ON THE DMV AND AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT HEARING -- I HAVE
A BILL I AM INTRODUCING -- THIS
BILL AND ONE OTHER BILL.
WHICH WILL COME LATER -- THIS
BILL AUTHORIZES BUT IT'S NOT
REQUIRED DMV TO ESTABLISH A TO
YOUR VEHICLE REGISTRATION
PROGRAM.
THIS SHOULD HELP DMV REDUCES
WORKLOAD AS VEHICLE OWNERS WOULD
REGISTER TO VEHICLES LESS OFTEN --
MAKING FEWER VISITS A DMV OF
COURSE THERE'S IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES TO BE CONSIDERED AND I
ASKED THE EMPTY FOR THEIR
THOUGHTS ON THIS SO I GET
RECEIVE RESPONSE ACTUALLY HELLO
[inaudible]
WELL.
WE HAVE THE HEARING.
SEVERAL GROUPS HAVE EXPRESSED --
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT THE IDEA
AND I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM
ON THEIR CONCERNS.
WE WE SHOULD KEEP IN MIND THE
MOTEL YOUR REGISTRATION IDEAS
NOT NEW IS AVAILABLE IN MANY
STATES ACTUALLY AROUND THE
COUNTRY THIS IS QUITE COMMON.
DID YOU CAN REGISTRY VEHICLE FOR
MORE IN ONE YEAR IT'S JUST
SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T DONE HERE.
AND IT'S AVAILABLE -- THE BILL
THE BILL SHOULD BE -- A VEHICLE
FOR OTHER IDEAS IMPROVING
EFFICIENCY A DMV.
I AM WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEES
IDEAS OF FROM ALL MEMBERS --
PROVIDING FOR WHATEVER
LEGISLATION DIRECTION THEY MIGHT
FIND APPROPRIATE THESE IDEAS
COULD MAYBE COME UP IN THE
CONTINUING.
WORK OF THE DIEM THE STRIKE TEAM
WHICH WERE GOING TO GET REPORTS
SIMENON.
AND DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ABOUT THEIR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PLUS
BUDGET REQUEST THROUGH THE DMV
SO.
THOSE OF US THAT HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES OF A BABY WE OUGHT TO
LOOK AT HOW THEY CAN SAVE MONEY
AND GO LET'S TAKE SOME.
LET'S TAKE SOME EFFORT AND TIME
AND LOOK AT EFFICIENCIES SO
URGENT A VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THOSE IN SUPPORT.
STICK IT TO BE PART OF THOSE IN
OPPOSITION.
OUR VAN TO THE COMMITTEE --
SENATOR STONE I THINK YOU WERE
FIRST THANK YOU -- SENATOR BILL
I I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA I
REALLY LIKE IT I JUST.
IS ARE GONNA BE PORTABILITY
WHERE SOMEBODY CAN CHOOSE WHAT
THEY WANT TO GO ONE YEAR TO YEAR
BECAUSE FOR SOME PEOPLE IN MY
CAN YOU KNOW YEAH I THINK THAT'S
GENERALLY THE IDEA OKAY I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE FOR THE RECORD
THAT'S THERE BECAUSE I WANT TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
NOT MY CONCERN IS A SOME MY
LOWER INCOME FOLKS MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO AFFORD TO YEARS ALL AT
ONCE SO YOU REALIZE WE HAVE
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA I MEAN.
IF WE CAN TAKE SOME OF THOSE
VEHICLES SEVERAL MILLION I HOPE.
THAT WE CAN REGISTER FOR MORE IN
ONE YEAR THAT WOULD.
OBVIOUSLY HAVE AN IMPACT CURRENT
AT ALL.
SO THAT'S THE ATTEMPT THANK YOU.
FINISH RUBIO THANK YOU -- I HAD
THE SAME CONCERN AND ONLY
BECAUSE I CONSIDER MY A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT AND I KNOW THAT --
SOMETIMES WHEN DONE IT'S A TWO
YEAR FEE WOULD BE MUCH LARGER
AND SOME FOLKS MAY THINK THEY
CAN.
AFFORD TO PAY TWO YEARS AND
SOMETHING APPENS I KNOW THAT
THE FEES AND FINES CAN BE VERY
STEEP AND I WOULD RATHER NOT PUT
THEM IN THAT KIND OF SITUATION
BUT I LIKE THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO ASK FOR THE ONE OP
TENANTS AND THAT WOULD SCATTER --
ACTUALLY THE REGISTRATIONS AND
PERHAPS HELP BUT DEFINITELY IT'S
A PROBLEM WE NEED TO ADDRESS
COMPLETELY ON BOARD AND DOCILE
THANK YOU FOR ADDRESSING THE OPT
IN.
OPTION -- AND DOUBT.
ANOTHER -- NOT CONCERN BUT I
WANT TO SEE IF YOU CAN SHOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS I KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS THE DMV
STRIKE FORCES AND DO WE KNOW
WHEN THAT IS GOING.
TO COME TO FRUITION AND WHEN WE
EXPECT TO HAVE THAT INFORMATION
AND IS THAT GONNA SHOW A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT YOU DO HERE.
WELL -- WE HOPE TO HAVE IT -- IN
AT LEAST THIRTY DAYS BEFORE WE
START REAL SERVICE BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS AND MY HOPE IS
THAT.
WE GET IT BEFORE WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER THE TWO HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET REQUESTS THAT
THEY'VE MADE OF ME THERE.
AN ANNOUNCEMENT ON NOT SO -- WE
HOPE TO LOOK AT WAYS OF SAVING
MONEY AS WELL AS SPENDING MONEY
OBVIOUSLY -- OUT OF SHEER ISSUE
ABOUT -- SOMEBODY -- IN TERMS OF
AFFORDABILITY.
THERE'S A REASON WHY IF WE GO
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S CREDIT CARD
IDEA WE CAN.
HAVE PEOPLE PAY THE MONTHLY.
NO THAT'S THERE'S OTHER CONCEPTS
THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT.
YOU KNOW MAKE IT JUST MORE
CONVENIENT -- FOR PEOPLE VARIOUS
OPTIONS I THINK.
I THINK WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT THE
FEASIBILITY OF ALL THAT KIND OF
STUFF AND I HOPE TO DO THAT BY --
HAVING THIS BILL GO THROUGH IN.
WORKING WITH MY COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I THINK WHICH IS NOT
GOING AWAY OUR COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO BE DOING WITH THE DMV.
THE SONG AS WE EXIST SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT.
COMMENT.
THANK YOU AND CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU.
ARM.
I THINK THIS COULD WORK VERY
WELL FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT I
THINK THAT. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
COMPLAINTS NOT THINK THIS IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST COMPLAINT SO I
GET -- BEYOND THE WAIT TIMES IS
THE FACT THAT.
THE REGISTRATION BILL SHOWS UP
AND YOU HAVE TO PAY IT ALL AT
ONCE AND FOR MANY PEOPLE THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT.
AVAILABLE CASH -- IN WHEN IN THE
SAY TO ME WELL THERE INSURANCE
THEY CAN PAY MONTHLY.
THERE EVEN YOUR TAXES OR CAN BE
PAID OVERTIME.
YOUR EVER ALMOST EVERY OTHER BIG
EXPENSE YOU HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO PAY OVERTIME.
BUT HERE'S THIS -- ONE EXPENSE
THAT ALMOST EVERY CALIFORNIAN
FACES THAT WE HAVE SET UP TO BE
PAID AT ONCE SO WHEN WE SEE
PEOPLE THAT DON'T REGISTER THEIR
CARS IT'S OFTEN BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T PAY IT ONCE -- NOW YOU
MENTIONED CENTER BUILD THE
GOVERNOR'S YOU KNOW OUR CREDIT
CARD THING BUT I WONDERED IF.
YOU WOULD BE WILLING TO BUILD
INTO THIS BILL.
THAT A TWO YEAR REGISTRATION
WOULD BE ABLE TO BE PAID IN
INSTALLMENTS THAT WAY REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THIS CREDIT CARD
THING HAPPENS OR NOT AT LEAST WE
WOULD HAVE A PROVISION.
FOR THESE -- FOR MONTHLY OR
OTHER PAYMENTS.
BECAUSE THEN IT WOULD BE CREATES
LESS OF A HARDSHIP FOR FOR AYE
AYE I'M WILLING TO LOOK AT ALL
THOSE IDEAS -- AND I THINK THEY
ARE MY BILL IS SIMPLY TO HAVE
THEM EXPLORE THE SUB RIGHT SO
YES -- AND LET'S PUT THAT IN.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK THE CREDIT
CARD IDEA OF JUST PUTTING ON
YOUR CREDIT CARD -- DOES IT
BECAUSE IT MINISTRY TO HOUSES
FOR DMV I DON'T KNOW LET'S FIND
OUT RIGHT -- LET'S SEE HOW WE
CAN GO ABOUT DOING IT WITHOUT --
IMPEDING DMV.
FOR DOING THEIR JOB I THINK.
I THINK TO ALL THOSE IDEAS ARE
GOOD THERE'S OTHER IDEAS --
PEOPLE HAVE LIKE.
WHEN YOU DO YOUR -- SMOG CHECK
YOU CAN PAY YOUR DMV FEES AT THE
SAME TIME LIKE IN ABOUT -- THE
THE WALK AND YOU DRIVE A CAR IN
A SMOG CHECK STATION.
AND THEN YOU GET YOUR SMOG CHECK
YOU GET THE CERTIFICATION.
IN NEVADA AND THEN THE GUY SAYS
SO YOU WANT TO PAY YOUR DMV SIR.
THANKS AND YOU MIGHT SAY YEAH
COURSE IN AND SO HE ADDS IT TO
THE SMOG CHECK BILL GOES ON A
CREDIT CARD.
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND
OF THOSE KIND OF IDEAS -- I
THINK ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD LOOK AT IT
THERE'S OTHER AYE AYE THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN OTHER
STATES -- I KNOW THAT WE ARE
LIMITED BY OUR TECHNOLOGY A DMV.
WE CERTAINLY THAT HAVE A LOT OF
ARM SO WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THAT OR COME THAT ISSUE IF WE
WERE ALLOWING FOR PAYMENT OVER
TIME CERTAINLY THE DMV COULD
ALLOW ANOTHER ONE OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES THAT ARE ALREADY SET UP.
FOR SUCH PAYMENTS TO ADMINISTER
THAT PAYMENT BUT WHAT I THINK
WHAT ONE OF OUR OBJECTIVES IS IS
TO HAVE.
THE DMV BEAM A MUCH MORE
CONSUMER FRIENDLY ANTI.
THOUGH THIS IS A HOLLOW ALL
THEIR IDEAS A COMMITTEES TALK
ABOUT THESE ARE ALL I DO IS I
WANT TO SEE HAPPEN I'M AND I'M
PUTS THOSE EXPLORE EVERYTHING.
WE SHOULD BE BROADENED OUR
EXPLORATION -- SO.
BUT MY POINT IS LET'S LOOK AT
ALL THIS STUFF AND HAVE DIEM BE
COME UP WITH SOME EFFICIENCIES
AND COST SAVINGS AND WAYS TO
MAKE IT MORE CONVENIENT FOR THE
CONSUMER RATHER AND STANDING IN
LINE OR YOU KNOW ALL THAT KIND
OF STUFF SO I THINK -- IF YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT IT
THE RIGHT WAY I THINK WITH THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR NO OTHER
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM NOT
SENATOR STONE.
SECRETARY MAY CALL THE ROLL.
THE SENATE BILL FOR SIXTY BY
SENATOR BELL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES RIGHT BATES AYE
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE ROSS
ROSS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STONE.
STONE AYE AMBERG WHO CASKEY
[inaudible]
THE I. [inaudible]
LAST.
OKAY NINE TWO ZERO NINE DIED WE
NEED TO CALL THE ROLL UP AND YES --
LAST BILL SENATOR -- OF SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION.
FIVE I'M PROUD TO PRESENT THIS --
THE BILL URGES CONGRESS AND
PRESENT A UNITED STATES TO
MOVING MORE MOVE AND MOVE
QUICKLY ON INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING AND LEGISLATION -- FOR
YEARS REGARDING -- REGARDLESS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT WE'VE.
SEEN INTERESTED IN -- FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL OR PROGRAM --
EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT IT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. FOR SUCH AN
ENDEAVOR ENDEAVOR.
BUT IT BOGGLES THE MIND OF MANY
AMERICANS AROUND THE COUNTRY
WIDE NATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INITIATIVE HASN'T COME TO
FRUITION.
AND WITH THE BACKING OF GROUPS
OF SUCH AS THE US CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND IT FEELS AYE CHAU
THE TRUCKER'S.
OTHER GROUPS -- IT SHOWS BROAD
SUPPORT HAS BEEN IN MOTION DC
BUT YET STILL NOTHING OUT -- WE
AMERICANS NEED TO MAKE CONGRESS --
AND THE PRESIDENT'S -- GET GOING
AND PASS LEGISLATION ON THIS
CALIFORNIA.
HAS TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE MANY STATES.
WERE AGING ANSWERS NEEDS REPAIR
AND WE KNOW WE HAVE A
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR BACKLOG.
WE HAVE WORKED HARD TO GET OUR
FUNDING -- LOCALLY AND STATEWIDE --
BY ALL THE TAXES AND INCREASES
BUT WE BUT THIS THE EFFORT NEEDS
TO HAVE OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS
STEP UP TO THE PLATE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND WE NEED TO INCREASE
INVESTMENT -- ANOTHER ISSUE IS
FOR THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
WE'RE A GATEWAY TO INTERNATIONAL
TRADE.
AND WE NEED TO INVEST IN OUR
PORTS.
AND ENSURE EFFICIENT DELIVERY OF
THE TWO POINT EIGHT TRILLION.
DOLLARS IN GOODS THAT FLOW
THROUGH CALIFORNIA.
ANNUALLY AND WE NEED TO HAVE.
OUR SB ONE FUNDS IN OTHER FUNDS.
ARE USED TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDS AND WE'RE READY TO DO THAT
SO I HEARD JULY VOTE ON THIS AND
URGED CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENT.
TO PROVIDE -- INFRASTRUCTURE RE
FORCES TO CALIFORNIA AND ALL THE
OTHER STATES WITHOUT DELAY
SERGEANT VS ON THIS RESOLUTION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAIL OF THOSE
IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
OF SECRETARY CULTURAL THIS IS
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FIVE BY
SENATOR BELL THE MOTION AS BE
ADOPTED.
CENTER ABOUT.
I BATES NO FAITH NO DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE.
NO ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE.
STONE NO I'M BURKE.
WHAT CASTING?
WE CAN SEE AYE [inaudible]
SENATE [inaudible]
JERRY [inaudible] SEVENTY THREE
SEVENTY THREE OF THE ROLE IF
OPEN AND I'LL GIVE THAT TO
SENATOR ABOUT -- WE WE WOULD
LIKE ALL ABSENT MEMBERS TO
COMMON CANCER VOTES AND WILL.
LIVE TO CALL ON THE BILLS SO.
THE SERVER THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS THREE TEN
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I
CENTER MCGUIRE.
MORALE.
MORALE AYE ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
AMBERG.
WHEN I GO TO TO THE SHOP TEN
VOTES IN FAVOR -- MOTION CARRIES.
TEN VOTES IN FAVOR.
WE CALL THE BILL WILL ANNOUNCE
THE VOTE THE PREVIOUS VOTE SIR.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WHEN?
NOW ON THE LIST.
SENATE BILL SEVEN BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS [inaudible]
SEVEN TO ZERO SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MORALES.
MORALE NO ROSS.
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
AMBERG. NINE THIS ITEM ONE AT
ONE POINT. ONE THE BILL
[inaudible]
YEAH. NINE VOTES IN FAVOR ONE
FOR POST.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE BY
SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
CURRENT VOTE IS [inaudible]
EIGHT ZERO CENTER MCGUIRE.
MORALE.
MORRELL NO ROSS ROTH AYE STONE.
NINE TWO ONE THERE HAS NINE
VOTES IN FAVOR.
MOTION CARRIES.
THIS IS SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY
TWO BY SENATOR PELL MOTION IS DO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT -- IT'S SIX ZERO CENTER
DAUGHTER.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE.
MORALE MORALE NO ROTH ROTH AYE
RUBIO. TWO ONE THOUSAND NINE
VOTES IN FAVOR OF THE LEAVE THE
ROAD OPEN DROPS OF MEMBERS.
THIS IS SENATE BILL TWO ELEVEN
BY SENATOR BELL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS.
EIGHT ZERO GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE.
MORALE.
MORRELL AYE ROSS ROSS HI. ELEVEN
TWO ZERO HOME. ELEVEN THAT HAS
ELEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR.
THE SENATE BILL THREE FORTY BY
SENATOR STONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE THE CURRENT BEAU IS.
TWO TO FOUR SENATOR DODD.
DODD NO MORALE.
MORRELL FIVE ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
AMBERG.
AMBERG KNOW WHAT COUNTY WE ASK
YOU KNOW.
WHEN THE INTERNAL?
CHOOSE ENTER NOW. THREE IN FAVOR.
THREE VOTES IN FAVOR IT OPPOSE
[inaudible]
YEAH. THREE VOTES IN FAVOR.
YOUR CONFERENCE.
WITH [inaudible]
WE CONSIDER [inaudible]
RECONSIDERATION GRANITE
[inaudible]
SENATE BILL. THREE SEVENTY ONE
BY SENATOR CAFIERO THE MOTION AS
YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION CURRENT
BEAU IS.
TO TO TO CENTER BATES
[inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DODD I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
SKINNER I NUMBER.
FIVE NUMBER. SEVEN SEVEN VOTES
IN FAVOR THREE OPPOSE.
THE SENATE BILL FOUR OH TWO BY
SENATOR BURGESS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER CURRENT VOTE IS.
SIX ZERO SENATOR GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER NO AMBER.
AMBER I WILL COUNTY BECAUSE YOU
KNOW. NINETY NINE VOTES IN FAVOR
TO THE POST.
SENATE BILL FOR SIXTY BY SENATOR
PELL MOTIONS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT BEAU IS.
NINE ZERO CENTER MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MORALE.
NUMBER NINE NUMBER I CAN IS
THERE. TO VOTE IN FAVOR.
NO OPPOSE WITH THE SENATE BILL
FIVE TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR ALLEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING.
CURRENT VOTE IS.
SIX TWO THREE SENATOR GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE. EIGHT TWO THREE THE
THIS ISN'T ABOUT SIX TWENTY FIVE
BY SENATOR HELD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AN REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATION.
CURRENT BEAU IS [inaudible]
SEVEN ZERO CENTER MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
NUMBER.
NUMBER I WILL COST ME WITHOUT
SKI I YEAH LEVIN VOTED IN FAVOR
[inaudible] FIVE JUST.
ONE WITH OVER.
ONE YEAH.
THIS IS SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION
FIVE BY SENATOR PELL THE MOTION
IS BE ADOPTED CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVENTY THREE CENTER MCGUIRE.
NUMBER FIVE NUMBER I THREE EIGHT
VOTES IN FAVOR THAT'S A WAITING
FOR ME.
OKAY -- I THINK EVERYBODY'S
VOTERS EXCEPT FOR CENTER REQUIRE
ROLE WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR
SENATOR. FOR A FEW MINUTES.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY THANK YOU
EVERYBODY.
WE OPEN THE ROLE FRISBEES.
WE CAN OPEN THE ROLE FOR SB
SEVEN THE AND THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS IS SENATE BILL
SEVEN BY SENATOR PORTANTINO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
NUMBER NINE NUMBER I MY TEN TEN
TO ONE AND CHECK OUT ON THE
GOVERNMENT.
WELL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTING OF FILE ITEMS THREE
TEN THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN CENTER MCGUIRE.
AMBERG.
I'M BURKE I ELEVEN TWO ZERO
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY
THIS IS SENATE BILL SEVEN
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. ELEVEN VOTES IN
FAVOR ONE OPPOSE.
SENATE BILL FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
CENTER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. TEN VOTES IN FAVOR
ONE OF CLOSED.
THIS IS SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY
TWO BY SENATOR BELL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I STAND ONE IN THOSE IN
FAVOR ONE OF THOSE.
THIS IS THE BIL TO ELEVEN BY
SENATOR BELL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. TWO ZERO TWELVE TO
ZERO MOTION PASSES THIS IS AN
ABOUT THREE FORTY BY SENATOR
STONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
CENTER QUITE [inaudible] THREE
THE PHARMACIST THREE VOTES IN
FAVOR AIDS OPPOSED.
CENTER STONE REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION.
THIS IS SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR CUT BY
OUR OWN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION CENTER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. EIGHT THREE INFLOWS
IN FAVOR THREE TO CLOSE.
THIS ISN'T A BILL -- FOR TO BY
SENATOR BARGES THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
ON WATER SENATE REQUIRE.
MCGUIRE I TEND.
TO TO THOSE IN FAVOR TO OPPOSE
IS THE SENATE BILL FOR SIXTY BY
SENATOR BELL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE MANY ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE LIMóN TO ZERO
LIMóN ZERO MOTION CARRIES.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY
SIX BY SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
CENTER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE NINETY THREE NINE
VOTES IN FAVOR THREE OPPOSED
MOTION KERR'S SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR HEALTH
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS CENTER MCGUIRE --
HI MCGUIRE HI [inaudible]
TWELVE ZERO POSTED FAVOR.
ON OPPOSED MOTION PASSES SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION FIVE BY SENATOR
BELT THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE THREE NINE BILLS IN FAVOR
THREE OPPOSED MOTION CARRIES.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS THREE TEN
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN
SENATE MCGUIRE.
WHY ARE AYE?
TWELVE TWO ZERO IT'S A GROWER
PROVEN TOWARDS HER VOTE.
AND THANK YOU EVERYBODY THE
MEETING OF THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEES.
YOU GUYS ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR NOSE
THANK YOU WORK